Look, I have a perfectly good excuse for this.
I was on a five-game loss streak on my four rivals.
And I was like, maybe I can try one more game.
And then I have 20 minutes left.
Maybe I can try one more game.
You can never end on a loss, guys.
You can never end on a loss.
So I was just like, maybe I'm on a five game last streak.
There's no way I'll lose a sixth game.
There's no fucking way.
And then, oh my God.
Okay, I need to show you this.
On my very first game, I got a VTuber on my team.
And I got a French VTuber on my team.
You'd be like, what does being French have to do with
whatever?
Okay, no, I will show you.
There is a perfectly good reason why I have to be very
specific on this.
Okay, let me save this.
Okay, my first game of the day, this guy started, by the
way, his name is a T.
TV name too so like you know It's gonna go so well so And he
would but the best part he was a TV name and he was off
stream So I was just like okay Why is he like okay he
started Shit talking everyone like Okay I'll show you guys
um I think It was this image um He started He started Shit
talking Everyone and he was like What the fuck is this DPS
Please uh you're garbage and we're like bro chill chill the
game just started chill we were like well xcc's he's
canadian he's french canadian he's quebec quad this one was
actual french french so so this guy was like what the fuck
is this like he started raging like automatically after we
lost our first fight so i was like what the fuck is going on
like please bear in mind i was playing with a pro player the
fuck and then i checked his okay i would okay and then he's
like g go next gg and we lost our first fight i was like bro
we just it's only one fight it was um he was calling for tps
guard and then he started calling everyone garbage he
started calling the tanks garbage he started called DPS
Garage but oh he was the one that was performing the best
apparently so I was like bro like bro what the fuck I was
like bro and then like if you look him up he's a vtuber so I
was like bro don't give vtubers a bad name right now there's
a there's a war going on like we don't need this shit like
so I chimed in and I was like I was like how are you a
vtuber So I chimed in and I was like, how are you a VTV?
Because obviously, like, I'm in this game.
And then he's like, how are you useless?
And he's like, yeah, I'm done.
GG, how are you useless?
And then, and I'm like, Mal, you ain't making a kid.
Because at that point, I was like, bro, like, you're like
just fucking firing random shots everywhere.
Like, he was just insulting everyone.
And then I was just like, at least I know how to play.
And then I checked his profile.
I checked his Twitch profile.
Or like his, okay, I did that too.
But I also checked his, because you know, I'm a fucking
petty person.
I'm a fucking petty person.
So I checked his rivals account because it's like not
private.
And he was Peak Celestio 1.
And I was like, bro, don't speak.
He speaks unless don't fucking speak and I looked at his
twitch user profile And he's like don't be toxic.
We're all here to have fun I just want to make you laugh and
then he said this shit and I was like bro What the fuck?
Oh, yeah, you'd see this shit offline thinking nobody's
gonna fucking call you out like Literally smirked his feet
guy like like the it's like those people hate and they're
the ones like fucking spreading hate like like it's so
fucking fake and then yes oh my god it's like it's so
fucking fake like literally like don't don't spread hate no
trolling don't be rude have fun no toxicity please I'm just
here to spread laughter and I'm like like and then literally
the first thing he said in this game first game by the way
started fucking bullets at all our teammates like oh don't
spread hate only i can spread hate like hypocrite as fuck by
the way like do as i say not as i do and like it sucked
because he was like a vtuber too so like obviously it makes
us look bad that's why i was like how are you a vtuber
because i was like what the fuck are you doing so like i was
like bro what the fuck you're all you're doing is just
making us look bad you fucking useless piece of shit like
yeah oh but don't spread yeah but don't don't harass him by
the way don't don't go harass this guy this guy's a fucking
loser um like i said you ain't making a kid like yeah
setting hurt people back just don't like stoop to his level
i had to call him out because like He thought there was no
consequences to his actions because he thought he was like,
there's no other streamer here.
The fact that he didn't know who I was as a VTuber, I'm just
like, that's on you.
Like, that's on you.
Yeah, so like, it was fucking great.
That was my first, I wish I was streaming this, by the way.
I wish I was streaming this.
This was my very first game.
And then, okay, bro, very humble.
I was going to keep varying.
Look, he was like shit talking everyone on our team.
The thing is, I was the only one typing back.
Everyone was just like calling him out in BC because
everyone else had BC.
I was too lazy to talk at that time because I was just like,
I'll just do, at first I was like, I'll just do two or three
games and I'm going to go, I'm just going to go like chill
after that.
And then I end up playing five, six games because I lost
five games in a row.
Like, maybe if I keep going, I'll eventually win one game.
So, yeah, the first game was a fucking omen.
And then it progressed.
And then on my, I think on my fourth game, I got a girl who
would say, who was like, I don't know how she's back, but
she's like, she was like, I'm banned on.
Apparently she made a new Twitch account and a new Twitter
account.
But like I had my team was throwing because one of our
teammates on our team is like super homophobic Super racist
and also super transphobic because she said all the words
She like in the past she used to say she said all the slurs
like all the gamer slurs back then So like like people on my
team were like yeah We're not fucking gonna win this like
like I we have this girl on our team and after we everyone
was like talking about being like, wait, aren't you that
girl that's like, that said like all these slurs?
Because there's like proof of her saying all these slurs,
saying like all the gamer slurs.
And that the whole vocabulary, yeah, all of them.
That's what I'm saying.
She was super racist, super homophobic, and super
transphobic.
She literally said everything.
And she's still trying to make a career.
Like she literally got her Twitch fan at one point.
I remembered.
and yeah the whole dictionary and and then like um and then
so like my team didn't want to try so obviously that's
another loss in the belt uh and then after everyone said
that to her she was like she was like here's my twitch
follow me in chat
he was like i was like bro Diamond, please, bro.
Diamond, please just drops her plug.
She, like, yeah, respect that.
She just starts plugging herself.
We lost, too.
We actually, like, shameless.
Like, we lost, and then, like, there was a reason why we
lost.
And then she plugged herself afterwards.
I'm like, what the fuck?
It's just, like, it's just, like, what's the word?
so like no no what's the word no like social cues whatsoever
like any exposure is exposure yeah yeah girl read the room
girl read the room yeah um and then and then i had my last
game where i was like i'll do one more game i have 20
minutes i didn't think it would be that fucking long by the
way but we had so many overtime pushes that it took the game
lasted like 20 plus minutes it lasted 20 to 25 minutes and
which i didn't expect because i was like we have like you
know i had it was like um 440 and i was just like i have
like so much time like we're gonna finish this game by then
and i was like you know we can't end on the loss you know
can never end on a loss So I was just like, yeah, all that
for a fucking, okay, so we had no support players other than
me and um Our guy was on rocket and like you didn't know he
was clueless he literally he even rocket is like the
character where You don't need hands and you still play
rocket, but he was so fucking clueless because he had zero
brain because um because the rocket kept asking um our dps
players when she should so he held his rock we were getting
dived on by everything it was hard dive like daredevil venom
iron fist like all fucking grabbing on to me and the rocket
and then i was just like oh my god you're all right and then
he's like let me know when to all like yelling at our dps
let me know when to all and he held it we were getting
fucking like harassed and touched and he still held it and
then we all died and then he was like okay and was but then
like me and the rocket we died but then the rest of the team
still live for some fucking reason and then the second time
it happened again but before the dive um he was like asking
our dps like oh let me know when to all just let me know um
i have uh which of course he had because he's been holding
that shit forever and then it happened again.
They fucking Thor, Venom, Iron Fist, Derodouble, fucking
went straight to us.
Like, there was no hope.
And then he still didn't halt.
He still held it.
Because he heard no reply.
Because our DPS players didn't respond to him.
So he's like, well, if I didn't hear an answer, I shouldn't
at all.
Because I have no free will.
I'm just a rocket player.
I was like How the fuck are you still holding it Like that
Five, four out of the six players On the enemy team
Literally ran into us And yet you just, you're like We'll
live Like actual sheep behavior He's like Don't worry guys
We'll live Yeah And then And then he started flaming our
tanks Because he thinks our tanks was the problem.
Maybe they were.
But you were also part of the problem.
He tried to like defer the blame.
Being like, oh it's not my fault.
Is there tanks?
Our tanks didn't know how to play tank.
Yeah, he started flaming our tanks because of all of this.
And I'm like, bro, I saw you.
Hold your ult for at least two fights.
You have no right to say anything.
it was anyone but himself yeah it was crazy um so yeah those
were those were my six games um I won you can know the crazy
part the game where this happened um the game we won that
game we the game where this happened we actually won I don't
know how the fuck that was the worst start it and then after
that I lost five six games in a row right after that I like
he kept trying to force us to surrender this guy kept voting
for surrender he kept fucking voting for surrender and none
of us surrendered and we we won I don't fucking know how I I
don't know how we did it so I lost six out of the seven
games yeah yeah I used up all my luck just to try and pull
up a win Anyway, so that was my Marvel Rivals journey, and
that was why I was 10 minutes late.
I never give up until the sixth loss.
So that was why I was late.
Other thing, I watched FNAF 2.
I finally watched FNAF 2.
I don't remember which day it was.
All these days are like blurring together.
as someone that has watched finaf one their members members
it doesn't mean you're safe by the way guys we're still
gonna watch that in the member stream one day um you're like
oh thank god that means we don't have to no no no no no no
no don't worry it'll still be a member stream in the future
but i just had to check it out because like people were like
no it is better than the first movie because the first movie
was an experience it really was like not the greatest but i
will say is an improvement to the first movie it has a lot
less plot holes but I will say um the second movie was
definitely made for fans because like I swear to God every
other scene or every okay yeah every other scene was like
look at this oh my god this was in FNAF oh my this was also
in FNAF FNAF, guys, remember this reference?
Oh, remember this reference, guys.
Oh, whoa.
It was literally that.
It was like nostalgia, but it was so many were like, oh, my
God, guys.
You see that?
That was also in FNAF, guys.
Oh, my God, and that too.
Oh, my God, that was also in the game.
Do you remember that in the game?
It was, like, it was literally that.
It was that type of movie.
And,
Blah-holes this time because the first movie I was so fucked
there was so many like really confusing parts in there I was
like this doesn't mix but the second movie they sort of
fixed that Yeah, did you see it?
Did you see that reference we did?
Oh my god Did you see the music box remember the music box
when she turns the music box and the marionette won't show
up?
Do you remember that?
Um, oh my god, it's that it's the music box.
Oh my god, it's the mask from FNAF 2 remember that?
Remember how, like, you wear the mask and they won't kill
you?
Do you remember that, guys?
That was in the game, too.
Oh, I remember.
And, oh, my God, did you see the baby animatronic in the
dream?
That's not till FNAF 5 or some shit.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I was asking my friend, because I was, like,
telling my friend, I watched FNAF, and they're like, oh, did
you see the baby animatronic?
Do you know what game that's from?
And I'm like, I don't know, FNAF 3, FNAF 4.
or some shit and then my friend was like no but now five and
i was like jesus fucking christ how many games i don't know
what i was like jesus fucking christ how many games does
benab have i was just like five and then my friend was like
there was five but now it's like it was like six i'm like
jesus i was like there's no but like from the main series
there's like six right it's either six seven ah six seven uh
yeah but um there's like six of them and i was just like i
don't i don't know how i can i can't believe there's six of
them um so that was basically for now too but the craziest
part i wanted to buy a popcorn bucket because like um i
thought figured like you know i low-key started wanting to
collect popcorn buckets right yeah i'm part they got me ever
since the zootopia popcorn bucket i they got me i understand
now like they got another one uh please do not collect this
um anyway but only for like the ones that i thought the
designs are really interesting so um so i saw the popcorn
bucket for fanab um during like zootopia they put it out
being like coming soon So I was like, oh, okay, I really
want to buy the FNAF one because it's really funny.
It's really funny looking.
So I, like, went over there.
Like, you know, I went to the theater and I was like, where
are the popcorn buckets for FNAF?
There's one for Avatar.
There's one for still ones for Zootopia.
Zootopia ones are still around with the snake.
And then still, there was still the ones for, like, Wicked
and, like, all that other shit.
And, like, Tron 2, Tron Ares, rest in peace.
And so I was really confused because I was like, oh, what
happened?
So then I asked one of the movie guys, and they're like, oh
yeah, they're all sold out.
I'm like, what?
Like, how?
Like, the Zootopia ones are still here.
And they're like, oh yeah, no, we sold out on the first
couple of days.
I'm like, what the fuck?
I was just like, the movie came out like a week and a half
ago.
How the fuck is it all sold out?
So then I looked it.
I was so confused.
So I looked it up online.
They're getting scalped.
No, they're getting, you know how much they cost right now?
Like all of the FNAF movie buckets.
They cost 250 American dollars for a FNAF popcorn bucket.
And you, the retail price is like $50.
And I was like, what the?
I was like, are you guys serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Also, Alan, I think in the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Here, my out, Doki, official Doki vs.
Dragon Popcorn buckets, please.
That shit's gotta be expensive.
I would have to, I would have to kickstart that, guys.
I, I can't, I can't do these wild ideas if there's not.
I would actually have to run kickstart fundos.
Because like the mold itself is gonna be very fucking
expensive.
No, I'll show you guys.
bucket I was actually looking it up because I was like how
the fuck are they sold out I was so fucking confused um but
no look at this uh wait where is it fnaf popcorn oh someone
already bought the cheap one before it before the prices got
up before the prices hit them uh fnaf popcorn but Jesus
there's one that's worth 300 by eBay well look at eBay I'll
show you guys the eBay one out of stock oh god it got it got
more expensive in two days guys in two days in six people's
cards are you serious?
Oh six other people are more crazy than me these are six
people that have in their cart right now that's actually
insane um it rate oh my got it got it's a hundred dollars
more expensive right now it's actually a hundred dollars
more expensive all right here you go there you go uh this is
now 324 us dollars for a fnapp popcorn bucket that's what
i'm saying i was like are you fucking kidding me what do you
mean the three at first i was looking shocked at 250 now
it's a hundred dollar in two days i think it was like two to
three days it got like um they sold eight of them oh my god
this is the last one by the way if you see the quantity they
sold eight of them they actually sold eight of them like
jesus okay um Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome.
Simple-minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Speaking of Zootopia, did you hear the snake characters
gotten so popular in China?
People are starting to buy them as pets.
Thank you.
I'm actually so surprised because, like, when the movie came
out, people were not fanning over Gary the snake.
It was fucking Popper because Popper was, like, on
everyone's, like, radars.
Like, he had so much fucking merch made of him.
Gary the snake it was crazy um so I'm very surprised that he
ended up getting popular uh because Utopia did not care
about him like they're like he is not merchandisable like oh
my god no I saw the avatar popcorn bucket and just I'm just
like how do you hold that like oh my god I need to show you
guys the avatar popcorn bucket because I was like I they had
the avatar popcorn bucket out and i was looking at it and i
was like bro that's cool that's like cool but also like that
is not holding a lot not only is it not holding a lot of
popcorn but like how the fuck do you hold i was so confused
um where is it oh i didn't bookmark it okay wait i thought i
did avatar popcorn bucket i saw there here you go like This
is not a lot of...
It's cool, I will say.
I'm not a fan of Avatar, Fire, and Ash.
No, of course, there's not a lot.
Do you know, okay, do you know the reason why Avatar the
Last Airbender, they have to put the Last Airbender down
there?
It's because James Cameron copyright trademarked Avatar.
So Avatar the Last Airbender cannot use anything with just
Avatar because of it.
They always have to have a little subtitle.
Or else James Cameron's gonna fucking get him.
blue avatar they trademark avatar first so they got to they
got to claim it um anyway but yeah no this is a like i was
like bro that's sick but also like that's not a lot of
popcorn i think that's like also like how to fuck the old
imagine holding this while you're watching a movie that's
like so obtrusive like it's not it is not comfortable at
yeah it's not comfortable or practical at all.
That's actually, like, what the fuck is that?
But it looks cool.
I will say it looks fucking cool.
It looks sick.
I still can't believe.
You can actually get the Avatar popcorn bucket, but you
can't get the Phanat one.
Joki, do you want the Phanat 2 Freddy Head popcorn bucket?
It's a Freddy Fast Bear Head as a popcorn bucket.
Yumi, thank you for that.
in the super chat thank you thank you how much is it oh my
god you get it on walmart okay at least like that's all
right you get okay is it okay good okay i will say what the
fuck how the fuck do you stick your hand looking at it bro
that's a tiny asshole for the popcorn that is not
comfortable at all so what this what this dragoon is saying
is that there i'll show you guys the picture of bucket so
this you can get it you can get it wherever you wherever in
retail because they're not like exclusive or anything at the
movie theaters but how the like yeah you can i guess that is
so uncomfortable i will have to say sticking your hand in
that hole for popcorn seems incredibly uncomfortable it does
not look great it's one of those videos where they cut hold
the bottom of the freddy head well thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you oh yeah this this one shows that
like it's definitely apparently like the eyes light up or
some shit too right or oh wait no it's just removable oh the
mask is removed oh wait no the eyes love what the fuck how
do i wash this you can't even like you can't even dishwasher
it's Not even dishwash safe.
You hand wash this shit.
Because there's electronics.
There's fucking electronics in this fucking popcorn bucket.
Because the eyes light up.
Now is that the bite of 69?
Or...
You don't.
But it's for...
How am I supposed to wash a popcorn bucket?
Like it's one use only, apparently.
Don't...
Yeah, don't get...
don't use a popcorn bucket dokey you put it on display do
you know nothing about popcorn buckets dokey it's a
collector's item we don't spend 60 american dollars to use
something speaking of spending money um i heard the shit
about i don't know okay you guys might not know this about
anything about this because it's a luxury brand um But I
also didn't know anything about it.
But like, it popped up on my Twitter feed about Hermes.
What is it called?
Hermes Birkin bags.
And I was so apparently.
Okay, so the luxury item about these specific bags is that
it's very hard right now to get a Birkin bag.
And I was like, and like all the super rich people are
trying to get it right now.
But you have to be on a wait list.
and you have to purchase an X amount of bags to get onto the
waitlist.
So you have to purchase X amount of money equivalent to that
Birkin bag to get on the waitlist.
And the waitlist is like two years.
You have to wait like two plus years to even get your turn
to be called up on the waitlist.
So I was like, Okay, um, how expensive is a Birkin bag?
I looked it up.
$450,000.
It's
like, what the fuck?
I was just like, I don't, what?
I don't, but that's like, but the thing is, that's like the
middle ground.
That's, it, it ranges from 20, that's what Crocs, though
that's with crocodile skin a normal Birkin bag is like the
one that's like not as a bougie is like 30,000 dollars the
normal ones that aren't like crocodile skin $20,000 that's a
freaking I know it's like $4,000 and pre-owned by the way I
need to let you guys know that is a pre-owned bag 20k for a
pre-owned bag yeah pre-owned and so I was like holy fuck
like this is manufactured scarcity too because they're
purposely making them so fucking rare so they can have make
them as expensive as they want because rich people are like
you know all the rich people's wives are like i must have it
it's the saddest simple if i don't have it all the other
wives are gonna make fun of me saying i'm not rich enough or
don't have enough power to be part of the group you know so
they're like i must have it so they get on the way or they
buy the pre-owned bag but like but apparently for buying
pre-owned bags is like a crime for them um they don't stoop
to that level apparently um i was like how long does to make
a fucking bag like yeah they control the it's crazy um um
but the fact that there's a pre-spend requirement to even
like get on the fucking wait list you have to spend the
equivalent of a fuck the bag you want to be able to get on
that like waiting list like what the fuck do you buy yeah
the phenam the pre-requisite is crazy no i was watching this
video um like i was watching this one because i was like
this girl was like you can't do this like you have to get on
the way this and this guy was like i am willing to give you
money like he was like i will buy seven bags right now if
you let me get a birkenbag please i swear my wife for
christmas she really wants for christmas i will spend the
equivalent of seven bags if i can get this bag for my wife
and she's like i'm sorry i'm sorry sir you have to get on
the wait list like it doesn't matter if you want to spend
money right now you have to get on the wait list and there's
a two-year wait right now like i'm really sorry he's like
please i will pay you in cash for seven bags and she's like
i'm sorry sir everyone is on the wait list for for this so
like i can't just put you in the front like and then you're
like if you check other stories they're the same way you can
try go home to this store you're still gonna be on the
waitlist just buy her a card bro like i don't wait i love
this i love this i love this comment rich people are so
bored they need a makeup fake side quest that's so funny
That's like the Hermie, Hermie situation right now.
Like, I know, right?
The man is like, I will buy seven bags worth of them.
I'll pay you in seven bags if I can get the Birkin bag.
That is actually true.
I didn't have, like, that's fucking wild.
Like, I'm like, why?
They just have, like, no time.
Like, they just are so fucking bored now.
I love this.
How can I waste the most money on the most worthless things?
I'll buy America to get this back.
We were lamenting about for that popcorn bucket being $350
right now.
And then these days, people are buying like 20, not even 20,
it has to be more expensive.
Because 20K is a pre-owned, it's not even that big.
I was like, okay, how big is this bag?
like I was thinking like okay how big is a Birkin bag it's
not even it can't even hold a laptop why the fuck am I
spending 20 grand on a bag that can't even hold a goddamn
laptop like maybe an iPad I will say maybe it's not about
the size like yeah that bag it's a fucking small even why i
need about the function yeah i can't even hold a small how
would i fit a chihuahua in this bag how why is there a lock
that lock is not locking anything i will say i'm i think a
lock is actually um aesthetic because like it's not locking
anything it's just locking the piece of fabric for fucking
no reason that lock better be made of goddamn diamond if
it's 20k pre-owned i think the real bag is like 50k or some
shit all right berkin bag price new all right let's see okay
35 grand okay all right yes 35 grand the bag is more
expensive than the But yeah, anyway, so that's really what I
want to talk about today, my rival's journey today, and also
what the fuck is up with Birkin bags?
Like, I think the craziest part was one of them being
$450,000.
I'll show you guys.
I was looking it up because I was like, how much are Birkin
bags anyway?
And then, like, literally the first result was a $450,000
bag.
And I was like, excuse me.
Excuse me.
Like, um, sir.
here, I'll link it to you.
Because I'll prove it to you that it's real.
It's very real.
Bro, like, bro, you can just buy a car.
Let's buy a fucking car.
Or a house.
holy shit i know i know me too me too buddy holy shit that's
a real bag
what is this i can't carry this bag can't even carry a car
it's because it's made of Himalaya Niloticus crocodile
diamond encrusted because the lock has a diamond in it oh my
god that's why it's so like for us if this lock better have
diamonds it's because the lock actually has diamonds holy
shit wait let me show you that's crazy look you can see it
actually has diamonds right here like that's a pigeon toy
Your lock is a goddamn fidget toy right now.
Yeah, and then there's diamonds on this part.
You basically have your very own fidget toy on your bag.
Oh, so it wasn't a bit.
Yeah, that lock alone is 200k.
Okay.
All right, let's play Hades.
I don't know how long I'm going to play today.
I don't know, it could be long because I went from one
addiction to the other.
Yeah, no, for those who don't know this, I said this before,
but diamonds are like, they're man-made inflation or like
man-made market.
So the only reason why they're so expensive is because
diamonds are monopolized by, I think like one or two
companies, and they are the ones that manufacture the prices
for diamonds.
But they're actually very common.
They're actually incredibly common.
But they're the ones that control the market.
So they can make it that expensive.
There shouldn't be that expensive.
It's just controlled by the market.
Alright.
Let's see.
all right so for those who are confused we did an extra
night during rivals so we uh we skipped you are missing one
night of gameplay more worth to seal off that the valuables
did the valuables inside damn you rich people thank you for
the super chat solid thank you thank you yeah and then For
those who didn't watch the rival stream, because I did one
run, I had to wait two hours for the first game.
So I was like, fuck it, let's just do a run.
And because I did one run, I decided to do a free will run
where I decide what to pick.
And then we ended up doing a magic build.
And it might have been the worst build I've ever done.
So we are no longer practicing free will.
We are no longer practicing free will after that.
That had to be the worst run I've ever done.
Oh, what's that?
Disgusting.
Oh, shit.
Free stuff.
I'm still picking it up.
So what's been going on with you and Kronos anyway?
You keep beating him, but he keeps coming back.
I like how pointless it seems, but there has to be more to
it, right?
Come on, Eris.
I'm not about to reveal the critical details of my...
Try thinking once, and I hated it.
What's the point of being a streamer if I have to think for
myself?
Oh, there's a bitch.
Are you planning to use his own powers against him?
Break free, our family members one by one.
Anything like that?
She must hate her family if she's trying to stop me.
Not telling you.
Hmm.
Alright.
Boo free will.
You prevailed in your attempt.
But our enemy is time itself.
She's nice.
No, she is not.
She's fake as fuck.
and as yet i often fought back feelings that this task would
be impossible i am her auntie she's my auntie first though
we're anteing each other ability tends to be transient time
would wear us down but with patience we can withstand you
cannot fix there are some people that are not meant to be
fixed and she is one of them patience never give her another
chance oh hey summon a colony of bats may use in cages to
better orient yourself.
Oh my god, let's say that I want a fucking army of bats.
Like, that sounds fun.
Oh, I just need two more runs for the sand.
I might just do that.
We'll just get a rabbit everything.
Don't fuck that.
We'll do get...
Let's just do two runs of the grandpa run real quick, too.
And then we'll finish the down... We'll finish the um... The
hell run.
Yes, Lord Carol.
You'll have what gold I may find as I require what supplies
you may spare.
Hmm.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, hey, nice.
More psyche.
We need that.
Um, well, need...
Actually, I don't need to spend stuff yet.
The unhappy goddess of Kamubans casts a judging gaze on all
within the crossroads.
Why need more than two?
How many do I need?
End of spite.
Don't want to get on them's bad side.
A nemesis, about the dream I had.
Kronos, he... demanded that my father tell him where the
fates reside.
Smart.
Mother Nix never would have told him.
The fates may be my sisters, but even I have no idea where
they are.
Long as they're hidden, no one can mess with their designs.
You don't sound especially concerned that Kronos apparently
found the Three Weavers of Destiny and may be forcing their
plans for the future.
Really?
Did I ever give you the impression I had any hope this would
end well?
Alright.
How did he have found them?
Oh yeah!
Where did Fates know?
Can they just see the future?
They're always weaving.
That means even they know only so much in advance.
Wait, time moves faster than fate?
Time moves faster than expected.
Have they ever thought to maybe be faster?
I mean, 20 seconds.
sand for all incantations are you fucking kidding me do okay
guys we're doing one ending guys okay is is seven sand
enough for what guys we're not hundred percenting this guys
i'm sorry like that's that's that's a little that's a little
that's a no no one ending is fine that's one ending is fine
guys i think i'd be happy with one ending um 25 and 26 i
don't even have okay i can grab some ashes yeah eight sound
is good okay that's good to know um i mean i have 35 right
now let's see how much do i need 200 i'll just buy more a
few top runs yeah that's why i want to get the oh wait do i
have okay more psyche and then we'll buy more psyche here
all right uh i saw someone's like is she always just gonna
spam staff i think the staff is my favorite i don't like the
other weapons like i just think the other weapons are not as
not as easy for me same with this they i don't know wait
what how do i what the what does this do let's see yeah yeah
staff has been great this one no there's also this and oros
i think this is too much does i have to front line way too
much yeah the staff has just been clutching it for me every
time I'll do one run with the axe, I'll do that.
I'll try one run.
Let's see.
Okay, let's...
Alright, spin!
What is this?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'll do one run.
I don't think I've done the axe yet.
Yeah, I'm a sap abuser.
But now I've joined in our Princess Melinawee's most
righteous cause.
Welcome to the ranks of the unseen.
What build would be good with an axe?
I'm not doing this yet.
I don't think I need to.
Because I don't have, like, needed to upgrade my weapons
yet.
Oh, what?
The family is united in our course.
In the name of Hades.
Olympus, I accept this message.
Wait, this is new.
Hello?
Hera?
I already had enough of a surface.
Yes.
Well, I promised the family that once you demonstrated your
resolve to us, I'd take care of you.
you under my wing and i always keep my vows what your
special seal mark damage and inflict hitch your cast inflict
hitch and immediately deal damage based on foes in the
blinding circle like if flows take 30 of damage dealt to
other afflicted flows your sprint inflicts hitch on
surrounding and deals damage when it does what the fuck is
hitch take 30 delta utter afflicted flows oh Oh, so it,
like, it, like, builds the damage together.
Wait, which was the best, guys?
Yeah, it shared damage.
I was thinking, yeah.
It's chain.
Sprint is good on Hera.
All right, we'll try to sprint.
Her majesty, the queen, is with me now.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It's so slow.
I'm not used to it.
It's so fucking slow.
Okay.
Fishing time.
Come on.
Mad.
There you go.
Yeah!
We got a figment!
I don't know what that is.
Whatever that is.
There.
Boom!
It's like a combo, too.
All right, 50.
We'll get... We'll get Hermes in here.
Also, another reason why I'm like, oh, wait, I remember
Hera.
I was literally watching Crapopolis.
For those who don't know what Crapopolis is, it's another
animation show by Dan Harmon.
And I really like it because I also love, like, you know, I
love mythology in general.
And I like Dan Harmon's stuff.
I really like Dan Harmon shows.
But I was actually watching an episode like today.
Crapopolis starts with a K.
Yeah, it was originally an NFP.
They originally made the show for NFTs and then And then NFT
market fell and then they're like, wait, this show is
actually pretty People are actually liking this show.
I guess we could keep going like Yeah, the original intent
was for it to sell NFTs, but then like People actually liked
the show so they're like, oh, okay, let's just keep making
it
It's a good show And another item appears afterwards what
does that mean like uh when you're slave oh deal more damage
with your weapon for the next 45 seconds oh shouldn't mean
streak be better three early is good is suffering from
success well the nfts failed though uh the nfts failed
so they pit they just pivoted because they're like oh okay
we can Just do that, I guess.
Can you remember you used my cast for this?
Feels a bit slow.
Oh, wait.
There you go.
What's this?
Ensure any goods offered by Sharon cost 3% Ensure a... Oh,
okay, we'll grab this.
Wait, what?
Your cast deals 35 damage.
Oh my god, I spent it the wrong thing i oh no counted i
didn't i didn't know this counted i thought this was
different i said good job free this is why we don't practice
free will this is why okay okay um do we get head for our
zeus Oh, refresh, resets every, oh, oh my god, okay, wait,
it resets every room.
Oh, each location, I thought location meant like, like the
arena I'm in.
Zeus, Zeus?
All right, guys, this is why.
Okay, I freaked out for nothing.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
That's actually really good.
Okay.
There you go.
All right, there you go.
There is a... There is a chair on right here.
And then...
Mining!
How exactly you shall vanquish Kronos?
Someone shall have to explain to me at some point.
Your witching ways shall help you to prevail will be...
Not, hmm?
At least he hasn't yet imprisoned you along with your kin.
Yeah.
I got out.
Don't have my arm no more, but I got out.
Right on.
Anisha counter.
I feel like two, right?
We would lose magic, though.
2, right?
But it does prime...
No issues at Prime's 50.
Ugh.
What's a mega cat attack?
Oh, hey.
Oh, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh.
Oh, and a shop, too?
Okay.
1 and Span Spin.
a win you mean left click oh spin a win okay well already
picked it i picked two all right it's fine i paid for this
anyway guys i paid for this it's too late to make the most
of our arrangement i need you activate a certain artifact
where you reside within the pitchfork facets of this
standing stone are our possibilities to be explored i shall
reveal I hope to see them all at first.
Oh, I learned an incantation.
Core previews.
After you, it's 50% less.
After it's 65.
Too much chance to find.
Resources for next.
Boons have a chance.
Oh, they're all so good.
Guys, which one?
I don't have free will.
Remember, free will was a mistake.
almost turned gay finishing this game what stopped you what
what was the one thing that stopped you from crossing the
edge i'm curious um have for hermes guys oh wait i can get
mystical fish oh shit got another what are all these fishes
for guys.
Hef for Hermes.
Or not Hermes.
Or, uh...
Oh, God.
I forgot all their names.
You mean Hesia.
Yeah, Hesia.
Hef for Hesia.
Hef?
Alright, we'll get Hef.
Oh, I saw fish for bones?
Oh, that's...
Okay, Hef.
They're both H.
I got confused.
Why are all the gods' names starts with H?
Alright, we'll do Hef.
What's up?
Like, Why are they all age?
Oh my god, forgot the damage.
I was like, am I taking damage?
I don't understand.
Jesus Christ.
I do so much damage, but it's very annoying.
Okay.
It's just so slow.
I will have to admit.
Alright.
Nice.
test that thing oh there you are we lost you for a bit must
have gone so deep we couldn't spy you know whoa whoa whoa
whoa how are you spying on me must have turned out all right
whoa whoa whoa when do you stop spying on me and cause a
blast ideas i should do one right one or two one right
because i don't know if i use my left click enough
Yeah, I'll do one.
I accept this gift.
Gee, okay, more ash.
Yeah, I was thinking one for sure.
There you go.
Oh, nice.
That's actually very convenient.
I literally just run up to them.
And then they get fucked up.
Haha, what you gonna do?
Oh my god, I can't fucking hit her.
What am I gonna do?
I literally can't hit her.
Okay.
This is faster.
I just noticed the right my right click is really fast,
which is good For me, all right ash time We have We'll grab
magic because I don't think I need more money.
I think I have 439 right now So grab more magic because we
got prime 50
All right Well nice Nice, I'm very strong right now.
Ooh, I grabbed some flowers.
Jesus Christ, what the fuck hit me?
Yay, magic!
Yeah, but I have a lot of money at the moment.
I have $456.
So I think that's...
We'll go through here.
HP time.
Oh, hey.
I haven't encountered a sink...
Oh, wait, that's a shop right there.
Okay, that's just...
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I have met the fountain.
I thought I didn't.
I thought this was the last place Yeah, we got free free
health Have since been taken by the woods or by decay.
That's good Rehealth it must have been magnificent Uh Nectar
or who got bones?
I have enough nectar I'm surprised.
I've been We only got the shop once Oh, shit That's not why
I want it And I have one more chaos, and then we should be
good.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Let's go ahead and make sure I don't hold it.
God damn it.
Get out of here.
Phone in time.
Yay!
Okay, I can hold now.
Nice.
Okay, and then I'm going to grab the shop.
Your special.
Gain 11 now.
grab this so I can do it a prophecy.
Oh, yeah, I'm grabbing the...
We don't need it.
I think I saved my money.
I have to unequip the money bonus soon.
Alright.
I missed a crow?
There was a crow?
I'm not talking to you first.
I'm grabbing my items.
Yeah, that's right.
To tempt What does the bird do?
I knew if I talked to her, she was going to take it.
Wait, what does the bird do?
Chat.
You're casting for like scorch.
But uses...
Oh, it's a familiar?
No!
I could have had it in her pet.
It just calls at me.
All right, one or two, chat.
Yeah, I guess it does uh, what if I get a freeze later?
I'll grab two.
We'll grab birds now.
Oh, oh, she left I knew it.
I knew about doctor.
She was gonna take it.
I don't trust her.
I oh, I forgot to give her a gift Oh, wait, uh, when you
restore it you drink damage all oh duo We'll grab the duo
Yeah, by her grace Guys, I knew it.
I I knew like I knew she was was going to steal it.
Yeah, exactly.
Yoink, bye now.
He doesn't care.
As long as he gets money.
Oh, nice.
I spent all my money too.
Good.
I had 400.
I'm broke now.
Our enemy surely is beginning to wonder how you are able to
thwart him.
Get that bag.
Exactly.
The less he knows of us.
He's all about capitalism.
Krono seems to think my family bond with him is why I'm able
to resist.
He hasn't made the connection that you're the one who's
prepared me.
Gotta do my SATs again.
My PSATs.
This is an internal PSAT.
Eternal PSAT test.
That's actually...
Oh my god, I almost forgot how to fucking kill this girl.
Okay, nice.
Sisters!
Got you!
Oh, hey, plants.
I'm like, oh, but there's a plant over there, though.
Oh, shit!
Oh, God.
Okay.
Yay!
I thought that was so unintentional.
I mean to do that, but I'll take it.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
That's so much damage.
How come the frog didn't get turned into a shield?
That's not fair.
It's not an inconvenience, but a strength.
How did the frog not get turned?
Can you go?
Oh.
Oh, hey.
That shade needs you, Freenos.
Come back.
Come back to hell.
We'll miss you.
Spin until we win.
Oh, win.
Sorry.
We win.
Again.
Can I gift you?
Oh, why can't I give Grandpa something?
Is your next boon you find in Clues?
Oh, yeah, we'll grab that.
Oh, no.
We don't need that.
We'll need...
Which one was it?
Oh, yeah, we'll need this.
And then...
Why are you so cranky?
I'm literally going to give you a free shit.
That's it?
You just don't...
Yeah, he's like, I just want to gossip.
He's just here to gossip with me.
He's like, bro, fuck my son.
And I'm like, yeah, I know, right?
Zeus is such an asshole.
That's cold.
Just want someone to talk to you.
Isn't that sad?
The only issue with this one is just the...
I think like the...
It's very annoying fighting these guys.
Only because that...
It doesn't like stop him.
Okay, spoon.
heart.
Okay, palm tab.
I think you get palm, right?
Yeah, palm.
I don't need health yet.
I just need stronger.
Oh, shit.
Spin!
Can't block this!
Oh, wait, that's fast.
Oh, okay.
Your attacks can deal.
Ooh, one, right?
I'll do one.
I'm scared.
My free will.
Chart.
Mouse one.
Dash onto the enemy attack gets cancelled if you dash again.
Oh!
I didn't know you could do that.
Always a treat.
I'm always scared to enact free will.
Oh, we'll grab this real quick.
Oh.
That is, it's just one guy?
Wait, what the fuck?
Okay, give me that money.
Do I have enough?
I have 129.
Maybe I can buy one thing.
Maybe.
Oh, I can buy two things!
Let's go!
Oh, wait, I can only buy one.
Oh, never mind.
Guys, should I get moon or nah?
Or just spend it on hef.
Should I get the moon or just spend it on hef, guys?
Hef?
Alright.
Uh, asarking...
Trying to deal more damage.
Oh.
Blast effects from...
Oh!
But your special...
Three.
Yeah.
Yeah!
I didn't want that, but that's cool.
Alright, Zeus or Hera?
More boom!
More damage!
Zeus or Hera?
Hera for born again?
Wait, I get born again?
Yeah, let's go.
Thank you for your service.
service at last a worthy opponent no no he's back no he's
back guys what do I do he came back oh shit oh god I'm
getting hurt everywhere I'm so scared oh my god he's coming
let's get closer he's getting closer isn't he Oh, thank God
I was fast.
Uh-oh.
Okay, I can gift her too.
Oh, that's my last nectar.
Hera, out of all the matters you could be attending to,
you've chosen to aid me.
I am honored and would honor you in kind.
Right down, right down.
Is there a wedding date that I should know about?
Were you merely being generous with me?
In any case, when I'm offered to, there's always a catch.
So, here.
I got An iridescent stand Yeah In the name of Hades Are you
damaging effects From Olympians are stronger for each boom
Boom's effect damage per Wait Oh so I have to get like more
When you run out of prime Until the next To prime Until the
next location to restore all one is broken
where a hitch of the damage all other oh my god what what
does this even mean born gain for one or three one is
terrible three is better one sounds crazy okay guys guys we
yeah i don't i don't get oh i regain it after spending it oh
one is good three or one uh oh this is hard uh one tells the
truth the other tells a lot i feel like one is the best map
mana oh i don't use do i use i use a lot of mana though um
three is i am okay what do i how many boons do i have from
everyone i have I don't even know.
Okay, I have...
Uh...
How many do I have?
I don't even know how many gods I talked to.
Wait, 20%?
I do have a lot of...
Oh, wait, but I would have 20% damage, though.
Yeah.
Shouldn't that be better?
I get 20% damage.
Yeah, I'll do extended... Yeah, I have a lot of gods.
I talked to a lot of them today.
I was like, hello, uncle.
Yeah, more damage is nice.
I got a goddamn axe for it.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Just get hit by everything.
That's fine.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I'm getting hit by everything right now.
It's not good.
There you go.
I should hit them.
Oh, my God.
Now I got hit by that.
We're still alive.
Oh, it's you.
There you go.
I was like, who the fuck did I leave alive?
Oh, hey.
Dig.
Dig a tunnel.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
That was a lot of damage.
But I also got a lot of damage on me.
Okay, I need health really badly.
Oh my god.
Three.
Wait.
Attack fires around you, leaving free to move and strike.
The final move attack sequence hit two times, but use...
Okay, three.
That has to be three.
One is spin to win.
Oh, one is good.
I feel like I can attack faster, though.
Oh, this is hard.
Okay, I'm going to like three more.
Okay.
Oh, this is a lot faster.
Yeah, I definitely like it.
It is a lot faster.
Uh, we'll get ash.
Spin!
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, god.
There we go.
Nice.
Ash time.
And I got a flower, too.
I have enough?
I do.
I have enough for the shop.
Oh, let it rip.
Oh, hey, fish tab.
Here, little fish.
Here, little fishy fishy.
Oh, no escape.
Yay!
What's that?
Okay, your blast effects also like glow.
Oh, more damage.
Game bonus based on your prime limit.
Hmm.
Two?
Two.
Okay.
Oh, I have more damage.
Yeah, glow.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I can't afford that.
I can't buy both of this, though.
Yeah.
I can't afford the other one.
Alright.
Time to be a hater.
Yay!
Don't you have any new material yet to get out?
Yeah, you've been saying the same song over and over, bro.
You're a one-hit wonder.
Shut up.
That's right, I said it.
I mean, you've been singing one song this entire time.
Not only I call her Wash, I call her a one-hit wonder.
She's like that guy who sang something I used to know.
He literally made one song and then disappeared.
Um, not, you mean greatest hit?
What do you mean?
Greatest hits.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, wait.
I already got him.
Whoa!
Nice.
Oh shit, oh shit!
That's a lot of explosions, guys!
I was not expecting that.
Oh, fuck!
Not again!
Okay, I gotta get her out of here.
Okay.
Just her left.
Alright, nice.
I definitely need mana, I know.
Oh, that was a lot of damage.
Because I'm a tank.
I'm a goddamn tank.
Let her reach the chorus.
No.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Oh, I'm broke, broke.
I have no money.
closer now that's right maybe maybe if they you know don't
die it's not my fault they died all right this way all this
sorrow uh where the fuck is the entrance oh there it is oh
nice we get another hammer oh my god everything's going up
for dokey i used up all yes okay i used up all my
Literally use it all up Just for this run Come on Whoa I got
sobbed Oh god that's so sad It's eternal cry A cry forever I
don't waste my Oh shit god damn it Oh no I'm so sad Wait
where the fuck is the all right not letting me pause where's
the other one okay that one's just money i see you two
statue okay i don't want to waste my uh my mana for this
until i get to the area all right grab money oh there you go
they won't like this nice
spin Jesus Christ, that's it!
Alright, we did it.
Yeah, I missed the tree.
Uh, you do more damage so that I know when your other foes
gain chance to dodge, which double against scorched
afflicted enemies.
Mmm...
It's only 5% though.
I guess we could do snuff candle for a boss fight.
Yeah.
Boss fight.
Where is the tree?
Oh, there it is.
Show me the way.
Is it just money?
Okay, it's just...
Oh, it's magic and hammer.
I don't even want to do it for the...
Okay, nice.
I got two just because, like, for boss fights, it'd be easy.
Alright.
That's right.
Spin!
Nice.
Last one.
Oh, never mind.
You're still alive?
Oh, your special strikes further and deals 150.
Your speech hit deals plus 300 damage to armor.
Your dash strikes.
Ah.
Um, I actually don't know.
I don't know if I use a three.
Three is good.
Is three that good?
Okay, I'll try.
all right we'll try it oh yeah money one hundred dollars is
a hundred dollars guys oh my god holy shit goodbye a hundred
94 who took the five dollars
100.
Who the fuck took the $6 from the chest?
Oh, God.
No, not her.
Oh, I'm so bad against this one.
Spin!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, never mind.
Maybe not spin.
Maybe not.
Jesus Christ.
She does so much.
She has so much HP, too.
That's the worst part.
She does so much and has so much HP.
the dead are as innumerable as the sprigs of wheat within
the morning fields but do not make for the most satisfying
sustenance for the unspeakable monstrosities therein she
heals are you serious that's why oh my god that's why she's
so tanky show you off and restore it when you take damage
you're up in deals more damage based on your taxes
specialist i should get three right one or three
Uh, three is nice?
One or...
Uh...
Three, okay.
Yeah, no, she fucking hits hard.
Okay, we'll grab the double palm then.
That sucks that this was where I get the doubles.
Why can't you double my hammer?
Hello, F-bo.
we're all in our offense is the best defense we all know
that but you possess such strength despite the change my
words perhaps but the intent is yours my words but the
intent is yours all right okay here you go uh yeah we'll
grab another have such a power power Olympus i accept this
message so much have i take damage drug your weapon deals
more damage based on hurricane, but you prime.
That's...
I don't know.
What this time?
Yeah, what this time?
Yeah.
Oh.
What does she have?
Oh, okay.
Come with me if you want to live.
Well, you're dead technically, but...
If you want a nicer place to live while you're dead.
Oh, nice.
Flower.
Oh.
Which one?
We don't really have the moon yet.
We'll grab...
I guess we'll get...
We don't have any moon powers, so...
I feel like I should kill here.
Hera?
Oh, too late.
Too late.
Here they come.
Look, it's because I thought, like, oh, we don't have any
moon powers.
Like, that's my initial thought.
Does it count if I have, like...
Um...
Wait, I can get more damage, too, if you think about it.
Curse you, free will.
Free will has betrayed me yet again.
Alright, grab health, too.
I messed up by listening to free will.
Oh, there's a lot of items here.
Alright, uh, where the fuck are the trees, though.
It was like money.
It was moons and herm.
Oh, there you go.
We'll grab moon first.
Nice.
There's a tree.
I should need this.
There you go.
We'll grab moon power first.
Oh, God.
That's depressing.
What do you mean you have your you have the witch?
Ooh.
I mean, that's good.
I actually needed that.
I needed the hit.
so I can regen my magic.
There you go.
Moon time!
Shine for me again tonight.
Death to Kronos.
I sense that you are growing closer to manifesting the
reality that we have long since sought.
May you yet drain whatever light is left in here.
Okay, that's another 5% damage too, if I get herself.
Makes everything else moves.
Ooh!
Your hex fires a beam that deals up your hand.
deals a large area target for a thousand damage after four
seconds oh Yeah, it's not healing though.
I would have liked to heal pick three.
Okay, we'll try three Three right three or one three is
funny.
Okay All right three is funny I like the sound of that all
right How do I use this again?
Oh, there you go.
Oh shit what the fuck happened oh okay everything's dead i'm
in the name of haiti's i'm actually summoning the moon oh
money oh nimble legs three is good too wait i gotta pee real
quick all right help me pick guys i gotta pee
i'm back numbers alan nexy bite and thank you for the super
chat thank you Thank you.
All right, what do you guys three?
Yeah, all right.
Oops, sorry, I had to tab out real quick.
Also, that reminded me, because you know how I'm like, fuck
free will?
Oh, that reminded me.
Do you guys hear about the news about like, apparently a
female esport player for like a mobile game got kicked out
during land because she was apparently using like the what's
called team viewer where the fuck where she had like a
foreign land.
That's crazy.
where someone yeah she got caught cheating because she had
someone controlling like playing the game on her phone they
were actually playing for her at land her phone had like a
fucking team viewer installed on her phone I was insane like
uh restore 50% that's a lot of it I'll just do this I want
the random item exhumed remain What the fuck did I get?
What the fuck?
Oh, it was just a bone thingy.
Well, grab the pavilion for extra money.
I think it's insane that...
Oh, hey, random item.
That, like...
That she did it on land, too.
After your foe's struck, your chain law deals more damage
and mouses up to three times.
Oh, one or three?
One?
Okay, that's more stuff for casting, you're right.
Can I afford this?
Oh, I can, but then I won't be able to afford food.
Do I need food?
Hmm, am I that hungry though?
Get the food.
Yeah, but then I could get another one who needs it.
hit more gods more yeah more power more powers don't get hit
guys but what if i i what if i just don't get hit though how
hungry you're not more dab you're right more damage okay
your scorch deals damage faster look at that whoa i want to
click scorch For the first time, inflict more.
It just don't get hit.
Just...
One or three, chat.
One?
A lot of you think of this super chat.
Thank you, man.
Clara really can't get enough of ruining girls' careers.
Think of this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think it's just crazy that she did it, lad.
That's insane.
Like, let's just someone else play the game for her.
watch she's holding her phone she's like whoa oh my god guys
he's won like what the fuck like acting it out too the
guardian at the gates of hell oh he does not even oh guys i
don't understand i just had to do one thing and i still
managed to fuck it up i don't understand
what I don't understand I just had to not get hit yeah
somehow still got hit how is that possible instructions
unclear I got hit okay shit oh my god you fucking kidding me
oh my god oh my god Guys, I got hit.
I don't understand how that happened.
And I got hit again?
How did that happen?
Oh, no.
Am I safe in this?
Should have got it.
No, oh my god.
Okay.
I have one Deptiviance left.
You are just act not safe.
I didn't think he would run at me.
That Esport Lady was smurfing.
No, you are not safe in that spot.
Okay, this is awkward.
I don't know if I'll make it to the end now, guys.
I have a bad feeling.
Guys, I have a feeling I might not make it to the end.
So Briss might have, may or may not have took two of my, two
of my death defiance cast.
It's not looking too good for me now.
101 HP is a lot of HP.
Okay.
Maybe I'll get a good item.
life essence discovered the fuck is life essence what did i
get what is life essence no it's okay it's literally 15 like
it's like one hit see expires after one hit oh i healed oh
my god i got see guys look at that that's all i look at that
i won the gotcha i literally just got healed Guys, I think
the axe is just not it for me in the deepest reaches of the
earth We're once criminal.
I can't believe that this is Tartarus I think I'm just not
good with the axe.
I tank it too much
No, it's because like I I keep oh my god I keep fucking
Instead of dodging I just tank it because I feel I'm like
I'm so strong guys I can just tank this But I was not so
strong.
In the end.
Apparently I was not that strong.
I keep thinking I'm like unstoppable.
But I can be stopped.
That's crazy.
What do you mean I can be stopped?
What is this bullshit?
She has she in fact.
I cannot take those apparently.
Spin!
There you go.
Oh, what the fuck?
You're still alive?
Oh, shit!
Okay, there you go.
That was unlucky.
I tanked it again.
Alright.
Your attacks can cause blasts.
Your cast for Poolean like scorch.
You deal more damage on foes.
Ah, fuck.
One or three?
Three would be good for Kronos.
One, right?
Five seconds?
seconds though yeah that five seconds is very short it's
gotta live dog
okay oh god this guy there you go oh hey money oh god where
is he oh nice oh god the time clock What the fuck?
What's hitting me?
Oh, God.
I don't even know what's hitting me.
Okay.
I got confused.
There's just so many things going on on my screen.
Oh, God.
That's so...
That was an accident.
That is an accident.
I don't mean to get hit there.
Oh, God.
I'll just mine this real quick.
I got too confident.
Oh, I don't have a lot of money, are they?
I hope I can buy one food.
Please.
Please, just one food.
I'm so hungry.
Please.
Okay.
That's five.
There you go.
Last guy.
Oh.
Oh, I have to.
I have to take anything I can get.
Found the treasury.
Oh, no.
Not them.
I gotta make sure I don't accidentally get on the coin.
okay nice there we go oh where are you interlocation gain at
the start gain armor that last seven oh fuck I might
actually need this I might actually need I might need this
too oh gain oh wait gain health wait oh wait you're right
How much did that give me?
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
Yeah, you're right.
I didn't see that Okay, I got two oh money I need all the
money I can get okay five hundred dollars.
I can buy one thing Oh, I can buy two with it.
I can still buy one thing A metal shunned by the true king
of the underworld not just for its softness But because it
was favored by his titan father a stark reminder of a
bygone.
It's okay.
I can buy one thing now Dad room.
Gotta talk to dad.
Hello, dad.
Oh, hey, nice.
I need this too.
Is that you?
It's me.
Please hang on, father.
I talked to brother.
Brother.
I wait to stop Kronos.
Hello, papa.
Forever.
Even when my brothers foster sisters and I vanquished him.
Yeah, because they're weak.
Eventually be back.
But deathless.
I'm different.
I'm not like other gods.
It would be on our terms.
We were such fools What else could you have done?
He left you with no choice and you lacked the means to
destroy him utterly It was for the best that we lacked such
means We would have used them and continued using them.
I merely judged the dead or used to I was never fit to judge
the living All right, restore health for one percent till
you reach?
reach the limit.
Oh, wait, that one.
Okay, sometimes you use...
Oh, shit, wait, two.
Oh, wait, but I get plus, guys, plus 20% more damage,
though.
But... I did use two, though.
Two is even more glass.
Guys, but more damage, though.
Okay.
Tokey, please.
Guys, if we're damaged, though.
Just don't get hit.
Okay.
Alright, fine.
Fine.
I'll get the heals.
Guys.
Tokey, don't.
Don't.
Tokey, don't listen.
Don't listen to your free will.
turkey guys but imagine guys I can do more damage oh shit
guys think about it think about it guys I'd be so strong
though Imagine how strong I'll be!
I'm full HP now.
I don't know.
I've never seen that before.
Oh, wait.
I can get more money.
Okay, nice.
Spin time.
Spin!
That's right.
Spin time!
Oh, shit.
Okay, but that guy's dangerous.
Spin!
there you go that's right jesus christ okay it's fine
nice money yeah okay now i'm 985 dollars oh wait oh shit but
moon i can go to the moon now too i'm greedy
oh my god there you go doki please i'm greedy guys but look
i can do more i can get more oh shit
spin yep nice let the greed flow
okay what can i do uh also creates feels more plus what's
this gain plus 50 i don't think i'm gonna make it we'll just
grab here oh i am nice let's go i made it okay gain plus 22
ensure any goat oh shit wait i can do this now oh wait okay
okay okay i can grab both of them oh wait i can only grab
one okay i can grab both All right, Deft of Files.
Okay, I don't need that.
And then I can make them, make it cost less.
Yeah, and I'll do that.
So I should be able to afford stuff now.
Go show that shade the way.
All right.
Now I can afford everything.
Three first, too late.
I should have done three first, though.
No, you guys were right.
I should have done it first.
But I can, it's okay, I can afford everything.
Too late, she took it.
Yay!
Oh, 350.
Three, four, five.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I don't know math.
Three, five hundred and sixty.
And then...
I'm not getting the card, guys.
It's not that worth it.
Do I get Hermes or do I get the Palm?
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
Do I get...
I don't need armor, right?
I don't need armor.
I'll grab the cup palm first.
Um...
Your attacks can cause blast at gain.
Ooh!
Oh, shit!
Three seconds, though.
Yeah.
Three seconds.
And then we'll grab a Hef.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
I should get the duo, right?
That's huge.
Yeah.
Don't grab armor.
And I have armor, too.
Nice.
Alright.
We have three, two death defiances.
Okay, we'll see how this goes.
I don't know how this is gonna go.
You again.
I would say I'm quite unaccustomed to so many frequent
visits.
Sucks to suck, bro.
I didn't think the bus driver.
Yeah.
So lonely, bro.
You got pay people to hang out with you.
That's so sad.
That's why we put you in a home.
Well, technically he was put in a home when you think about
it.
You are unfortunately caught in the midst of a dispute.
Too damn bad.
The difference between having family around or not.
Because of you and this dispute of yours.
And now you'll be destroyed for what you've done.
Was it what when you put it that way?
No Have I not made any mistakes?
We would not be here now would we certainly not as such
vicious foes yet here we are Each in turn facing the
consequences of the past All right, here you go
I'll put this here and then get rid of his little minions
That's right You have no friends grandpa Shit.
Sorry.
Sorry, Grandpa.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
What?
Okay, that's not fair.
That's not fair, Grandpa.
And you know it.
Oh, my God.
No, not this.
I gotta get rid of.
Whoa, he just walked.
It's not fair.
You just walked.
That took you.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't see this.
Oh, no!
Fucking kidding me!
Okay, that's not fair.
Are you...
That hits me!
Oh, God.
Okay.
It's fine.
Well, get rid of him first.
Jeez.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my!
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
I'm not a tank.
Okay.
It's okay.
There you go.
I just need him to stay here.
Maybe he'll stay here.
I don't know.
I'm doing a lot of hope right now.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's bullshit.
Oh god, what's going on?
Oh god, he's getting healed.
Are you fucking kidding?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh no.
Oh no!
That's so unlucky.
Oh, God.
There we go.
We did it.
Not even close.
Guys, not even close, guys.
You don't even know why you're fighting anymore.
To prove something to your children.
I'm so strong.
I was literally a glass cannon there.
He took everything from me.
Everything and more.
Now they seek for you to take the rest.
Such a wretched family, this.
Well, then you shouldn't have children.
That's your fault for not using protection.
He should have practiced safe sex.
That's his...
If he didn't want children, should have pulled out.
That's his own fault.
It's true.
Wrap it up, Grandpa.
That remains of time.
Damn, not wrong.
Full of game week.
That's his fault.
He did this to himself by having children.
To the abyss of the subconscious, I descend.
All right.
I'll go to Surface World after this.
run because I just need one more run anyway quick time event
fail hello
brother I'm
not a nap your fucking sister that's messed up he called me
a nightmare try to save the world bro that's me good news
sister it took some doing but I managed to persuade our
father to let me hang on to his favorite spear a while oh
yeah that's nice you did that's great but where is it i
found no trace of any such weapon when i passed through here
i have it secure except i felt a little hesitant about
handing it over across this astral psychic whatever you call
it zagreus i need that spirit i need that spirit we need
that spirit so i'm gonna have to find in the surface world
later the millinery you're asking me to permanently slay a
member of our family who evil family he's an evil man i
don't even know of course you can what do you mean you don't
want to go through with because if i do it if the children
of the underworld king and queen we do what is required of
us not merely what we desire because it's like if i have to
if they bury it on the surface world what if i just do one
more run here and then go to the surface world you sound
just like father ability
oh yeah did you hear in australia they banned everything for
until you're 16 16 is a fucking like high age limit like
yeah i'm sorry for the australians yeah yeah so if you're 16
if you're under 16 years old you can't use twitter you can't
use tick tock you can't use instagram you can't use twitch
you can't like all social media is fucking bad literally
everything VPNs are eating good tonight.
Bro, imagine how much money VPNs are making now.
Yeah, you can't even use YouTube.
That's crazy.
Like, we have YouTube kids.
Oh.
Oh, I'm having my first sibling fight.
I can't force you to cooperate with me, but I can haunt your
dreams.
I'm gonna haunt you, brother.
This was a lovely chat.
See you some other nap time now.
Count on it.
And mark you my words.
We're going to fix this.
I just think 16 is way too old like maybe 13 because a lot
of you know originally you're not even supposed to go on
these websites at 13 anyway so like like 13 or 14 that's bad
but 16 that's a fucking teenager bro brother we shouldn't be
fighting i understand where zagreus is coming from but he
hasn't had to go through any of this make it 18 too young it
should be 18 yeah yeah when you can drink you can go on
youtube yeah because 60 is when you learn how to drive you
know my stance on this dora you need to get out of this tent
you're very talented i've never met a shade that speaks oh
no what if they have to watch tv No You're gonna have to go
back to TV
No They can't skip ads There's no ad block on TV Oh the
humanity Yeah There's no guys There's no ad block on TV guys
Who the fuck even still has Tivo The moon oft shines
particularly bright in one fair corner of the crossroads of
the underworld may always clear her thoughts and have a
moment's peace and listen to the frogs what Kronos fell to
you once more that much I heard it's an impressive feat
although you mean to bring him death yet he is deathless
this seems to be a paradox that's right mortal death is not
the end but mortals often think at least you don't have to
play league true that's a sacrifice we're as it may seem so
then to vanquish him must be at least a step toward that end
what shall become of everything if you succeed and time is
truly killed a world without time we'll live forever yeah
our world existed before time and can exist oh my god we're
gonna kill time let's go no more daylight savings guys We're
gonna do it, guys.
We're gonna cancel daylight savings.
More Jesus.
How would I not have enough for anything?
I'm so fucking poor.
Finally.
I found him headmistress.
My father.
Kronos has him locked away in Tartarus.
But I couldn't save him.
He asked.
Truly.
How utterly predictable of Kronos.
to gloat in such a way.
I regret that your reunion with Lord Hades thus transpired.
Though I am gladdened you discovered him.
How does he fare?
He...
I really wouldn't know.
Yeah, he's definitely having a mid-life crisis.
He looks like he's having a mid-life crisis.
He could still bestow.
What can we do?
Yeah, we'll do a surface run.
We'll do one surface run and then go back to do last Kronos
run and then commit to the surface.
Use full discretion and be brief, should you encounter him
again.
And I shall see about ensuring Kronos remains ignorant of
your newfound connection.
Speaking of time, I don't know how, but I accidentally
fucked up my PM AM for like Asia, like for the Asia goon.
So for some reason, I actually put like 530 PM PS, JSC
instead of 530 AM.
I don't know how I fucked that up.
it i was just like wait what beautiful night isn't it it's
been like that for a month i was trying to figure out how
long it's been and i did i don't know how i messed it up for
entire month moon dust oh yay moon dust i need that recently
although you always have an idea don't you would you believe
it doesn't block discord and roblox that's the fact that
robot they're like it's okay they won't be playing roblox
There's no 16-year-old that's willing to play Roblox.
I mean, they have nothing left.
I was like, bro, let's hang out in Roblox, guys.
One at the very least.
That's crazy.
I can't really give me Nightshade, of all things.
If they have nothing left, I mean, Roblox should be blocked,
though, I would agree.
Activate in the treatment attempt its chaos trials for
Stardust.
I mean, Stardust is...
What do I get out of it?
No, Roblox is fucked.
As ancient chaos beckoned me to say, awake, o monument of
night, I shall obey.
So moat it be.
We have a dragon that makes Roblox, Roblox, Roblox games.
Apparently he makes like four digits.
Is it four digits or five digits?
He either makes four or five digits.
I don't remember.
lot of money i just remember that how long has it been since
you visited the surface like per month was it six what that
i remember i told you guys was six figures oh yeah yeah we
have we have a dragon that does uh roblox development for
games and he makes six figures not a month though i think
that's a year six figures a year yeah per year with six
figures Yeah Hermie's requested that I pay a visit when I
can figured I should ask if you had any notes It's like I
said the dad because he develops like skin she does like
cosmetics and games You'll feel right at home.
I mean cosmetics.
I understand too because you make a good cosmetic on roblox
That's like you know like you know you make like something
for I don't know digital circus or some shit the children
will eat it up Like you're deep you're what's your name
Pommie or whatever.
Yeah, you'll get a lot of fucking money for that shit.
You're like the best looking Pommie head.
Like that's those children are gonna go wild.
Oh, there's the Chaos Trials.
What does the Chaos Trials grant me anyway?
I think I can raise my grasp.
Five, six, seven.
Aha.
Guardian Encounters.
What?
Okay, we'll grab that.
I'm going to buy...
Not quite.
I'm going to buy this so I can...
Oh, wait.
I use this to activate no more than two cards.
Wait, I want to buy this.
Oh, okay.
Wait, I want to upgrade.
I can upgrade.
Uh...
Plus four.
Again, they're deft defiance, technically.
Okay.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, I can't start.
Oh, God, 12.
Oh, HP limit?
We'll grab this.
Yeah.
Okay, we'll grab the money.
And then we'll try the surface world.
Do I... Oh, staff with the surface.
Oh, wait.
What does that mean?
Is it powered up?
Guys, what does it mean when there's red on it?
Does it mean my staff is powered up?
Let's see Revealing influence reality as you know Because
you try as an alternate option way to pursue your task Could
be a certain less other twist Oh more bones Oh Oh okay
Alright That's two That's four Use We'll do this We'll do
this on the next run on what shall happen if and when all
this is finally over commander i know i ought to be
completely focused on the task but as we near a potential
end oh my god forgot to change my eye give me a sec i just
realized i was like why don't we match anymore girl give me
a sec i forgot to bind this
all right now we matching we're the same stop it how many
times have i told you never think
Yeah, stop thinking.
I like what he says.
I like your funny words, Bone Man.
No free will and no thoughts.
If you're always doing good right now, you're always doing
good later.
That's all there is to it.
Yeah.
Don't you worry and...
Never think.
Why was there?
Oh, he's blushing.
Wait, can I give it to him?
What do I give it to?
Oh, no, it's not him.
Oh, you blush, you saw that?
Little ghost blushed.
Alright, which one is this?
Oh, Aphrodite.
Yeah.
I can breathe now!
I can touch grass!
It's time!
Look at you beneath the shining moonlight.
Welcome, gorgeous.
How's he?
office of our world please stay as long as you like or as
long all right my specials you're cast and flick weak and
damaged foes while dragging them towards the center uh you
want to click weak or nearby foes oh okay but that now
requires me to have a mad two one two or three
three okay man in region Let's try three.
There you go.
That means I can use this more freely too.
So weird being able to breathe in the air now.
Oh my god, hammer right away.
This is where the dead have risen.
And Olympus teeters on the brink of doom.
This is going to be the first surface run because I spent it
all on killing grandpa over and over again.
again i have to get out of this damned city
so this is the first technically the first uh surface run
gold coins
your special bounces towards up to two your specials are 25%
faster your attack oh mirrored three right because i had
mana regen too yeah All right Oh my god Guys look I can
breathe I'm touching grass guys Hey Gotta figure out how to
How to fuck to Traverse this area Oh my god What the fuck
hit me
Oh god it's that Okay I see now Okay I don't have any more
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Ooh, this is bad.
Okay, I gotta destroy this first.
Go Shades!
Do your thing!
Okay, I need to remember like...
Yeah.
I can't...
I'm so not used to having the... Was it... You know when I
have like the double the insane damage?
It's so weird not having the crazy damage now.
What the fuck?
I was like, who was following me?
Yeah, I heard the difficulty is like a lot harder.
So that's why I did most, I did like all the hell runs.
The grandpa runs first.
So I can be stronger to be on the surface.
You surprise me fairly often, little star.
That's me.
Defive.
X makes everything slower.
fight for you two or three they are slower but I don't know
if that's good three I would have another buddy what is this
what does this go oh is it like free shit oh oh it's like
free stuff extra loot room oh yeah it's like one I see.
That's cool.
What?
Oh, okay.
It doesn't matter.
I was gonna summon.
I was gonna be like, I shall now summon someone over.
Fight for me.
Okay.
What?
Oh, pylons remaining.
I love free stuff.
Is this one drink only?
The barrier's lost some of its strength.
The back cage.
Nice.
What?
That's our fight!
I couldn't do it.
Oh, shit.
Okay, nice.
Holy fuck.
I keep thinking like he's hurting.
Oh, shit!
He was hurting me!
I was like, oh my god.
I keep thinking he's like trying to hit me, but if he was he
was trying to hit me like I wish it's it's so hard to tell
when it's like When they're like fighting for me or not I'm
having a hard time trying to figure it out
Like I can't see which one's mine and which one's his that
he is
That's the only thing I wish there are different colors, you
know changes everything you can help us defend this mountain
yeah oh my god you can go to the olympus there attacks
inflict blitz you're special i feel like attack right you're
special i don't use i'm gonna do attack this is always good
should head to the main square
all right there's no extra guys it's uh there's no refills
right for this i know i asked before but I wasn't reading.
Uh-oh.
I just want to be sure.
What's this?
Oh, and Christ an incantation.
No refills?
Okay, I won't use it yet then.
What the fuck is this for?
Like, what is it summoning?
Jesus Christ.
Oh, okay, it's summoning monsters.
Okay.
I'm so confused.
Oh shit, I didn't even see this tombstone.
Where the fuck did this tombstone come from?
Okay.
Just stand over there.
Bro, it just keeps reviving!
There we go.
Okay, more hearts too.
Oh hey.
Oh, he's chilling.
He's just chilling.
I'm like where the fuck
Teardrop?
What the fuck is a teardrop?
Oh, is it like a special item?
Like resource?
Oh, it's a... Oh, okay.
I was like confused.
I was like, what the fuck does that do?
I'll summon him.
Oh my god, I didn't want to summon this guy.
I didn't even want this guy.
Oh, what did I get?
Do I not get anything?
I'm sorry.
I know he's like, but he matters, Doki.
What do you mean?
All minions are good minions.
Be nice to him.
Goodness.
That was fast.
And then we'll also grab magic, too.
Oh, I got money.
Okay.
I couldn't see it.
I wasn't looking at the floor.
Okay.
all right another place down uh Hermes or Zeus first I feel
like you know what we have already got Zeus we'll try Hermes
too okay all right god damn I keep summoning this guy I
don't want to summon you like you don't do shit your attacks
are so slow
Rude, Doki.
He didn't pick to be summoned, Doki.
He didn't want to be born.
Imagine you see a barrier that Norris instances of damage.
Shadow cast faster and cast.
Oh, two or three.
I feel like two, right?
For the cast.
Attack three?
Two.
Okay, more people are voting for two.
Call upon Aerith.
I almost forgot about this guy.
Makes it blocked.
Why is it blocked?
Um, I demand to...
I demand to be let in.
Hello?
Why is it blocked?
Do you know who I am?
I am the...
daughter of Hades.
That's right.
I'm pulling the card.
There's like three Zeus's.
Oh my god, it's all Zeus.
It's just, it's all Zeus.
Oh, there's Hera here.
Jesus Christ!
Where did I go?
Okay.
Oh, there were Googles here.
I didn't even see this.
I wish.
all right oops all Zeus we saw a report suggesting that you
made it to the lowest oh I forgot wait I already gave her a
gift not yet it seems a sign of progress nonetheless oops
all Zeus god he's so obsessed with me to be fair I think
he's like fucked every all the gods and goddesses so like
I'm like the only one left so he's trying too hard all right
creates a fisher that deals long line one uncle no okay you
know it's true that zeus would fucks everything that's your
uncle brus read up zeus lord it doesn't care zeus doesn't
care
guys he does not care
Yeah, but I feel like my double attack uses it up more.
I'll grab more mana, actually.
Oh, shit.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, we're going to grab this out of the way, too.
I should have done it.
I should kill everything as well.
Yay!
Oh, hey, there's extra rooms, too.
That's good.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot of them.
Nice.
Extra health.
Get in here.
I need your ash.
You can't say gross.
You all know he does not care.
He doesn't even care if you're an animal.
And we can't still get the...
It locks out?
Oh, are you... I didn't know.
Oh, I didn't know it locks out, guys.
I would have went to them.
the other zeus they gave me three zeuses i didn't know i
thought i could get all of them oh i don't mean i got more
magic i wasn't reading when you told me guys farewell aphira
uh you know i didn't read the moment you told me you should
have told me early you should have told me when i was
reading you've come to aid me even here lord karon though i
imagine not even you can travel much farther where i'm
headed
average american child jokes on you i'm canadian jokes on
you
hey poseidon
no i thought like i do all the pylons and they'll still be
there you know the rooms will still be there i didn't know i
had to pick and choose came towards other oh wait yeah
Gamba, Gamba.
All is possible.
Across the river Akaram, the underworld boatman travels
between realms through hidden borders, unseen as a shadow in
the dark.
Is there anywhere Lord Gamba can grow?
It says, oh my god, that's a lot of dead sheep.
Oh, it's a Cyclops!
Oh no.
The Cyclopean Shepherd.
Why does he have eyes on his nipples?
What do I owe you for the inconvenience?
I can pay.
Oh, you pay.
What?
What did I do?
Your sheep will come back, I swear.
That's how he sees.
Why do you just raise cows?
No one told you to fuck.
raise sheep only.
Like there's no...
Jesus Christ, I don't know what he does.
Oh my god, that's what he does.
Oh, that's what he does.
Okay.
Okay, I get it now.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, let me go!
Let me go!
Oh my god, I didn't know he could grab you.
Oh my god, he's a grappler.
He's a fucking grappler.
Oh my god.
The man's a grappler.
Jesus Christ.
Rumba!
Wow!
Okay.
I'm, like, so scared to go up to him.
Wow!
Okay.
I'm gonna send another one in.
Oh my.
Oh, God, he's fucking ripping it.
He's shredding it.
Jesus, no!
Okay, that one was new.
That one was new.
I'll send another one in.
Oh, God.
Nice.
Oh, I got him.
I splashed his Achilles heel.
Nice.
Oh, you sleeping now.
Yeah.
Oh, this is where I get the wall.
Okay, so that's how I get wool.
Alright, first tribe.
First tribe.
He got sleepy.
He got really eepy after.
Oh, hey.
I got the city.
It must be where Polyphemus lives.
Okay, I get wool.
That's fucking right.
Give me your wool.
Oh, that's a lot of dead bodies.
okay drink the fountain and then oh i got food wait what the
fuck where was that food uh i guess concave i'll do that
what the why are there so many dead bodies here yeah i got
wood from it all right we'll go this way hit the sheep to
get the wood Oh, no.
Not the water level.
Oh, no.
Oh.
The water levels are the worst.
Hey, cat.
Hello, cat.
You want to join my crew?
Oh, it's like an ocelot.
Oh.
Ran off.
You didn't want to join my crew.
I'm not cool enough.
I don't understand.
I'm cool.
No ships risen from the depths.
Oh, shit.
All headed for Olympus.
My dragoons say I'm cool.
There's it.
Say that again.
I failed the vibe check.
Take me away.
He sent some dog poppers, an idiot.
of being the closest ship i'll take it guys i'm cool right
guys am i cool guys am i cool guys yeah yeah guys guys come
on come on go speak truthfully the sticklers
Okay.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, is that my god?
Yeah, that is.
All right, palm tab.
You automatically inflict a weak when you claim other work.
We should get more Gamba, right?
Three.
Your special deal is more damage and then flicks.
I feel like two?
No Gamba?
Okay.
More Gamma.
Come on, guys.
More Gamma!
How about Gamma where?
Alright.
Yeah, more damage in this lake.
Look at that.
Downers!
Now we get to every time.
Let it ride.
You're right.
Now I have two gambas.
Never stop.
All in.
Guys.
That's not gonna blow up, right?
There we go.
All in on the gamba.
Nice.
I got tree break.
Ride it.
Ride the high.
Drop Blitz.
What the fuck is that?
No idea.
They should be in a different color of their part of my
crew.
I'm literally so confused which one is mine.
Like, I know it has a giant heart, but still.
It's so confusing sometimes.
Alright.
I think you're cool, Jokey.
But, seriously, why do I know?
Bama, you think you're the super chat.
You're not a loser!
I believe!
You're cool!
We're all cool!
But Jokey, if we're all cool, then we're not cool.
How can we all be cool?
Oh, wait.
I think more magic, mostly.
And there's no...
one that's not cool and no one is cool yeah
all right he's still there believe okay my guy died i don't
believe no more all right nice more magic oh wait we'll do
moon now so much magic.
Okay, it's summon.
Like, I think we have enough magic.
I say as I'm, like, love... I used it all up.
Don't worry, guys.
We have enough.
One.
One is still enough, guys.
Alright, minions.
Trace, servants, steal more.
Okay, we need... What is this?
Attack 75% faster.
Do we aim for the purple?
Guys, one, two, three, four, five.
Okay, do we aim for the purple, guys?
Try to go for blue.
Aim for top blue.
Oh!
Go for this.
The third blue.
Aim for this.
Okay.
There you go.
One with Selenie.
Alright.
We get Pissat.
What the fuck?
How do I kill that?
There's no mistaking it.
How the fuck do I kill this?
Can't shoot that.
Oh, okay, never mind, I can.
Wait, does that mean like I can just...
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
Oh, my...
Okay, oh, there he is.
Whoa.
Oh, did I get hit by that?
Can't tell.
Okay, this is not fair.
I don't have anything.
All right.
Where is he going?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, that's where it's going.
Oh, shit.
That makes sense.
I was like, where the fuck is it going?
Okay.
What the fuck hit me?
Oh, it hit him.
Okay.
I'll shoot this guy.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, that's a lot.
That's a lot.
Oh, I don't like that.
Okay, that's five.
All right.
That's five.
Jesus, fuck!
It was not five.
Yeah, it's okay.
All right, last one.
Last one.
GK, there's still one more.
I can tank it.
Yeah!
Vanquished.
Now I'll get Poseidon.
That was a mini-boss?
Jesus Christ.
That was so much for a mini-boss.
Was that an actual just mini-boss?
I feel like that's so much.
Oh my, yeah, that's so fucking hard.
I literally lost 100 HP for the mini-boss.
Pose were powerful.
When every sprint hit the first foe, Oh, yeah, we should get
this.
Three, right?
Three or one.
Damien hits with a powerful three.
Yeah.
Oh, yay!
I'll get bonus.
Oh, it's just money.
Oh, and another!
Yay!
More money!
Wait, that's bad.
There you go.
I got money.
Whoa!
Flagship.
Oh.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, I guess Zeus, look at that.
The cast caused lane moths to repeatedly strike one floor at
a time and a blind serve.
Take damage, your flow is struck by lightning.
Your lane boss effect may strike two times.
One or three.
Gamba always wins, exactly.
And another.
One?
Annalise.
Zeus came home.
Um, I'm making a 4 to everything.
Technically.
And special deals more damage and hitch.
Your cast costs Oh, wait.
Two.
Every... Or three?
Or three.
Glamour gain, right?
Three.
That's good.
Yeah, I get more magic.
Oh, God.
The main boss fight's gonna be hell.
I am not equipped for... Jesus!
I am not equipped for it.
Get shocked.
Oh, my God.
That's my team.
Wait, can I summon two?
Oh, no.
I can only summon one.
Alright, Hermes or Palm?
Chat.
Hermes or Palm?
Herm?
Hermes.
We'll do Hermes then.
Jesus, what the fuck?
I've seen this guy before.
This is my first time seeing that guy.
Nice.
Okay, I'm getting more recharge though at least.
My guys just slowly walk.
Bro, I killed this guy.
them all you didn't do nothing he's just slowly walking up
your chance are more likely cure except for where are my
other chance base effects your moves are faster these all
suck three three effects gamma oh gamma next god damn it
We'll do all right.
I gotta summon something better
Okay Damn it Oh my god.
Okay, that's a lot We have something these guys actually
Yeah, these guys can move faster.
I like that It's something who moves faster There we go More
hate health Yeah!
All right, shop time.
Another shop.
Double shops.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there's the golden apple!
Your attacks and specials are stronger.
Your cast gains power and knocks foes away.
Oh, oh, but it's holding.
I never hold.
Your move, press and hold attacks special or cast.
and mute them but use three at the start of your attacks are
stronger okay yeah i don't use my mega cast oh now grab the
food i guess i got glamour gain all right how do i fight
this oh this is gonna be scary new boss time
god it's here coincidence running into you like us so far
away from home where are you headed I could give you a lift
Of course, it's not She's not Never comes true Thanks You
sure about that?
You sure about that?
Because it looks like You've been having A pretty rough
night Oh, I wonder why I wonder why I wonder why this game
Is saving me so fucking long, Ares I don't care For your
insinuations here Wow, don't kiss your favorite character
Your best friend Enemies to lovers, right?
We'll never be go past enemies.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, how do I kill her?
Oh.
Oh my god.
She has a gun.
What do I do?
Bro, she has a gun.
a gun reloading what's she doing wait what is she doing okay
what the fuck okay okay that that's factual bullshit oh my
god
Okay, that's good to know That's good to know Plus a hundred
percent damn it
Oh my god, that's actually bullshit
Oh my god, where did she go?
Jesus Christ Oh my god, of course she's like of course she
flies over way.
I'll fucking course.
Oh my god, please.
The moment I kill him, are you fucking...
Oh my god, I can summon.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Oh, thank god!
Oh, wait, no.
She died.
Ah!
Oh, thank God!
My minion did have what's worse than dying by me?
Dying by an NPC!
Imagine dying to an NPC.
Couldn't be me.
Minion with the clutch, bro.
Do you think my minion's okay?
He's just standing in the fire.
Oh, that's worse.
That's looking worse.
that's that oh I'm in Olympus now
oh my god need as much fucking health as possible guys is
this the last area if it's the last area should I get the
death defiance or the knuckle bones I should get the is this
the last area no no okay we'll get the not the last two more
okay we'll get the knuckle bones in.
Boneser.
Teeth.
I'll die to this boss.
Okay, should I get toothed in?
I'll do death pin.
The fuck is death pin.
Okay, I'll get toothed in.
It's very hard.
Guys, okay, two for it, bones, guys.
The fuck is in grade pin.
This?
Is goaded?
Just go Toof.
Okay, I'll go Toof.
Okay.
I'll use Toof.
Alright, this is apparently where I definitely will die.
Alright, we'll find out.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see how close I am to dying.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna summon.
him.
Look at this.
There you go.
I didn't even expect it to get blocked.
Prophecy for Toad?
Money.
I'm gonna get a hammer for sure.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh my god.
I did not expect this.
This is a lot.
Okay, I think this is the... Oh my god, it's the weaker one.
Yeah.
Yeah, why are you attacking me?
I thought we cool.
Are we not cool?
Oh my god, we are not cool.
We are definitely not cool.
Okay, I want to summon the...
There we go.
Yeah, I wanted to summon that.
That one seems cooler to summon.
It seems like it do more, too.
Jesus, they're so tanky, too.
Apparently are not my friends.
Your special gains, your special fires to protect at your
attack, deals, and also strike side.
I do charge attack a lot more.
I feel like I do charge attack a lot more, though, for real.
Susan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, this all sucks, but 99% of Gamma's quit before they
hit big.
You are the 1%.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Two for shotgun DPS?
Oh, maybe that's better.
Okay.
Oh, you're right.
We'll do shotgun.
I'm grateful Daedalus.
Oh, wait.
That's my guy.
Magic?
I feel like health.
I'm going to go for health.
I think I charge enough magic in general.
Okay.
There you go.
Where are the others?
Okay, there you go.
Jesus!
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, these guys are very annoying.
For real.
Alright.
Summon him.
Alright, more HP.
Yay!
Another!
Yeah.
Uh, money?
We'll go...
I don't think I need that much money, so we'll go Harrow.
Gamba!
Oh my god, I fucking...
There you go.
Nice.
That's good.
These guys are very annoying.
Oh my god, that's a dragon.
There you go.
I want to summon the dragon now.
The dragon looks cool.
He looks so cool.
Like, how much damage did I took?
Your moves create a fisher.
Your damage effects for each boom.
Plus three.
I say join the count when you cast damage any foes whenever
they...
Whatever they appear.
Wait, three, right?
We'll go three.
Oh, hey, a flower.
Oh, another Poseidon.
Okay, uh, we'll grab Poseidon.
Poseidon or magic?
I don't think I need more magic because I have the regen.
Right?
Right, guys?
It should be fine if I go for...
Yeah, I have a lot.
lot of regen, so it should be fine.
Regen is super slow.
Okay, well that's too late, guys.
Guys, it's too late.
I already did it.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
I thought it'd be someone else.
Okay.
Holy fuck, that's a lot of...
That's a lot of armor.
Oh.
Oh my god, they have so much armor.
Nice.
Holy shit, that was so much armor.
Oh!
Is that chaos?
Oh, I know, that's just a choice.
Your moves also launched...
God, I can't even get any duels.
But you prime his surrounding foes with power splashes, they
start to strike.
Also launch a wave.
I don't cast it enough.
Also launch a wide wave.
Yeah, I think I'm just going to do this.
I'm going to prime it.
It should be fine.
Yeah, I have enough for it.
Alright, Hera or Zeus chat.
Which is better for me?
Hera or Zeus?
Zeus?
Is that better stuff for me?
Alright, it's a boss fight, though.
Alright, mini boss fight time.
We might lose our death.
Defiance.
Please tell me you're smarter than the other automatons
around here.
Oh, we don't get help, too.
And that's the worst part.
Oh, my God, please.
Please be nice to me.
Oh, my God.
I'm burning myself, too.
Oh.
That's fine.
Oh, fuck.
That's okay.
Oh.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
What the fuck?
Oh god.
Please get close.
Oh!
Okay, not that close.
Too close.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Nice.
Oh, I lost a lot of HP though.
Oh, I lost too many HP.
I just didn't know what he does.
Mindless machinery and nothing more The numerous defensive
capabilities of terrifying Talos The most powerful Yeah, six
feet apart Two guys sitting in the hot tub Six feet apart
because they're not gay
Can't self-repair, you're dead
Seven and wild Whoa, geez, whoa taken up the cause not to
mention the spear oh is affidavit here yeah for there are
those against whom not even my feminine don't pray for duos
to lose the boons oh what do you mean i wanted duos though
The gift.
But I got the duo.
I chose the duo.
I don't know if it's bad or not.
But I did it.
Oh my god.
Wait, this guy is crazy.
Wait, I summoned him.
He seems fucking insane.
Jesus Christ are you fucking kidding me holy shit what is
going on oh my god I might lose that I'm losing one from the
I'm losing it from the minions oh my god I'm so scared like
I don't know what's going on what the fuck is going on oh my
God these enemies are crazy no these guys are insane just
dodge okay I got dodge better for these guys these guys do
so much um one or two I hate the stat I don't I don't like
the snipers at all.
Raceprint hit the first foe run into Blastenex.
One?
One.
Okay.
We'll do one.
Oh, nice!
Another one!
Alright, we can get two then.
Yeah, we can grab two here.
A fishing point.
Hey, it's just one at one and two.
So then we got one and two.
Palmerheart.
I don't think more health is going to help me anymore.
I don't know.
Do I need...
HP?
Or Pob?
Yeah, I think I might need him more.
I don't even know who he's trying to fight.
Like, who is this guy trying to kill?
Oh, God.
I got this.
I'm gonna use cover right now like I definitely need cover
there you go oh my cover is definitely gonna help me here oh
thank God oh thank God I'm like trying to use as much cover
as possible um okay there's palm oh they're like fuck zeus
here oh wait sun oh wait i should get moon so i can increase
my right moon is better yeah moon for the are they fighting
each other i'll let them fight each other
yeah i'm getting the auto seekers first fuck these guys
That's smart.
See, look at that.
I let them fight each other.
Oh, wait.
That's my teammate.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Get him.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Is he- Oh, he's bad!
He's bad.
He's a bad eagle.
He's a bad eagle, guys!
Oh my god, what the?
Oh my god.
What the fuck happened?
Oh, I'm so dead.
I am so dead.
I'm already so dead.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I'm actually, I'm not okay.
USA, USA, USA.
That eagle took a hundred of my HP!
That eagle hits so fucking hard!
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Plus five percent.
But then my servant's still ten percent more damage though.
Oh, I'll do that.
Fuck it.
I want more damage.
Go, Freenos.
be free jesus i'm going to the shop fuck this i'm going to
the shop i need hp there we go sort of yeah give me hp
okay okay but i could still gamba oh i didn't give it to me
all right all right take your foot struck you're straight
okay i feel like crime's fine i have region i'm i'm gonna do
it too oh my god i don't even get another zeus oh my god oh
is that the ego that fucked me up earlier oh is that is that
why you're like you're gonna die is that it is that
That's gonna fucking kill me.
It gave me a little sneak peek.
Yeah Yeah, yeah, no.
Yeah, it gave me it gave me a little sneak peek there.
Yeah Yeah, I saw it Stop right there Here comes the
unexpected wrinkle in my master's plan.
Oh my god I know who you are lost daughter of Hades Eagle is
the least of my problem.
Should I just mine that rock?
I'm gonna go find the rock
Prometheus from the alias movie I'd not heard you were
liberated or that Kronos is the master you serve solidarity
between Titans then yeah we'll go get the rock who's been
star against my kind but no more this is my attempt at
atonement what by leading this reckless assault i never took
you for a coward oh is that the one where the eagle picks
his guts out every time yeah who gets yeah the eagle eats
his guts how the fuck they're working together now give me
who spends on oh guys yes i'm not that sure i i am a bit
terminally online but like i don't know everything no chance
at all yeah how did he tame Oh my, I'm farming this
Hit my head He'll be sick I'm gonna grab another rock Guys,
I got the rock Oh my god, I still got hit by it Wait, I can
grab another one Yes, I did that grab another rock
What the fuck What the fuck Jesus oh my god he does so much
he actually does so much
Yeah, I didn't dodge it though.
I didn't dodge it correctly.
What okay.
What?
Oh oh oh So confused oh
It's like, what?
Okay.
Last chance.
Yeah, no, I'm not first trying this.
I'm so confused.
Holy shit.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Okay, I get it now.
Okay, this...
one two three okay oh my god i don't know
i can't remember oh my god that's so hard what the fuck i
was like okay but what comes after that i was like what
comes after that though
Oh my god So what's the deal with the horned guy anyway Saw
him a nemesis chatting like they were an item Alright It was
weird Okay I need to say number I get it now I get it The
horned guy is Lord Moros Emissary of the three fates Our
distinguished guest And a valuable ally Oh I got like He was
like one third life left He had one third left.
Looks like we really put him up in style.
Okay.
I gotta remove.
I gotta see.
It's such a long pattern!
The pattern was so long, chat!
Oh my god, you bitch.
I'll pick up you.
It sucks that I will pick up your rags.
I need it.
You traitor.
How dare you stand against me in our- I know!
That's why I've been saying!
Show your face again here.
No, it was five.
It wasn't three, guys.
The second one was more than three.
Sorry, babe, but I'm not going anywhere.
Think Nixon, Hecatee, and their...
Okay, I didn't understand what it was.
The first time I was so confused what the attack was.
I thought, like, I was like, why is it like picking it?
Like, is it a Gamba?
I merely mistook you for one of...
I thought it was a Gamba!
I didn't understand.
It was my first time seeing the attack.
I thought it was going to pick a random thing.
I was just like, what the fuck is he doing?
No, that was me, all right.
Then I had a great time.
Hey, I was like, I don't know.
Is she gambling?
I think I made clear.
I wasn't on your side.
Then you serve Kronos.
That's right.
Kronos sympathizer.
Oh, I've got more psyche, though.
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah, I got the rock.
I was just farming the rock.
I was just like...
All right, let's see.
That is like, I'm at least I can crit the rock before it
fucking kills me.
Alright, review the aspects when they're free to empower
each main weapons.
Okay, let's do that.
I mean, I have a lot of stuff, yeah.
It's aspect time.
I seek their aspects hidden from my sight.
Yeah.
As you say.
What else did I get?
I may have paid pretty far for my first try.
on the... What was this?
Nice contained and eternal.
For my first try on the surface?
Come night.
Reveal the guarded treasures of this realm.
See that, sisters.
Alright, what else?
I'll grab it.
I'll just grab everything.
No purging pool of Tartarus.
Alright.
Nice.
What's this?
Reveal hidden aisle where you me a story.
Okay, yeah, we need that.
Iron and dry wood.
Uh.
Alright.
Let's pick this up.
And then start farming again.
We're farming.
The embodiment of sleep doses interminably in a private.
Alright, we can do the last grandpa run.
We'll do the last grandpa run.
And And then we'll go back to the surface.
Because I just need one more grandpa to run anyway for the
sand.
It gladdens me to see you, Hecatee.
I have observed the stalemate upon Olympus holds.
Although the Titan Kronos musters forces in Afera still.
Shall I continue monitoring them?
Yes, Selene do.
Blasted Afera is the closest exit out of here.
Do you suppose they are prepared for a single assailant to
weave through their ranks?
isn't it ready the titan's forces are somewhat in disarray
thus no i do not think they are sufficiently prepared for
one of us all right we got this guys i believe in this break
i guess all right let's grab more psyche oh i can finally
yeah i can afford this now activating all surrounding cards
god damn it Uh, I have an ash.
I don't have enough ash, though.
I can't.
Uh, fuck it.
Alright, well...
We'll do one more.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I can upgrade!
Right?
Yeah!
Okay, I can upgrade my weapons now.
So much to choose for.
Oh, I can get this too.
Grab this.
Black code.
Oh, fuck.
that wait is this good or bad is this a good oh my god i got
missiles so ancient is the pitch black stone it predates
time itself oh it's op okay we'll try it seems to drain what
light and color well how come we didn't have this technology
wait wait a minute our aspect
okay how much is each of them And what's this?
I can only aspect the staff.
Which is the most busted for the staff, chat?
Which one is the most busted one for this?
Circuit?
When so does you're forming a psychic leash.
Oh, wait.
Moments?
Each fire in place up to until you...
Wait.
Aww.
Whenever you use it, each fire is in place up to three times
until you use it again.
Circa with fire or lightning ring.
What the fuck?
My lightning ring.
Like, was that even mean, guys?
Circa, it busted too.
We'll use turrets for each of...
Oh!
Okay, we'll try Circa first.
I'll try it.
I only have a frog, though.
What's this?
I'll try it.
Oh, shit.
What?
Is this default?
This is the default, right?
Is this the default one?
Yeah, reading is very hard.
Oh, okay, so this is the default one.
Okay, I get it.
Yeah?
Okay.
Um...
I'll do...
Which to use fast.
I'm gonna go grab water real quick, guys.
I need to get water.
Back with water and I peed.
Alright.
Also, that...
is here too you want he's inside now i'm back everyone uh
many nexi zekra coyote papa thank you with super chat thank
you thank you all right let's try this out all right we're
gonna do oh he wants to talk and transpired with the silver
puddle back there i could tell young one you're doing a
perchance that of the fates themselves I've revealed in the
pool the aspects of the nocturnal arms Not their truth I was
just seeing what he's doing But different ones with their
own great power Ah the nocturnal arms Your brother he once
used their counterparts And those ones too turned into other
stuff Well if you need to test your newfound strength I'm
here I know it commander Alright whoops I didn't want to
look at the sun Or the moon Sorry the moon Oh my god that's
scary oh my god fine you can leave he's like looking at you
wanted to come inside like not anymore okay he like looked
at the door he like looked at the door is like leave i want
to leave all right okay i'll create the aspect too how oh
lingers for two seconds you explode and he's one of the best
if you stuck on your... Oh, I need bronze still for that.
Oh, wait.
I need... Oh.
Oh, I can keep upgrading it.
Wait.
Oh, I might as well.
I mean, I can't...
I might as well.
I'll try this first.
I mean...
Everyone says the circuit one is pretty good, so I'll try it
first.
Where's my... Oh, yeah.
I wanted to do the time trials.
Okay, Let's do the time travelers.
Oh my god, just got my upgraded staff.
Are you kidding me?
Alright, okay, it's just the woods.
It's just the woods.
I can do the woods.
Alright.
Yeah, it's just the woods.
It's fine.
Thank you for that.
I can observe more clearly both the outcome of your trial
and all else.
all right your specials jesus okay oh my god i'm gonna do
attack oh my god we have so much hp why am i afraid
why would i be scared okay what's the catch what's the catch
guys guys what's the catch
What's the catch?
Guys, there's no way.
Oh, it's the first run.
Oh, it's the baby one.
Okay, there's no catch.
The catch is that it ends.
Okay, that's good to know.
Best shows are 25% faster.
Your tax hasn't arranged and deals 100%.
two times oh fuck i don't have magic mana region i forgot i
haven't seen apollo in a long time there's so many gods now
this might be a bad pick just because i don't have mana
region oh i don't need who needs mana region look at my mana
prometheus himself leading the assault against us one of our
soul allies amongst titan kind yeah i know i was like my
mana is so hot He knows which side shall be victorious when
all is said and done.
Wait, Apollo doesn't believe in us!
Area.
Our spirits faster inflict days on surrounding foes.
Wait, which one do we want?
One or two.
You know what?
I have so much shit I'm gonna do too.
I'm like, I literally have the god build.
Like, I'll never die.
Who cares?
Let me just tank it all.
Yeah, it doesn't really matter.
Gaining random end.
No, I'll keep my money.
Actually, fuck it.
What does it give me?
Charity bottle discovered.
Yeah, I'm going to speedrun this.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I was going to say, what are you doing here?
Oh my god, look at the fucking region.
Before they expire.
Alright, this one.
Like, it doesn't even matter.
I literally cannot die.
Like, I'm so strong.
Holy fuck.
I'm actually so fucking strong.
My god, you guys just died.
Alright, palm time.
I'll be- I'm so fast now.
i'm so fucking fast you know what even faster oh hey nice
for heels most of the others are holding out at the top of
olympus and you are the reinforcements so come on back when
you can all right hey uh your moves are faster your attack
even faster oh my god a thousand and five i'm fast as boy oh
and money too
I'm just all speed.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
That's actually crazy how fast I am.
Um, something is foot here on Olympus.
Rumblings, yet not even Poseidon knows the source.
Well, whatever cowardly maneuver Kronos has in store, we're
going to repel it.
With your aid, perhaps.
As me.
Tax influx, blitz, oh my god.
and blitz too the underworld of hades holds more than the
souls of the dead all right after you just restore it gain
25 now might as well which way oh i should oh wait i don't
need heals i was like oh i didn't see what it is i saw it
was hbi guys i don't think i need more hp i i think i'm fine
on that i'm most definitely fine the hp department let us
together shine this night a moon this strange sensation i
remember what it is the whims of chaos affecting our
surroundings even if in size i have a thousand hp i think i
have more than enough guys not chance okay your xandra's
that inflicts morph on up to five oh wait does bosses i
forgot it doesn't right yeah no we'll just get the we'll
just get this affidavit
a thousand and twenty five is better than a thousand okay
that is true
hmm you are right does seem a little bit better
Yeah.
Oh my god, he had to walk away.
Though I admit to having some small weakness for the tall,
dark, and brooding types.
How is this?
This is a long-ass forest.
He's defacing our beautiful mountain.
Yeah.
I know.
The mountain was so pretty.
Create a heartthrob.
Oh.
Now for the rest.
Guys, I don't need more.
I don't think I need more.
Feel more damage to nearby foes.
Guys, we don't need more.
Guys, guys, we don't need more.
I have a feeling we might not need more.
Yo, try hard, sub.
Oh, I didn't even see the one.
I didn't even know what that was over there.
Olympus, I accept this message.
Yeah.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I fight Chaos?
Wait, you're not chaos.
That pitch black stone in our training grounds.
I've sensed it ever since your incantation.
A subtle influence of chaos on this realm.
Our goals are intertwined.
When I gaze upon the stone, I begin to see different paths
and possibilities in every facet.
Some leading closer to our victory.
It's very much disquieting.
know the choices that we make might all be pre-ordained to
some extent uh-huh i will say i'm not really like that
concerned right now are you fucking really wait where's the
third one i was like where is she oh wait that's not what i
wanted whoops oh my god
Okay.
Are you fucking okay?
It's fine.
I have like literally so much HP.
I still have a lot.
Alright.
There you go.
God damn it.
It's fine.
I didn't get hit though.
Alright, last one.
There you go.
It's fine.
That should do like, that should just kill her.
Yeah.
I was gonna say that should just kill her.
You have grown strong.
Yay!
That's me!
She's talking about me, guys.
Alright, nice.
I got the chaos dust.
I did as chaos asked.
I got the thing.
Oh!
Reality restored.
That was easy.
That was for babies.
Okay, nice.
Oh?
Oh, okay.
Now I have this.
Okay.
I don't...
I can't do anything with it.
Alright, let's try this.
Let's try this one out for the first run.
For the...
Let's see if we can make it to Grandpappy.
Wait, what?
Oh, there's more.
What the...
What?
Oh, that's a lot harder now.
It's a lot...
It looks a lot harder.
Alright.
Make some dog treats?
Oh, shit!
You're right!
To get the pets.
I can grab this now.
Ah, that's a nice touch.
Not even the wiles and stratagems of that resourceful sack
of cities.
Odysseus may be sufficient to overcome the tight...
How do I make that dog treat here?
This should work.
What's this?
Jesus, there's so much stuff now.
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, there you go.
We gotta make the dog treat.
Yeah!
Alright, now we have doggy treats, too.
And we're a psyche.
Alright, let's head over.
Let's try the new weapon.
God, I'm so fast.
Alright.
Alright, let's do.
I'll get you, Kronos.
All right, Poseidon.
Man, I'm fucking...
I'm like that girl, that girl in League of the In Arcane.
Or whatever her name is.
All right, attacks hit flows with a splash that knocks other
foes.
Your special, Winner Sprint.
Special hits foes with splash that knocks.
My special is my right.
I feel like it knocks other foes.
The one that punches.
One red.
Yeah, Jane Arcade.
Oh my god.
Whoa.
Damn.
That shit was crazy.
I did not expect that.
Okay.
What is the...
I don't know about her.
Okay, her...
I will say...
Her right-click cast is not that cool.
I don't think her right-click cast is...
it's that strong.
Unless I'm wrong.
I could be wrong.
I'm always... I'm wrong quite often.
Omega normal is a shield.
Time of need here.
We need to get to the bottom.
Oh, wait, boons?
Okay.
Any game is worth more.
Ooh.
And cast your faster.
Alright, guys.
Two or three.
I only need that much money.
Okay.
Um...
Do?
Okay, wait, what is the...
Is that the shield?
Wait, what's just the shield?
This one?
Oh, I can't do it.
Wait, what gives the shield?
Left click or right click gives shield.
Which one gives it?
Hold for it.
Oh, for the shield.
Oh!
Oh shit.
I do so much damage though.
Holy fuck.
Left click.
Okay.
Yeah, no.
My left, yeah.
I feel like my...
It does so much damage.
Oh, I haven't seen the meter in a long time.
Jesus Christ, that's a lot of damage.
Oh my god.
BAM!
Oh, I blocked it!
Yeah, no, I do a lot.
I haven't seen the meter in a long time.
I have so many gods now.
Oh, I might make some spicy noodles for dinner.
Because my gums are full.
I think my gums are fully healing them.
Well, not fully, but they're healed enough.
Like, it's okay.
I think we'll be fine.
Yeah, it's bulldog time.
Toki, no.
That's the risk I'm willing to take.
One, okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, spider?
No, spider?
We'll grab armor.
Gamma time.
It's Gamma time, guys.
I believe in the power of Gamma.
There you go.
Oh No, what is that and then Vivian.
Oh, yeah, I brought a frog next thing they give a super chat
that you think carbonara of course I do have ros ros is
also really good I think I get the carbonara as a classic
Frinos is a friend a familiar friend of mine in fact.
He means you no harm at all Your stature flies however,
that's we may need to safeguard Oh That is a relief or rose
If indeed you are a friend, then you are welcome here.
And if you'd like a bite to eat...
I'm running talk about tonight, so I too am playing Gamba.
Alright, let's see.
It's where I read Dawn that grants plus five.
That creates plus one now.
I don't use that much magic, right?
Do I... I mean, do use a...
Actually, I do.
One, right?
One is better.
Yeah.
how does that feel oh grab this that's actually what we need
to oh and we get chaos does it hit my armor no it doesn't
okay oh and he has the rainbow rocks all throughout the
underworld but now Kronos works to be shaped around to suit
his practices however there shall always be darkness here in
this space and I have made it visible to you all right oh
i'm grateful for this gift another incantation okay restore
three next encounter you channel your moves faster
uh one or two i feel like i have one or two one right all
right let's grab some rocks too
Fuck, I have a lot of money.
From nothingness Spring Old Creek.
I feel like I have a lot of money to spend right now,
though.
Should I just spend money?
Is it worth it?
I'll get a shop later anyway.
That's true.
I mean.
I stunned him.
There you go.
That's fast.
Whoops.
I forgot.
I mis- misclick.
Mis-input.
Oh my god.
This freeze is so good.
That would be better with attack though.
Remember that.
Boy, I take my everything I said about your weapon first.
We met.
In my defense, and often I see workmanship superiors of
mine.
Though, don't go tell them anyone I said he's much.
Okay, your special can cause when you take damage.
Oh wait isn't this good for my weapon isn't one good I
feel like it is right yeah one would be really good because
I'd be like boom did it kill him I can't tell I can't use
magic right now though I I gotta be very careful.
I'm trying not to charge it up.
Okay, nice.
Jesus Christ, I'm so strong right now.
Okay, this weapon is pretty good, I will admit.
Enough of this.
Nectar, wait, what?
Oh, that's a prophecy.
Oh, they're material.
Oh, I'll grab material.
Oh, only first rocket are you serious?
I thought oh my god, I swear to god if you kill I swear to
god She takes my shop and even still it's not enough.
Some help they are Direct your criticism to the gods
themselves now.
What is it you want with me?
I want a little taste of all that power I swear to god if
she steals my shop.
Come on.
I'll trade you Oh receive for it bro I already have so much
money I know oh okay I guess I'll take HP I guess I'm
already so rich I don't need more money in game in game in
game just so you in game guys in game just
just a reminder okay there you go that That should be all
the chaos stuff, right?
Okay, now I can do this.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I took damage?
Now to the matter at hand.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, we gotta get to the shop.
That's the last shot, right?
Yeah.
Behold your queen.
We have a long-standing partnership with your good boat.
Typical streamer, am I right?
After a bit, he takes them Yonder to your realm Or used to,
anyway You hear that she doesn't need We're here to stick
and see Juicier and lobster Too buttery Thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you Guys, in game Guys, in game
I can't afford an Ermi's Birkin bag, guys I swear to God,
I'm not on the wait list For a Birkin bag I swear to God I'm
not on the two-year waitlist.
The likely story.
Guys, Gambo?
Gambo?
Vested in me.
Arctic ring.
What the fuck does it did it do?
How is it that strong?
I don't understand.
What makes it strong?
Each night I find it brimming with coins.
Which must mean technically I'm in your tent
And whatever you say my lord she awaits Time to visit Tell
me air we clash again Has your brother come to understand
yet the necessity of his participation in your task?
Oh 10 to 30.
Oh, that sounds good It's been a bit of a struggle.
He's found a suitable weapon in our father's spear that he
hasn't granted me its essence yet Then tell him what he
needs to hear if that is what it takes to spare him on i do
not like having to count on him any more than you but his
cooperation is an absolute necessity all right i need more
than his i'm doing my best i visited him seven times i'm
going to deceive him if that's what you suggest i suggest
nothing the task is yours as are not my fault achieve it but
achieve it he keeps going off topic i'm Trying to do the
thing.
There you go.
What?
Oh my god, my fucking armor.
Guys, I don't have regen anymore.
That's bad.
God,
I'm so fast.
Oh my god, I chose the wrong.
I chose wrong.
Okay.
Last one.
Oh, hey, flower.
Oh my god.
Oh my.
That was good.
Oh nice.
Okay, that was the right one.
There you go.
Okay, I deserve that.
Oh, duh.
Oh, okay.
That's okay.
That one's the easier one.
Oh my god.
Okay, I might be like trolling a little.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's the last one.
And then we'll freeze.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you...
Oh my god, I chose wrong again.
Oh my...
This might be the...
Okay, this...
I've taken so much damage.
This is the worst I've done against here.
Know only that I would not willingly confront...
She has done...
This one has the most random moveset she has ever done on
me.
Like, she has never cloned that much until now.
I passed the test.
And I managed...
Maybe I should not pick the flower.
Maybe I shouldn't have picked the flower.
Yeah, usually she never does the fucking clone shit.
Ain't sure any goods cost...
Uh, 3% less.
gain plus two now now we're fine hey whenever you enter a
location grab that again we have so much money yeah i got
too used to a thousand hp yeah yeah my children are crafty
to them you are nothing but a common tool and not an
especially sharp one it appears to me
All right, here you go.
Oh, and at that we can just do surface runs after that.
Because I should have everything I need, right?
All right, water time.
I'm sorry, money time.
Oh.
This?
Your ship beat up.
What the fuck?
What the?
Well, I'm trying to beat your ass up.
Hello?
Nice.
Okay, I really need to get regender for sure.
Holy shit, that's a lot.
Oh my god, that was so fast.
Okay, oh, fuck.
Like, I was like, that's alright.
Little Sim won't hurt anybody.
It hurt a lot.
Oh, I can't afford everything.
I'll buy a head first.
Show some of it and restore 150.
Give them redemption armor.
Mmm, two.
Wait, which one, chat?
Yeah, just exfoliating the skin real quick.
Just doing it with a little bit of treatment, getting a
little bit of sauna in.
Two might be good?
Three or two.
Aww.
I'll do too.
Oh, to one I don't want.
Thanks, I guess.
I was like, oh, she's gonna give me three.
Oh!
This woman was ever a twisted pathway through this world.
Yet I provide for him my light.
Nevertheless, he need not always find his way alone.
It's okay.
I didn't need it.
Oh, hey, nice.
Heels.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
We got the healed one.
Okay, that's good.
Zeus here.
We'll get Zeus.
We need Zeus anyway.
Might be able to grab Blitz too.
Okay.
What?
That didn't hit?
I thought that would hit.
Out.
Okay, that sucks.
Nice.
Lock time.
Oh, wow.
I didn't need to heal that.
I...
I was like...
Oh, my God.
Not the same.
Not the same!
I dubbed Sana!
That was an accident.
Olympus, I accept this message.
Gink dodge.
Hard target.
Most foes.
Okay, we'll get the slower.
Dash more frequent.
I don't think I need Dash that much.
I think I'm fat.
Oh hey, Narcissus.
Narcissus tab.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know, right?
God, I know.
I spoke to Echo about you.
Said you didn't mean to hurt her.
Though, perhaps I shouldn't have.
She responded in her usual way, but I could tell something
happened.
Bro, he broke so many people's hearts that Echo is just one
of the thousands.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm sure she'll find someone who thinks she's awesome.
Plenty of fish.
In the sea.
Yes, I've noticed.
So, has anybody ever fallen out of love with you?
Or do they all end up in the morning fields pining for you?
Yeah, it's his fault that he was just born so fucking
handsome, guys.
Oh, what a curse for him.
Love me much as much as me.
Freeze, bro.
I am my number one fan.
One boon, one palm, two.
I guess the pond, right?
Fuck it.
I'm getting the palm.
What did I get?
Molten touch.
Where's that?
Oh, okay.
Grab that.
He's just so handsome.
Guys.
Can you really blame him?
Like, he was born with such...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Oh, that was an accident!
I just took all of that.
Let's see, I can heal it.
Uh, forums, I guess your freeze effect lasts longer.
Are you clear?
In random boom, you have gains.
Oh!
Wait, three!
I just like tanked the entire thing.
Right?
Yeah.
Bit late.
Oh, whoop.
I took it anyway.
There's a lot of counters though, I'm pretty sure, right?
All right.
Okay, let's grab him there.
And then...
Jesus Christ, will it hit something?
Like, I'm like, hit something!
Okay, your special locks on faster and use this...
your special launch and fly!
Oh!
Let's turn if it's damage to armor.
Fuck, okay.
But...
Yeah, we have extra damage.
One or two.
Which is better, chat?
Three?
A lot of people are saying three.
Oh, wait.
Not a lot of people.
It's one guy spamming three That just Never mind I realize
It's one guy spamming three
Okay Pro almost won Pro almost won by voting Seven times
Alright 20% Let him have three.
Okay, we'll do two.
He almost got me there.
See you in the crossroads?
Oh shit, wait, I mean I'll do this just for more money.
Oh shit, wait, that's so fast.
Wait, this is actually so fast.
What's this?
What the fuck?
Alright, hard.
Guys, Kronos or shop, chat?
I don't know.
I don't know if Kronos is worth it.
Oh, Chaos.
Sorry, Chaos.
Sorry, they both start with CH.
Chaos, okay.
They both start with CH, guys.
I got confused.
Make sure you lose.
Fire spells.
Ooh.
Surin undercaste's 39 damage.
Oh, that's so rough.
Three is so rough right now.
Two.
Okay.
This is going to be rough because I have to fight.
Oh, I felt it.
Yeah, no.
Oh, shit.
I already took damage.
This is going to be rough because I'm fighting.
Oh, no.
Oh, I can't do space.
Oh my god, I have to dash across.
That's not fair.
I...
Or that's not...
I have to dash across that.
Okay.
Alright, one, two, or three.
Okay, it's just mana.
Yeah, at least it's just mana.
I need to use the basket again.
I'll be right back.
I drink.
I hydrate so much.
Alan, Zekro, Nexy, Papa.
They give us super cheap.
chat thank you thank you all right gain a barrier that stops
one instance of damage attack deals more but uses plus 10
two offense three defense well you guys know what the fuck
i'm gonna pick all in offense time the painter's back i went
outside touch grass but i'm back
down there hmm maybe you didn't notice the sign but that's
our private little area where fans are not yeah but i'm not
a fan oh shit i forgot to fish again happens to be built
atop a drain that spills into the morning fields below you
could always flush it's okay good for her i'm not a fan oh
you went looking through our work so what if a few ideas go
unused here and there if you don't cut you never get to the
good stuff all right here i go I'm so sure I'm not used to
it There you go It's okay we don't need that magic We're
already using it all up Does that mean I just can't dash
anymore If I just use it all up Like what does that mean for
me Oh my god thank god I healed
It's okay.
Oh god.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Okay, that's fine.
I'll just use up all my dash then.
Jesus Christ!
Oh god.
I got out.
Are you?
Oh, fuck, it's this way.
Let's go get it.
Oh, boy, whoa, I messed up.
I messed up a little bit.
I might be tanking it when I shouldn't be.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, girl, you gotta get out of there.
Come on.
Here you go.
Oh, my God.
Okay, this is bad.
Okay, I might have tainted a little too much, guys.
Oh,
no.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I messed up.
I messed up.
Yeah, here we go.
That's it.
That's again.
I still made it.
That was awkward.
It's okay.
We still made it, guys.
2 HP, guys.
I told you.
2 HP.
Not even close.
Let's go.
I grabbed this.
I have so much money.
I might as well.
More than enough, guys.
That's more than enough HP.
Guys, I don't know.
I don't know if this weapon is for me.
I think at the end, I think the staff is definitely the best
for me.
It has the best balance between everything.
Alright, I will grab.
I just realized I'm using all my magic.
I already forgot about the curse.
I already forgot the curse.
I was like, whoa.
What's that sound it's making?
Is that a bad sound?
Eh.
Surely that's not a bad sound, right?
Alright, nice.
I need more damage.
I am... I'm so weak.
Oh, wait.
Where am I?
God damn it, I used it again.
Okay, here you go.
I want to get rid of these guys first.
The Medusa's first.
Are you serious?
What the fuck hits me?
Oh, fuck this.
I don't need the mana.
There you go.
I have two more encounters.
God, I feel so slow.
Fuck it.
Oh, hey, Pat.
God damn it.
Was that it?
Another tree somewhere?
Is there another tree here?
No, I know there's a hammer.
I'm just trying to see if there's anything else I'm missing.
I definitely feel like I'm under DPS right now.
I'm under damage.
No, I know there's a hammer.
I'm just trying to see if there's another thing around me.
I walked by a tree.
God damn it, I knew I walked.
Oh, wait.
There must be a tree nearby.
I'm following the golden petals.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
No, yeah, the hammer's the only thing.
Look it.
Boom!
Yeah, I definitely feel very underpowered.
I feel like I could be stronger.
For sure.
My build is, like, not very ideal right now.
Yeah, it's low DPS.
Briefly gains plus five for up to five consecutive hits on
the same throw.
I don't think I can rely on that.
Uh, I'm going to do attacks faster.
Feels even.
Yeah.
If I attack faster, there's more DPS per second.
Uh, money.
Uh, power up my moon.
Yeah, at least I'll have like more DPS for it.
Where are the trees?
Oh, there's a tree.
Yay.
Alright.
Grab that tree.
Alright, moon money.
Oh, that's it?
There's no bonus items?
I'm so surprised there's no bonus items.
I expected, like, bonus shit.
Okay.
I stood that chance I had.
Nice.
Okay, now I can dash again.
Alright.
Let's see.
you gain one more hex your hex also restores any you lost
during the last two seconds when you hex you gain 50 I'm
just gonna grab that.
We're having more HP use plus one wait I don't need to deal
up 15 your hex restores magic uh grab this use your hex one
more time I'm gonna aim for the top
all right
okay we'll grab the money that's crazy there's no bonus
stuff i'm surprised about that i expected like bonus like
items here but i guess not this area is fucking cheap as
hell oh my gosh i need i need a heal this area is actually
so fucking cheap that was all of them can afford me oh no
i forgot about oh well it's like a fish
it's okay guys i can fish though i got i got anguish though
guys it's okay i can at least i can fish guys at least i
didn't say anything about about the don'ts at this I don't
know what he was like back when you met but he has a certain
vanity about him that official yeah I definitely have
anguish it's often like I'm not even there I'm not even
there not even there all right manifest okay okay copy of
your most recently came
Look at that.
Three, at least there's hope.
At least there's hope in three.
We're gonna have to meet her.
I think they caught a live one.
There we go.
That was bad.
Wanna beat up her first.
Oh my god, it literally just misses her.
That's crazy.
There you go.
There, a Naga freezer too.
Oh, that was fast.
That's what you get.
Thank God.
But money!
Alright.
You're gonna buy it.
The bonus is, if you, your cast deals more damage, if you're
in blinding circles, the bonus is double.
Two?
For freeze lasting longer?
Or one?
Or three?
All three of them are pretty good.
Two?
All right.
I have to double check to make sure I'm not getting one guy
by the same guy.
All right.
Let's grab the shop.
I mean, I bought the thing I might as well.
Oh my god, cannot fish.
Oh, hey.
Is this food?
Oh, it's seeds.
All right, here we go.
Oh, nice.
Another one.
Your sprint flicks deals damage when it does.
Your damaging effects from Olympia are strong for each plus
three.
How many do I have?
Um, I don't even know how many I've talked to.
I can't tell.
I can't tell with this.
This is not very helpful.
Uh, one is good.
I see one or...
Two, you need that damage.
That is true, I do.
Yeah, I'll do two because I'm very poor in damage right now.
Oh.
I have...
Oh, all common bones gain rarity.
At least two.
Oh, I have two of all of them.
I have two on all of them.
That should be good.
Yeah.
Haboon awakened.
Getting nice.
And I got another upgrade.
Okay, a lot of them got upgraded too.
That's good.
Alright, this one I don't know.
I don't know how... I feel like...
I'm not very good with this weapon.
Kronos must have kicked him out again.
Jesus!
Yeah, no, I am definitely not very good with this one.
Are you, oh my god, did I dodge it?
I can't tell.
Okay.
It's fine.
This isn't who you are.
All these demons.
We'll grab heals right now.
Honestly, it might be better for me to grab heals.
Okay.
I need more damage.
I'm so weak.
I am actually so fucking weak right now.
That doesn't hit me, right?
Are you serious?
Okay, that's fine.
You know what?
I'll grab heals too, just for the sake of it.
Am I in this?
Get out!
Oh.
No, I'll just do all.
I'll just full heal.
Oh!
Yeah, we did it again.
This is boundless rage and hides for now his fangs.
All right, that has to be the best Cerberus run.
I will admit, that is the best Cerberus one I've done.
But it was the worst Hecate run I've ever done.
need more damage that's all i need
all right oh wait i didn't even need to refill that i just
did it out of like i just did just to flex all right uh i'll
grab another chaos oh is this me sacrificing uh i don't need
money i have so much money right now in game in game in game
in the 80s in the 80s disclaimer disclaimer yeah
guys i don't need i have 600 gold yes i might need more hp
though this is not a lot of hp i'm not really happy about
that damn way to flex don't keep trying to press guys in
haiti's in haiti
jesus what the fuck of course it got blocked there you go
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Alright, nice.
We got the another chaos circle.
Yeah, I bought it.
I paid to win the chaos.
Oh, and a tier.
Oh, and another thing.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to rob chaos.
Like, I got so many chaos that he just doesn't want to talk
to me anymore.
Oh, wait, this is good?
This is good, right?
It's heroic.
That's me too.
I need more damage too.
It's really rough.
I can survive.
I can do it.
Oh my god, that's an encounter.
Please tell me.
No, it's not even an encounter.
It's not.
It's a Titan forever.
die we were related yet now i realize i've grown old and
wretched and rough can we said like super chast negative
money then since you are currently bawling and i see they
get a super chat they can thank you okay let's see it was my
wrath that brought me to this point and how can you possibly
let's pray to god i get all the side rooms let's pray to god
we did this to each other gods and titans doomed to live
forever you'd learn nothing all the while that's true when
you live forever like you get bored
oh hey i can deal more damage damage while dark your cast
launches a projectile that seeks bows the bounty circle
forms when it hits
i don't know if that's good
Wait, but how many times does it happen?
Three is good.
Three is for prophecy.
Three is nice.
Try three.
Let's see how it goes.
What does it go?
Okay.
All right, we'll try that.
All right, let's hope we get all the side rooms as possible.
Okay, that's fine.
We sort of... Alright, there you go.
There you go.
Alright.
Launch another one.
It's just all shocks.
Oh my god, I wanted to do something else.
That's five.
Oh my god, it's like moving to it too.
That's crazy.
What?
That hits me?
All right, please give me a side room.
Okay, nice.
Okay, we got a side room.
That's good.
Yeah, I'm trying.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
There's rats right now.
But no!
Oh, my God.
We're both residents.
Okay!
We're just...
I was like, bro, that's awkward.
That's a little awkward.
We're just looking at each other and be like, hmm.
Take.
Damn 20.
Winnership.
Whenever you take less.
Okay, I do not have six.
Unfortunately, I only have four, so I don't think that's
worth it.
Restore some.
Whenever you get resources, you spread.
I guess it's one.
I don't have six of this.
I have only four.
I don't think I'm going to get enough for it.
So I'm going to get one then.
Yeah.
I don't have it.
Oh, nice.
Oh, and then there's this too.
It's good.
All right.
Two more encounters.
I don't even remember what I'm encountering.
What I get from it.
Guys, I forgot already what I get from it.
It's been a while.
Oh, that's just awkward.
I mean, remember it's a cast.
Yeah.
All right, nice.
Well, I'll heal for it, just because I have this.
Yeah!
Oh, plus 60% damage.
Okay, I just got it.
That's good.
All right, how many do I have?
Five.
Oh, I can make it.
Okay.
What's this?
Grab this.
Then we'll grab this.
Alright, that's good.
Oh, hey, money!
Okay, I'm...
Whoops.
I accidentally missed.
That's okay.
Okay.
Nice.
Got the freeze in.
Oh, my God.
That's okay.
That should be the last one.
They're gone.
Alright.
That was...
thousand dollars.
Oh more.
Oh wait, that's a duo.
Wait, that was Hefany and Hefany.
What?
For free?
Oh!
I
take those.
Yay!
Oh.
But neither will I take these line down.
Family requirements.
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh!
Oh, okay, never mind.
Oh, okay.
I thought, okay.
That's okay.
Oh, okay, okay.
I didn't realize.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, buddy.
Sorry, sorry.
What do you mean he's mad?
I didn't know.
Oh, my God.
It's so much damage.
He's just hammering.
Oh, my God.
How long?
Guys, how long do I have to live for?
This is bad.
This is actually so bad.
I actually...
No!
I tried to heal!
Oh my god, I actually tried to heal.
It didn't work.
Oh my god.
I actually tried to heal.
It didn't work.
Oh god.
I got the heals.
I got the heals off.
That was so scary.
Okay, that should be enough.
Oh, thank God.
Let's all just take a breath.
Yeah, no, I was panicking.
I don't even know.
Okay.
We don't have a lot of armor.
I feel like...
I feel like, too.
Yeah.
I didn't realize the enemies get harder.
The more side rooms I take.
Anyway, let's take...
Anyway.
Let's take that one.
I might do it.
I might be doing this to myself.
Potentially it might be on me.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I definitely need the heals though.
Okay, nice.
Jesus!
It's just all fucking snipers!
Oh!
One or two?
Yeah, we have good HP right now.
Two, okay.
Two for the blast, you're right.
The blast is pretty important.
We'll grab this plant too.
everything oh hey money let's go how many fucking side rooms
are there what's up it's just all side rooms like it's okay
it's okay I might not need the money guys I'm not but you
agree it's me
guys it could be very important
oh my god oh my god guys why did i take so many oh my god i
might have i might have fucked up just a maybe it's just a
little baby i can't i'm not sure yet i'm i need I think I
need more.
I need more rooms to figure it out I need more rooms to test
it out guys Oh my god, 2,000 gold now I'm at fishing though
Oh yay I got Jiffy I'm at I'm at room three I Made it to the
first room
Okay, I might have Might have been just a little greedy Just
a little bit Yes I can't tell you Okay, we're definitely not
We don't need to grab the money chest though I think I think
we're okay on that
You shouldn't trust me Unless Unless No, we're fine.
We're fine.
But you need it, Doki.
But imagine if you had the extra hundred dollars, Doki.
I want to get rid of the time, though.
Holy shit, that's a lot of shit going on my screen.
I am so confused, guys.
There's a little bit too much stuff going on my screen.
Just a little bit.
there you go okay mining mining mining all right last room
oh my god oh my god okay
okay we got rid of all these guys oh i might have fucked up
Holy shit.
Made a little oopsie there.
The last guy.
Boom!
Okay, thank God.
Alright, now we have to shop.
Yeah, at least it was a small room.
That was a lot of people.
Okay, technically.
Alright, we're gonna buy...
I'm not gonna...
Okay, wait.
1,5, 6, 7, 8.
Oh.
I don't need the salt that bad.
I can't I don't have enough I thought I did can I afford
everything I
can are you guys sure all right five seven eight oh I can't
yeah I should have looted the troll
God damn it
Alright, I should get two
Grab this Oh wait, one One for sure
Three right Yeah Okay, now I should have enough Okay, last
run for Grandpa And then it's all surface baby
You spoke before about the consequences of the past, of your
own mistakes.
Yet this is how you choose to rectify them.
Your entire family is against you.
As ever.
The only difference now is there are even more of you all
falling in line.
You would excise me from my own family, then very well.
But this is the result.
You're going down, old man!
You don't want to rule the underworld or the surface, do
you?
Yeah, look at him.
He thinks he's got a chance.
And then this is the run he kills me
Whoa, that's gaslighting Whoa, this guy is an actual
narcissist Whoa
My kids are not perfect so that's why That's why I'm not
perfect because my kids ended up not being perfect That
stuff, that's so fucked.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Oh, well, fuck this.
Fuck that shit.
I'm fucking killing these guys first.
All right, there you go.
Oh, my God.
I dodged the chest in hand.
He's like, no.
Oh, that's good.
It's good that the freeze follows, too.
Thank God.
I'm glad about that.
That's really nice.
That follows him.
Oh my God.
Woo!
Okay.
That's good.
That's fine.
Oh no, not these guys.
I'll get rid of this.
Oh, fuck!
I didn't that oh my god oh my god that's a I might get
deptify instead no oh oh that's close no oh my god it's an
unblockable are you fucking kidding me really oh my god the
last one wait was that my last deptify is oh my god wait I
might actually die oh no oh this is bad this is bad this is
actually very bad it's actually very bad oh god oh okay
oh god okay
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, shit, that's not fine.
Oh, I should have got more HP.
I should have got more HP, guys.
I messed up.
I messed up by...
I have too little HP.
No!
I knew I messed up somehow.
I just don't have enough HP for this.
Oh, my God.
No.
Oh, yes!
Oh,
dodge work!
I don't think it was.
Super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Her green chickens, me.
Oh, thank God for the dodge.
Oh, Demeter came in clutch.
A bit of feuds and snide remarks.
Dodge actually works.
Oh, yes.
This is the whole of it.
I may have denied it to you.
But I wasn't doing it.
punished never punished oh I see she just wanted to put on
the show yeah yeah I purpose guys I purposely died used up
all my all my fucking death defiances so to make it make it
more intense guys
Ozu, thank you for the vibe, gift of ships, thank you, thank
you, guys, see, I made it more intense, guys, for the
content, it's called showmanship.
Again, to the abyss of the subconscious.
All right, I have all the sand now.
Yeah, we don't want to make it too easy.
Night and darkness, guide me to my blood beyond the grasp of
time.
All right, off I go.
everything's under control yes
all right here I am what the fuck did you say about me
that's right whoa our duty besides father always says no
fighting in this house I didn't feel good about it either
and I couldn't help thinking about what you said I know you
were being honest with me about your concerns all this must
be so much to take in believe me i'm absorbing it as quickly
as i can we have the sinister grandfather who's resorted to
all out war against the rest of the family one way or
another he needs to be sought that's right and i've been
trained in how to stop him though unfortunately it requires
you to do some of the dirty work the worst of it in fact i
can understand why you would be reluctant So what do we do?
Say we proceed as planned.
I get Gaigaro's to you, you do something to it.
I use it to destroy Kronos in my time before he takes
control in yours.
Then everything would be alright.
Yeah, which is that easy.
Well, I assume so, yes.
We can't anticipate exactly what shall happen in a world
without time.
But it's existed in that state before.
And can't be worse than letting him prevail.
But if Kronos is gone, what happens to you?
dead no if cronos hadn't taken father's throne we'd be
together as a family he denied me a father a mother a
three-headed dog you and some evening he'll deny you that i
like how he's like the last person she names soon like an
afterthought like she's like dot dot dot oh you
the dog the dog has a higher ranking than her brother
I don't want to lose you either, Zagreus.
Oh, and you.
You and all the rest.
Normal sibling behavior.
I did one more run?
Oh my god.
I thought that was the last run.
He's like, don't worry, I'll have it for the next meeting.
What the fuck do you mean?
Return to Shadow now.
Oh my god.
Alright, we'll do a surface run.
We'll go back and forth.
Run it back.
Any new hauntings need evaluation or anything?
I'm fine.
It's just...
I think I've hit a bit of a slump as all.
Happens, right?
I'll get over it.
That'll be fine.
It'll be fine.
I'm fine.
I confess I feel a bit self-conscious that the fated
lizard...
is there for you and all to see some of the matters it
describes are rather personal if it's any comfort the
prophecies appear only to you oh so you just see a blank
list when you fulfill a prophecy I see it's like a sudden
realization we know our paths are intertwined to an extent
well may your sudden realizations connected to my actions
not be too embarrassing All right.
This wasn't on the list before.
Grab this.
That's it.
That's all I can grab.
That's fine.
Again.
Oh my god.
Hey, yay.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum.
Guys, I'm not, guys.
Don't judge me.
It's free.
He just like, she just throws it on them.
Guys, guys, don't judge me.
It's free.
Okay.
it oh he's again my task surely you've better uses of your
energy than this and throwing all your rubbish everywhere
what would you even know i have every right to be here and
you're never getting rid of me who gave you the right this
is my home to how things were we're going forward not back
Bro, what the fuck?
Who invited this bitch?
Fresh from the pot.
Oh, nice.
Oh, I got the doggy treats.
Yeah I'll just grab every oh wait summon.
Oh, I got the colony of bats All right Give me the bats and
hear the city of the dead.
Yeah I created bats guys.
I did it created bats
any of these things do for me said welcome to tomato farm
welcome welcome i created batman at least the greek with
chronos in the past yeah i'm the goddess of bats no other
course but to destroy him created and enslaved we don't talk
about the second part okay i gave them life
oh blood and darkness he's got to you hasn't he your brother
at least if not chronos himself Why are you asking me such
things when you have come so close to the completion of your
task, Milanoi?
Well, for one, we're on the verge of destroying time itself.
For all you've taught me, I've never fully understood the
repercussions this would have.
That's what all the gods say.
I cannot bear you such repercussions ere they come to pass.
Our charge, your charge, is to stop Kronos.
Whatever it takes, I trust you shall require no additional
reminder.
just and um wait your turn i'm trying to get more psyche and
more psyche still and more psyche as well
yeah i was gonna spam that good you're back according to
reports aries flew off toward the rift of thessaly on an
intercept course with the fleet except i don't think that
she's headed
reports aren't of much benefit to me after the fact but at
least I can confirm they're accurate I'm preposterous that
we cannot rid ourselves oh there's gonna be cages on the
wall with the spark oh so the more rooms they have the more
so they'll have the bats there I see that we could not
forewarn you on this one we will continue investigating her
motives and accomplices I'm not convinced she has either
pick pick pick okay we mean this and this apparently all
right now we can use our staff for real i should be able to
increase my grasp i have 30 now i'm gonna grab one for three
you take the i can grab this i'm just gonna pay for this
just for the sake of it and get alter location rewards take
zero damage the first time you are hitting guardian what's
guardian encounters oh like the boss room I've reached my
limit did I oh I did oh I need okay I need 500 where the
fuck am I getting shadow the headshot I can't mind we'll
grab wait what can I upgrade here of night oh grab this the
witch's staff with me my friend all right money within the
silver pool now swim dark apparitions of the arms of night
oh it's the cauldron oh what do i make it so many different
forms okay i need three okay by light of moon in darkest
arabus I urge ye spirits at the crossroads thus look well
upon the wards about this place which keep us hidden within
night oh oh she's using the cauldron oh i can't use it
anymore okay sorry sorry oh she's just she's like i'm busy
right now using the cauldron right now there you go i'm just
like um when can i use it okay i need ash and fabric i mean
i can't All right, I just need a farm that I was just like,
um When is it my turn?
Way to stick it to that.
So you smack Kronos a good couple of times now.
Remind these shades in me what is to happen next.
How are you going to kill that which continues coming back?
Commander, though it's tempting to share all my latest
progress, we both know I'm never to divulge the details of
my task.
Not even to you.
Not even to me.
But can you say at least your brother, be all right i've
been worrying about the guy he's all that'll be fine he's
just sleeping deep breath all right time for the surface run
i don't know if i'm gonna make it observe the handiwork of
chronos all about you there the what's thriving city of
afira laid to ruin the underworld's gates flog open am i
supposed to get a new guy for which there must be
consequences all right let's see oh let's this is always
good right i remember this is always good i know i should
have i didn't wait for it you guys to tell me i was just
like it's always good oh oh my god there's the psyche bond
few entrances into the underworld exist and one of them is
through the akaron who's a okay our foes can use this as an
exit so can i all right fishing time oh what Oh, Ribat.
Wait, how is he able to swim?
This is the surface.
No way around the city.
I have to get through.
Alright.
Oh, that's so cool.
Okay.
Wait, that's cool.
Wait, I like that.
Oh my god, I didn't see this.
Okay, why are you next to me?
Why?
You're supposed to be not next to me for this to work.
Okay.
Let's see.
out of.
He's like a little lizard.
His sprint hit the first four you run into blast that
knocks.
Any finds and you see any minor finds and worth more and you
see oh, okay.
Your cast.
Oh, wait.
Three is good for um his voice with powerful slash not
tethering not one i feel like three right three or two three
would be good for like early game right since we're still
very early
yeah i'm an early game now so this should be good that's
what i was thinking too all right bats time where are the
bats who
Sister, stay out of my bloody way, else you're liable to get
hurt.
Now scoot.
Until whomever sits here.
Oh my god, Hercules?
Your threat is duly noted, son of Zeus.
I'm headed for the docks, but understand this city's sealed
shut.
What is he doing here?
Are we supposed to work together?
Yeah, you're not even...
You're a demigod.
You're not even a real god, Hercules.
I'm daughter of Hades the dead yeah I'm a full god you're a
half-blood I'm sorry are we are you friends oh there's the
bats What is that?
What does this mean?
No, you can't say that.
Yeah, but I'm a full-blooded god.
I don't understand this.
I mean, hammer, Poseidon.
I guess the moon?
I'll grab the hammer first.
Oh, it's like a map.
Alright.
Got rid of him first.
Oh, I didn't even see this house.
Alright, nice.
Hammer time.
He insulted me first!
He...
He's...
He insulted me first.
He said bad things.
It's not my fault.
But you took it too far.
It's not racist.
It's goddess, okay?
I'm only judging him because he's half a god.
God.
Vampiric.
Three is awesome.
I'll try three.
Let's move cast, though.
Something's changed.
Wait, was there a room?
Let's see.
We'll do the moon.
I can grab the moon.
Guys, Hercules...
Guys, guys, guys.
Hercules isn't even real.
He's real to me.
Guys, he's not even real!
He's making me a head to be like, He's real to me!
I call upon the moon and draw you down.
I ought to welcome you more formally to our world's surface.
They made a Disney movie about him.
He's real.
Oh, yeah.
They made a Disney movie about talking bears.
Is that real?
I'm gonna get it.
Oh, get it.
Total eclipse.
Total eclipse of my heart.
Yes.
All right.
Hestia, right?
We'll do Hestia.
Oh, there is a Zeus down there.
You want to get Hera?
Her Zeus?
Okay.
Wait, how many have?
We got three left.
Okay, we'll get Hera here.
We'll grab this now.
Oh yeah, there's money here too.
Oh my god, there's the thing.
Alright.
Oh no, I need mana regen for sure.
I knew I'm missing something.
I need mana regen so badly.
Yeah, I definitely need mana regen.
Where the fuck is the house?
Oh, there's no house.
Okay, they don't have homes.
That's good.
Okay.
Area clear.
Yeah, we need mana regen.
We don't have a lot of that.
I've incarnated recently decided to show up as she is
willing to do.
good sport of us before must think we're fools and easy prey
you correct her yeah i will uh make random boon become
heroic your cast inflicts and deal damage based oh i don't
even remember what what boost do i have are any of these
good enough for um i swear to god if they get this gets
heroic i swear to god i i there's there's not a lot of
things to get but are you sacred bond oh that's good that's
actually good oh my god it hit the blitz oh that's actually
so good for us it got the blitz guys we needed that all
right and then what do you guys want Hestia and okay which
one I won the gamma all right which one do we do next we
have three what are three should we do Poseidon is my best
mana Hestia...
Who the fuck is?
Imp.
Uh...
Hermes...
Hestia Zeus Hermes.
Hestia...
Zeus Hermes.
I'll go Zeus first.
Everyone says Zeus more.
Oh, so we'll go Zeus first.
You shades are getting out of there.
but I definitely need mana regen one use this the casting
more wait where am I where is my fucking vampiric shit I was
told I get plus okay where the fuck does it oh I have to
slay a foe with it oh my god why did I grab this hear me on
my authority Yeah, I have to do last hit.
Oh my god, I gotta fucking play League of...
I gotta play League of Legends right now.
Like...
I gotta play fucking League of Legends.
We're gonna get static.
Oh my god, I do not have a lot.
I gotta play...
What is the game called?
What is the genre?
Almost through.
Alright, Hestia.
Jesus Christ.
There you go.
MOBA, yeah, MOBA ink.
It's literally a MOBA right now.
Got a fucking prop, like, get on kill.
Actual bullshit.
Your soul be damned, traitor.
You're not supposed to be up here, right?
No.
I'm not supposed to touch grass.
This is so bad.
I'm literally not getting any mana regen.
Your foe perish in the blast of damage just ending
surrounding foes.
Your special leaves scorch.
I feel like...
Oh, Pia, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, we have a good stream, Pia.
We're touching grass right now.
now.
We're on the surface because we can finally breathe O2.
What do we want?
One or three, right?
Three?
I don't know if one would... I don't use my special that
much.
I'm gonna do this.
Or dab.
I haven't found any extra rooms.
What the fuck?
These gods are so fucking stingy.
It's because I...
What the fuck?
What are you doing?
Oh, he's used this god.
Oh!
Bye.
They're just chilling.
Alright.
Last one.
Hermes.
Hermes are Poseidon.
Many.
They're going to keep the ships.
They can thank you.
Or waste it?
No, they're just that.
They free money.
Guys, it's free money.
Double magic?
Should I do it?
Alright, double magic.
Rice, thank you for the...
Where did he go?
Oh, he's a...
I was like, where did the guy...
Where did the fuck did that guy go?
Oh my god, he almost threw that at me.
Oh my god, I already used that all up.
Hell, he got us a lot of...
I gotta destroy this guy's house real quick.
That's right.
No more housing for you.
Magic.
Yeah.
Oh, thank God there's a fucking room now.
Alright, nice.
Still didn't fucking proc on kill.
Good job.
Alright.
Uh, is that everything?
Yeah, I killed everything.
Not to get out of here.
Oh, but yeah, it raised Thank you for the gift of ships.
Thank you.
The suspense.
Oh, grab the water.
Okay, shock time.
Oh, I missed the transform.
What's the transform?
The city at her back.
The princess of the dead heads toward a dismal pasture where
she senses that she is not exactly being watched.
Polyphemus must already know I'm here.
Get the cage?
What do you mean?
Oh!
How do I do it make it better?
My blessing made it all that way on just a rickety old
wooden ferry boat.
Must be a litany of fire safety hazards there.
Although plenty of water near with which to put them out.
I'll get the chance again.
Okay, that's good.
Yeah, I didn't realize.
I missed it.
And Leaves.
Okay, two, right?
I do two.
I do.
I have a lot.
I have a lot right now.
Grab this and this.
I'll grab everything.
I am very low HP.
I don't think we're going to make it all the way to the end.
I have a feeling.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
They got the Vampirid shit, guys.
I know It's just Be safe, Lord Karon I'm back I was
just really thirsty I also beat up your sheep a little bit
And besides, your residence is filthy You could stand to
clean it up Instead of facing me Let me know if you need to
God damn it, I can't play a mobile with my rogue Like
I'll wait for my ice to melt now you want to live oh my god
oh my god i escaped all right oh my god oh oh shit okay okay
i still i cannot i literally can't use my fucking my god
what the fuck my army
Okay, it's okay.
He'll stand over here, right?
Come on, just... No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I needed him to literally... He just needed to stand there
for a little bit.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I'm fucked.
No, I'm fucked.
I'm fucked.
Okay, it's okay There we go, there we go We hit it The
fluid's going hot Is it 8 HP, 8 HP and a dream We got the
wall too
See no big deal No, no big deal This actually was so good Oh
my god, why the fuck did that
That shit is actually fucking ass.
You want to become heroic?
Okay.
I just want to make sure...
I already forgot what I have.
Isn't that extra low?
That extra low for me?
God, these sheep are so stingy!
They're so stingy!
Alright.
Yeah.
Where is my wood?
You have so much hair on you.
As soon as one ship sinks, another rises from the depths.
It's still connected to the main fleet.
Oh.
Oh, I got cookie.
Here, take my cookie.
Be my cat.
We share a bond We do Your name is Tula, isn't it Yay I
stole someone's cat guys Let's go Let's fucking go I stole
somebody's cat My cat now It's not my fault They left it
outside Oh my god Did you saw that news article Some guy
like stole somebody's cat Like some DoorDash delivery guy
That's so scary He left their cat outside and then some guy
just ran up and fucking took it After a DoorDash delivery.
Well not ran up You know what I mean.
That's fucking weird That's actually fucking weird bro
Yeah, I read yeah, like some DoorDash guy just went up and
took the guy's cat because it was outside It was like free
cat I guess just fucking just took it but like not even I
keep petting everything uh we'll get ash he's okay I'm
getting like the shittiest stuff right now I swear I'm not a
fan of like the items we're getting
ash Oh, fuck.
I forgot about the transform.
I keep forgetting.
That's a thing.
Okay.
I keep forgetting that that's a feature, guys.
It's so windy.
All right.
Do we get moon or palm?
It's so windy.
I keep forgetting.
the wind I blame the wind guys the wind is big it's so loud
you know when it's windy that's fucking getting over okay
fucking left okay that's fine oh more blitz I might as well
upgrade the heroic one oh no the This one's going to be
scary.
Yeah, when the wind makes me forget.
Don't you hate it when that happens?
Okay, which one's easier?
Which one's easier to fight?
Pick hair up first?
Is Hestia easier to fight, guys?
Now I know.
Okay.
That must have been the wind.
What do you mean?
Hera is easy.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Well, we're fighting Hestia.
We're going to fight Hestia now.
All right.
Um.
One or two for damage?
There was damage inflicts hitch.
That makes me use...
I'll use two.
My right click more.
One?
One or two, chat.
We're not getting...
We're end game?
Guys, I don't know if we're getting to end game.
I don't know.
Oh, no.
But, uh, Zeus, Hera duo.
I don't think we're getting a duo, are we?
Oh, we'll try it.
Estia, Gouda, please.
Alright, let's see.
Sorry, great, auntie.
Uh-huh.
What?
She's angry with me now.
Where is it?
Okay, it's over here.
Okay.
Okay, the only issue right now is that I'm burning.
Okay, okay, I'm burning.
I'm on fire.
That's the issue.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Is he not dead?
Oh, my...
Holy fuck.
There we go.
I can still fight.
Let's just cool off a bit before these flames of mine get
way out of control.
Alright, let's see.
The more I have...
I have two right now.
I'm gonna guess two.
I just need to have more fire.
Yeah.
I can keep sa- Yay!
Oh, I mean, I guess, sure.
I don't know how useful this is, but sure.
Oh, hey, fishing.
Fishing.
Wait, that's water?
That is a clear-ass water.
I got a shrimp!
Let's go!
Whoa!
Oh, my God.
Oh, hey!
I've never interacted with this person before.
Who's here?
Davy Jones?
An island.
Who lives here?
Is that who I think?
Whoa, wait, who the fuck is here?
What's wrong with this pig?
Oh my god, I don't know if I can slap it.
Red?
Oh, it's a...
What?
Is this a Naga?
Oh, is that Cersei?
Oh, I'm using her ability!
Show me your palms.
Yeah, I'm using her weapon.
This is your famous island.
be here rather than another drowned ship i take it we're not
meeting by chance wise to our ways as ever our lady hecati
and i decided i had best to relocate for a while and survey
events as oh she turns sailors into peggy's then tonight
within my crystals oh it's time to eat bacon how may we make
you better What does she give me?
Bookmoon's might.
Stronger this night.
Oh, I got plus trying to shrink in size so that you move.
Oh, wait.
The smaller I am.
Free, right?
Oh, my God.
My hitbox is smaller now.
Wait, I didn't kill him.
That's a lie.
They're alive.
Yeah, the smaller I am, the smaller my hitbox.
All right, let's go.
Titan.
Okay, I got it.
I got the HP.
I think I got it.
Oh, my God.
That is...
Okay, this is a lot of fire.
Did I get HP from that?
I do.
That was a lot of fire.
Okay, I can change this, right?
Okay, I'll be able to change this later
Okay There you go Maybe somebody will come over Okay, this
is only useful in boss fights Which I've learned, I have
realized Oh my god, I still haven't got it Wait God damn it,
I don't have enough I don't have enough Okay, how do I
change?
Oh, okay
I mean, I guess I'll take it Okay, okay, I guess I'll take
that Okay Go, Fritos Be at peace Alright We got Psych either
at least By Hermes tab Oh, that's fine
Alright Did I proc?
I don't even know if I got the damage if i got the vampire
thing here god damn it there you go oh my god that doesn't
count because it's left it has to be let's act if grams
could get prometheus to take his side who only knows what
else ruffled a lot of feathers haven't we uh five steven
super chat thank you thank you i always love the simpsons
episode where homer was uh eat it uh odis i forgot to
pronounce his name odd odyssey and cersei turned his crew to
pigs are you done eating your friends those were my friend
Oh, I remember that.
Oh, yeah!
I really did the parody of that.
Sprint is 15% faster and gives you.
Alright.
One, two.
Uh, I guess two, right?
Two would be better.
Or three.
Right.
Yeah, but plus 0.5.
I mean, getting that.
The last time I had that, it was not better.
I learned my lesson.
The last time I had that, the last time I had that, I didn't
do Jackson.
shit in the name of haiti's i'll say a food too oh wait
chain lightning yeah we'll grab that food nice we might die
okay i'm gonna pee we have not a lot of hp we have 76 hp i
don't feel very confident that i'll be right back i got peed
I'm back.
I'm hydrating a lot.
Um, Alan, next thing, Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And I forgot to grab mana regen.
Oh my god, I have mana regen.
It's okay.
I don't think we're gonna make it far.
Anyway, guys.
I don't...
This might be a little rough here.
I'm gonna grab that tree branch before she fucking kills me.
How cute.
Old Cersei must have done that to you, yeah?
I've flown by her little island where she's doing all her
lunatic experiments.
Oh, she has a new dialogue for it.
I'm going to have only ice left in my water.
Even more we easily identified the work of an experienced
enchantress, but only to spawn our craft.
Your craft turns you into a walking joke.
I'm just pointing it out.
I hear you.
I'm going to grab this just in case.
Oh, I made it just in time.
There you go.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
I got hit.
everything just hits me oh my god this is actual bullshit
because like our attacks are all red damn this is not good i
i need to not i realized that i actually might i have to not
get like okay it's fine i realized that i should stop
getting scorch because scorch is actually so bad for me Oh,
fucking course.
A fucking course!
I need to stop getting a scorch.
Like, I literally can't see.
Plus 100 damage.
A fucking course.
Oh my god.
All her damage does red fucking shit, too.
Okay.
Alright, if that's 5.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Of course that doesn't.
You're good.
No!
Guys, I might.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god that actually hits.
What does that say?
Oh my god.
Where is she?
Okay, that's fine.
Nice.
Oh, we lost one, but like it was gonna happen
Thank God We got the golden apple Now the climb oh my god
thank God she stays still there.
Thank fucking God Okay, this is where I grabbed the tooth
It's tooth tab.
We are not very healthy.
We have only 76 HP.
This is the least amount of help I've got for this run.
To the fort of the most sacred mountain of the gods.
A little bit of a climb.
Alright, Apako.
Oh god.
That's quite enough.
Alright, we're gonna...
Let's just stand behind our frog.
There we go.
This is the only thing we can do.
Uh...
Magic.
We still don't have regen.
Yeah, you know... Oh, hey.
Oh!
What?
That was an accident.
Oh, whoop.
Did not... whoopsie.
Okay.
Dennis.
All right, magic.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
God.
Wait, what?
Oh, guys.
HP or Poseidon?
I forgot.
It makes me airdrop.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Why does it do this to me?
I feel like I really need HP, though.
Unless Poseidon.
Oh, I need HP.
I'm so low in HP.
Okay.
I'm going to attack on site.
Oh my god, he didn't win.
Okay, it's fine
It's okay.
No There's oh wait, I didn't eat that anyway.
I thought yeah That's fine Here we go.
I got the proc.
Oh, no.
Oh, no Oh, no get it out.
No Yeah!
Oh shit!
Oh my god, is he still here?
Is he still here?
Is he still here, guys?
Okay.
He's gone, he's gone.
He can't hurt me no more.
He's gone, guys.
Oh hey!
Another person to talk to.
That's new.
So I say, can't we just, you know, invite him over to a
feast?
Wait, is it the god of wine or party?
I forgot his name.
Whoa!
Hello, sir.
What a party.
Oh, my god.
It needs you, Freenos.
Rest easy now.
Oh, my god.
That isn't cool.
Oh, it is!
It is him.
It's the god of wine.
Damn.
Bro, the Greek guys don't know how to party.
Bro, he's sexy and he knows it.
That's literally the fucking thon.
It's from the 60 and I know it's on.
Bro, there's a cheetah in the party room.
Why is he hiding a gun on his feet?
Oh,
God.
He's stuffed up.
No, he's stuffed it.
Just isn't one of them.
What's the use?
We gods can't die, but we can live.
Your mountain is under siege.
He's like, I don't care.
I'm here to party.
More reasonable reason to raise a cup while we still can,
yeah?
Though I get it.
More like it's the nuclear lodge codes.
That's what's in the speedo.
Get a load of these.
Grants power when used.
Let's see.
Restore took damage in Oh.
Your moves inflicted hangover the first time they strike
foes.
Two.
I feel like two, right?
I'm dressed yellow.
Yeah, that is an elephant.
That's a long-ass elephant trunk.
That sucks.
I don't have enough nectar.
I didn't realize I'll need it.
Without partying.
Bro, these satyrs know how to party.
Oh, is it worth fighting Hera?
Guys, is it worth it?
Is the boss fight hard?
I forgot.
Oh, wait, I remember it.
No, I remember the boss fight.
Is it worth getting Hera or just get magic?
Hera?
All right.
It's a...
Oh, what?
What is this?
What?
what what is this oh what is this oh my god i'm grabbing
this plant before i die what the oh my god oh my god no
we're dead no we're dead here we're dead it was not worth it
It was not worth it.
Okay.
I just need to...
Yo, this boss fight sucks.
100%.
There we go.
Maybe I can...
I locked in him in.
Yeah, just had so much armor.
Goodbye, death defiance.
I have to find Depth Defiance.
Okay, one.
Yeah, I'm getting rarity.
Okay, two.
Yeah.
Oh,
nice.
Oh, shit.
Everything rarity.
Yeah, yo.
Um, we have one Depth Defiance left, guys.
Oh, my gosh.
Stop, stop.
Stop walking away.
Whoops.
It's bad.
There we go.
I got the 5 HP.
I needed that 5.
Okay, they should spawn in another one.
Oh no, it's the robots.
The robots are here.
The robot uprising is here now.
Oh no!
Oh my god, they're here.
There we go.
I got the HP too.
More HP, please.
Uh, we'll get the Pob.
This guy.
Are you fucking- Oh, thank God, okay.
What is it?
Okay, nice.
Broke his armor.
Okay.
That's good.
I have full HP now.
That's good for me.
Oh, my God.
No, that's not good now.
Oh, are you fucking kidding me?
nice okay five hp i'll take those okay it's fine oh shit
it's okay it's not okay but it's okay it's not okay but we
can make it work oh my god that's so much damage guys that's
a lot of damage guys i don't know anymore oh my god
Oh my god, there you go.
What?
Define intervention?
I...
Oh hey.
Wait, is that Athena?
Athena!
Oh my god, you're real!
I'm proud to welcome you to Olympus.
You know, you could have came here a bit earlier, but that's
okay.
That's okay.
I already... I killed 80% I killed 90% of them, but that's
okay.
I'll take it.
Now where can I direct my wrath?
Oh my god, I even, I am tired here.
I'm sound high pitched too.
Well met indeed, Malinoi.
The wretched titans armies have infiltrated our most sacred
grounds.
And then your wrath may be well spent.
Yeah, I just realized my voice is pitched tired too.
Where most of our family now takes refuge.
Oh my god, her shield does blink.
The palace of Zeus.
And what of you?
here fighting by your side oh my gosh she's so big compared
to me what the fuck because that is precisely what our
strategy requires for they aided your arrival did they not
now let us go our separate ways and may my blessing aid in
your assent so i mean it's gonna help gonna show up even
more now oh my god okay but you prime bro it's fine i'm okay
with priming magic prime a hundred and twenty five okay this
is fine actually it gives me a death to five
Should I flag?
Okay, no, three is huge.
No, we need that.
We don't.
Nice.
You know what?
Look at our magic.
Guys, look at our magic now.
Alright, um, which one?
One, two, or three?
We just go all in and blitz?
What, Matt?
Three is run saving?
Oh, you mean the next one, right?
Yeah, no, look at it.
Well, I feel like we're meeting new people, so we'll get
nectar now.
I don't think we need ash.
I mean, we'll get the materials, though.
Guys, ash or nectar?
I feel like we should get nectar just because...
We can always buy nectar, guys.
We can always buy nectar, though.
I think it's fine.
right i don't remember do we have it yeah we'll grab ash we
always yeah
oh boy oh god oh god oh my god guys i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry if i killed your dog that was like his dog oh no more
nectar or no more no more magic Guys, we never got mana
regen.
Guys, it's okay, we don't need it.
We don't need it.
We don't need mana regen.
Famous Lasper.
It's okay, we don't need it.
We don't need mana regen.
Oh.
18 Ash.
Oh, hammer.
Wait, hammer's good.
Hammer time.
Oh, god damn it.
That was an accident.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's okay.
Hammer time.
Attacks hit two times, but you...
This would be... Okay, we have to get 30.
This would be so good, but I don't have...
I still don't have matter.
So we'll just get plus 30 damage.
Shop.
Hmm...
Does this, like, progress the room, guys?
Does this progress the room or not?
I don't know.
Because, like, will I get another shop if I go here?
Or no?
Oh, it both?
Okay, we'll get shopped then.
Yeah, we gotta spend the money.
The moolah.
Okay.
Oh!
They're all cast, the spy.
I might as well get this.
It's like some sort of mana region.
The majestic summit of Mount Olympus would be very much in
sight from here.
Were it not for the very dark.
At least I made it to him.
I don't know if I'll beat him, but I made it.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, this is gonna test us.
Ah, yes.
Resist all you like, yet the age of God shall end.
All right, we have two death defiances.
I don't think we're going to make it, but it's okay.
It's the thought that counts.
If I somehow gave you the impression that I'm interested in
your doomsaying and false prophecies, I assure you, I'm not.
Your disregard is the very reason you're no longer fit to
rule.
I know you'll never relinquish this mountain.
Fall with it, then.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Bitch!
Stupid eagle.
Oh my god, I hate the eagle so much.
What?
I dashed through.
I swear to god, guys, I dashed through it.
I swear.
I swear I dashed through it.
Oh my god.
He's so scary.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It throws double.
Okay, that's cheating.
Oh my god, here we go.
Okay, bottom.
Okay, middle.
Bottom, top.
It's not fair!
Are you fucking kidding me?
That should have been illegal.
Oh god.
Oh god, nothing.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god, it's five This is not fair This is actually not
fair Oh my god
Okay Okay Middle Top Middle, middle, top, middle, bottom
Middle, top, middle, bottom Middle, top, middle, bottom
Middle, top, middle, bottom Bottom Top?
god oh thank god let's carry on oh god not the eagle not the
eagle oh my god are you fucking kidding me i can't see i
can't see oh my god i can't see oh god not again not again
no no love
the first one was so bullshit I couldn't get there this time
it's clouded his senses oh my god oh my god that was so
bullshit warbling about but they make it through some pretty
hairy times yeah no i think the scorch i'm not getting a
scorch for my power-ups scorch is so fucking hard to see i
really hate scorch power-ups because i can't see the attacks
very well because it's all red my entire screen is red there
is very fierce
it's too much visual clutter it's because like it blends in
it doesn't like it looks the same as the um as the fucking
thing yeah no it's the same color too yeah their reign over
the heavens and the earth and the continued existence of
their home oh that's nothing new oh it's okay yummy yummy
yummy yummy yummy yummy Babe, you know what you put up more
of a fight out there than I figured the rail was so hot to
the touch I could hardly stand it and the dash also the dash
covered the entire thing with red as well Pleased to be of
entertainment for your benefit is that all this is to you
then you jeopardize our continued existence just for a cheap
thrill Don't go acting like there wasn't part of you.
Yeah, oh now she's so friendly and now that you've had a
taste you want more don't you No, no, that's fine.
No, it's okay.
You can just leave and leave the apple.
Just leave the apple and that's fine.
Too bad we can't have it all.
You're all right?
No.
I got my ass beat.
Why can't Hestiest thing not be red?
Contain a moon map.
Okay, let's grab that.
She's kind of bad.
Don't.
Bad.
Don't make me get the spray bottle.
Alright, Rush, uh, sometimes contain a shrine of Hermes.
I mean, that sounds nice.
Yeah, I'm saying how the fuck did the eagle befriended him?
His old job was to eat his liver.
See, plain enough.
For one, he wants his vengeance on Lord Uncle Zeus and the
rest.
And for another, he's a titan himself.
I am a titaness as well as his sister Selene, lest you
forget.
Our lineage need not dictate our loyalties or principles.
They bonded at work.
You know, he fed the ego something else that wasn't living.
It was just like, whoa.
Oh, okay, that was literally the last one.
Oh, yeah, I do not have a lot of psyche left.
Hey, here you go.
Eris stands against us.
Just as I need my destination.
Yeah, he started Uber Eats ordering for the Eager.
I'll do much of the talking.
Imagine my surprise.
So what to do?
Can't kick her out since all children of Nix are welcome
here.
Whose ever bright idea that was?
Maybe give her some more second chances.
Wait, am I?
Why am I giving her second chance?
It's like, fuck that bitch.
This opposes us.
Now that one hurts, God is.
Amongst us mortals, he was quite popular.
Beloved even.
Oh, oh yeah, that's why.
He was when I gave fire.
And that's why they punished him.
And in so doing, he violated the will of Olympus.
Supposedly, he has the gift of foresight.
He ought to have anticipated the consequences of his
disobedience.
Yeah, she must be punished for being an asshole.
What makes you think you did not?
All the more reason we admired him.
He knew the cost of what he did for us and paid it
willingly.
So I choose to think.
But all that's in the past.
If he's thrown in with Kronos now, he's lost his way.
He's done this.
Let's pick this up.
Is there anything?
Oh, wait.
Got a plan that.
And we got a plan that.
All right, we have a cat now.
We abducted somebody's cat.
No, I still don't have enough.
pet again?
I don't remember.
Where the fuck is the thing?
Oh, there she is.
Aww!
She's so cute.
Look at her.
Aww.
That's cute.
Alright.
Sprint by Tolan.
She will attack.
What does she do?
What does he do?
Wait, what is the amphibian?
What is the frog special?
Meow.
wow all right i want to upgrade this i want to try this now
he protect and she attack all right let's try it okay i want
to try this do i have it oh i do have it okay can i rank it
up i need enmer how do i get that oh it's from this okay a
healthy fear of darkness that's enmer right is this the
enmer thing
yeah oh okay so where's upgrading um 3.5 seconds okay we'll
grab that No, let's do this.
I swear it, Nix.
And...
I just need to kill her, right?
Time.
And...
More expensive...
Of your grass for your arena.
Uh...
Which is good for it.
Horace, Menace?
You know what?
Let's just...
Grab...
Fuck it.
Let's just grab this.
There we go.
And then grab time.
Because we just have to kill her, right?
Yeah, we just have to kill her.
Oh, wait.
Is that Hecatee?
Is that Hecatee on the top?
I can't tell.
Is that Hecatee?
No, that's Erys.
No.
Fuck that shit.
Alright.
No, we'll just grab this and do time.
we all have to do is kill her and that's we'll try we'll try
it we'll do our best this is my path yeah i don't think i
can do that i'll just try as fast all right for the silver
sisters i go fast i regret you've been swept up in some of
our little disagreements here young lady we all wish to
bestow our favor and should not be fighting over who gets to
go first yet our is not so delicate as it may seem.
And we always stand together in the end.
Wait, where's my cat?
We did not break... Oh, there's my cat.
There she is.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, where the fuck did my cat go?
Okay, we gotta dig this.
Okay, I gotta go fast here.
Alright, hard time.
We gotta go so fast.
Oh my god, I'm so not used to using this.
I'm not good with this weapon.
Money time.
Okay, we don't need transform yet.
Okay, that's good.
Nice.
God, this weapon is so...
It feels so slow.
Why are you just sleeping?
Can you help?
Bro, he's the cat's just sleeping!
Why won't he help me?
I'm so confused!
Wait, where is the last one?
Okay, there she is.
Okay.
Nice.
Where is my cat?
We're here!
why is she sleeping hello we're up against Prometheus it's
more of a support makes him quite an elusive one I guess the
titan of foresight that's just doing cat maybe against the
gods who punished him I will wake her up he's in my way I
know precisely what you mean though if he really knows the
future wouldn't he choose the winning side careful with him
sister all right your specials may deal critical damage but
you prime 40 enemy damage you deal may be critical hmm one
two one or two we take oh or three plus 13 percent chance oh
my god they're all really good this is 14 percent chance
I don't know.
They're all really good.
One or three.
It was for everything.
That's true, but it's 4%.
Is 4% worth it?
Hmm.
Alright, I'll make it cast.
I feel like I do cast a lot.
Yeah, I'm gonna do cast.
Yeah.
Then it's yours.
I cast a lot.
Let's do this again sometime.
We're grabbing this.
Oh my god, wake up!
Wake!
Oh my god, wake the fuck up.
There you go.
We've got a situation starting to unfold.
A big crevasse opened up at the base of the mountain.
And something's in there.
Something big.
And it's breathing.
What the fuck is up there?
Oh, two times.
Wait.
Yeah.
night that's for sure we need this actually okay uh shop
wake up wake up there you okay nice oh my god thank god
she's awake now thank god the cat decided to wake up that's
all i need
All right, armor tab.
I know.
You've been getting anywhere, my friend.
I know that whatever you do, you do not give up.
But I don't rightly know how close you are to what you mean
to achieve.
I'm closer than before, but how much...
I made it to the surface.
I'm getting there.
The silk has been of so much help.
I'm glad it has and figured that it would.
I don't know if I can get into ground flow with this one
With the weapon I have Not good with this one Let's see
Makes you restore plus two Dawn and that creates Dawn and
your cast deals Oh okay but I'm gonna take a lot of damage I
don't trust myself alright I don't trust myself because I do
take Way too much damage So I'll get the restore Actually I
have enough HP so I might as well get the plus 60 armor yeah
I need the fate fabric anyway grab head no no I did it oh I
thought it I thought it automatically goes in my in
automatically goes in my inventory oh my I'm so sad I
literally don't give it to me automatically.
I guess you didn't need it.
I'm so sad.
Okay.
Yeah, we'll do the armor.
I'm so sad.
The cat is leaving.
This should help.
All right, we'll grab this.
Okay, guys, which is harder?
Which is harder?
I need a note.
Which one?
Grab Zeus last?
Okay, I gotta deal with pep.
Like, I have been so fucking scary.
But I guess Zeus is scarier.
Okay.
I do have a lot of armor.
Based on your...
Both were, like, super annoying.
Okay.
Two or three.
I mean, they're all pretty bad, but two or three.
Three could be two?
Two, okay.
Okay.
The forge of the heavens.
Yeah.
You were defiant, speaking you, young lady.
One would be wise to hold in check
All right, Lord uncle, I met no offense.
Oh Now he's upset.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, wake up Wake up, wake up, wake up Oh my god, it's
fine
Yeah, there last one oh my god took five damage accidentally
wake up samurai best applied against our common foe but do
be mindful of your place next time all right let's see your
special inflicts uh damage from emily activated splits and
makes them stronger oh I don't know.
I don't have mana regen, though.
Do I?
I'll try.
I need a fine regen then.
Oh, he gets it automatically?
Nice.
That's good.
Wake up.
Wake up, Samurai.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright, good.
Critical, nice.
Okay.
Oh, I could transform it.
Oh, you're right.
Oh!
Wait, that's a nice transform.
Until they expire.
After you take damage, unranic damage.
Oh, two.
Stronger cast.
Okay.
chop time yeah and money here and then the meter here
morning sun shining brighter than any gold you shall have
yeah more air for crits yeah that's what it's thinking metal
sort remain within the earth all right your specialty on
more damage after remaining active oh okay every one second
When we gather resources from a location, restore some...
Okay, two, right?
Manner regen.
Yeah, I don't need that.
I got more magic.
Wait, that regen sucks?
Okay, well...
Oops.
Alright.
Oopsie.
Oh.
I guess here we go.
Found something new to...
work a chill sweat through the air as you approach and
seasonably cold and perhaps it is as Demeter desires you go
to time out corner does she not she does she knew me for her
granddaughter at once have you had opportunity to speak with
her about me and all that's transpired now I've been a bit
preoccupied at least Here Demeter she'll be able to cool her
wrath against me for keeping you a secret for so long But
she mad that's on you
Oh my god wake up wake up wake up wake up, wake up, wake up,
please What the fuck okay, it's fine
Okay Oh, God.
It's okay.
Wake up.
Wake up, Samurai!
Oh, shit.
Wait, is that the...
Oh, that is the right one.
I couldn't tell.
Oh, my God.
Wake up, please.
There you go.
What the fuck?
Ow!
No, no, I'm a pig!
Oh, no, I've got something to say.
Oh, my God.
Where's the cat?
Cat, wake up.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Where's my cat?
There she is.
Please!
Okay, nice.
Okay, good.
Nice.
Got her.
Oh Yeah, she bought a spell from Cersei one further secret
of the oath of the unseen I shall reveal now When you feel
suitably prepared consider this then perhaps clash under a
new yeah, that's not your spell What the fuck?
Where did you get that?
Oh, I got the Val Rivals.
I heard someone said that that's a good spell Or something.
I don't know what it's for that's talking about in chat
earlier.
Yeah.
Oh, I accidentally was using the Deftify and stuff's fine.
Cost 3% less.
Okay.
Talk to you.
Alas, there are no seasons in the underworld.
Alright, off we go.
I forgot what my...
Oh, yeah.
That's for the fabric, which I never received.
Okay, we just got a killer.
This should be fine.
Should be fine.
Okay.
It's okay.
Should boomerang this for a bit.
Okay.
boom wait where's my cat cat go go do your thing good job
cat oh hey fishing we'll grab that fish yay oh i got gutter
paw that's cute
that's cute i like that what the fuck that hurt me what the
fuck did that hurt me
Jesus that has a lot of damage Oh my god Cat this time It's
time cat Uh More blitz Wait Damage from Immelene the
activation Makes them stronger The casting ban Oh 60% Oh I
don't know They're all really good One or One two and three
Are all good chat One Three Two Okay we are I don't care
Okay Druidy rules, guys.
What's my druid?
Middle.
I have to use more cast, though.
One, two.
One.
Always blitz?
Oh.
It's hard.
Okay, trust it.
One is most...
One buffs...
Fuck!
I think you're right.
One.
I'm gonna go for one.
This will be over soon.
Okay.
I think it's just one guy, right?
I don't even need it.
Fuck yeah, I'm gonna go straight for the hammer.
I feel like there's no...
I wouldn't need anything else other than the hammer.
Honestly, okay, guys.
Come out of your goddamn shell.
That's...
Oh, shit.
Wake up.
It's time.
Oh, this is...
This is very frustrating.
Okay.
There you go.
And we'll grab this too.
Where's the hammer?
Oh, there it is.
Specials have plus 15 and deal of damage.
Your dash strike also fires your special three times at once
in a fan pattern?
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, my attacks have plus 20.
Oh.
Does it mean, does it automatically fire?
Does it automatically fire?
Oh, it does!
Oh, shit!
Wait, that's crazy!
Oh, God, no.
No, please.
Please.
No!
Wait, I have a cat!
Oh, my God.
It's cat time.
Wake up.
I'm so scared of this rat.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god, he's so strong.
He's so strong.
Oh my god, where's my cat?
Wake up.
Oh my god, there he goes.
Oh my god.
Oh, where is he?
Thank God.
Uh-oh.
God's what a monster.
He is definitely a menace.
Your taxiomer damage, your cast inflicts...
Wait!
Freeze!
I get freeze and it expands.
That's good, right?
One is better than three?
I hate that mouse too.
Yeah, I don't know.
Because it's like...
Yeah, cast.
I'll do a cast for you.
Yay!
Alright.
That's good.
I got double.
We actually got...
We got a good one.
We got the echo too for it.
Because I was stuck between those three.
There you go.
That should be all of them.
Nice.
Oh.
come over here wait what oh I don't have auto now all
right uh Hermes oh
god it's okay all right oh my god I can't get my cat over
here nice
oh either one of you she couldn't just send you off to deal
with grants before you were ready you must having to wait i
know i do all right any you gain your sprints and gives you
a barrier you more damage your weapon for the next 45
seconds plus one percent one percent is not that much i feel
like i don't even know we're we're early game yet
yeah hermes has no friends are you okay i'll do it then
uh the meter do i need hp oh maybe i do i'm like looking at
it i'm like jesus christ yeah maybe i do need hp
okay all right nice maybe i can just stand here oh my god
it's so fast we should Showed them to specials deal more
damage and inflict freeze wherever you gather resource
restore some health gain plus one Deal more damage if you're
enough the bonus is damage.
Okay, so people are telling me I should try to use my Fool
and inflict freeze.
I do use my special a lot, so I'm gonna do that Okay shop.
I assume the next one is the the boss now Olympus I accept
this message Sprint is faster.
Honorary damage and daze all foes after your cast expires.
Rapidly deal damage.
In the area for two seconds.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
New sprint.
Tucked away.
And then...
Your sprint is faster.
Attacks and special deals.
You have to spam a lot of dash.
I'll do two, yeah.
Hmm.
And I can fish, too.
Get over here, cat.
Yay!
Another gutter pop?
All right.
That's fine.
That's all right.
God, wake up my cat.
Yeah, that's me!
Yeah!
One day, we'll get our own big security team to take care of
us.
That's me.
I have little choice.
Here to cancel another concert!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm like that guy, that party-crasher guy that everyone's
afraid of right now.
That like, he literally, like, all the fucking celebrities
have, like, increased security for that one party-crasher,
man.
That's me.
I'm him.
Literally the guy went to the Lady Gaga concert with a
mustache and, like, fucking sunglasses or some shit.
And a wig.
And he still got found.
So do your worst, lady.
That was crazy.
Where's my fucking cat?
What the fuck?
Wait, where's my cat?
Oh, there she is.
Oh, what the...
Okay, I never used this cat before.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
I have to go away.
I have to leave now.
Where is he sleeping?
I'm trying to... Wake up!
Oh my god, the backstab does nothing there I just realized
Where is he?
Wake up!
There you go.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god, that was not fine.
That's not fine.
Bless her.
Okay.
It's okay.
It's no longer okay.
Where's my cat?
Where the fuck is my cat?
Like, I'm just trying to find my goddamn cat.
There he is.
Okay.
I got her, though.
Okay, I got it.
I got C still.
Whrrr.
Alright, nice.
Got five in him again.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Cut!
Okay, there we go.
Oh!
Lost it, catchy song.
There we go.
Yeah!
Oh, I got the nightmare too.
You're more like, I don't know.
Do you think I could do...
Do you think I could do the thing for...
For...
For like the grandpa?
Think that's possible?
Which one would help?
Wait, I don't get death defiance?
Wait, you stole my...
Oh, it's because I fucking accidentally used it!
Okay.
Oh my god.
I heard I accidentally...
I accidentally used my tooth.
God fucking damn it.
Okay.
It's okay.
I technically have three death defiance because I got my cat
with me.
Yeah.
All right, let's see if we can grab this run.
I think we can do it.
I think it's possible.
My damage is pretty strong.
All right, grab this.
Okay, I have moon.
We'll grab moon first.
We actually have no moon.
I just realized.
Wake up.
I'm always telling him to wake up.
Please.
Please wake up, cat.
Oh my god, you serious?
That hurt me?
Okay.
All right, nice.
Oh.
This one vow that may rise above the rest.
It is my charge as I of night to bear it witness.
Should you choose to speak this vow of rivals, discover the
extent of it, and overcome your strongest foes.
Okay.
I can do that.
Please make your choice.
All right.
Together we shine.
We get to summon a minion.
There we go.
We got a little Medusa.
Uh, heftime.
Please don't give me an echo here.
I don't know if there's another thing.
It would be very sad.
Oh, yeah.
Let's hope there's no...
I'm just hoping that God...
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'm gonna grab this before I claim it.
Just in case.
I don't feel so strong, though.
Your damage and attack deal more damage for each.
I have four.
I think that's good.
I have four, so I have a lot of attacks.
The meter.
The meter or Apollo chat.
Which is better?
Since I have time, I actually have to...
I have to, like, pause it.
Apollo and Grandma.
There's a fish.
Oh, there's a fish.
No, that's not a fish.
Where's my fish?
Oh, there's a fish.
I got tears.
Why are they all sad?
Why are all my fishes sad?
I'm like concerned.
All my fishes are so sad.
Oh my god.
I need a cat.
I need the cat I'm not doing so well.
I am not doing so well Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh I'm just gonna use this I don't trust myself right now
Okay, okay, are you fucking kidding me?
Yeah, get it here.
We need your help I did HP like 20 times!
Okay.
After your cast, uh...
We'll get like smite.
They were all garbage.
Anyway.
Which is more worth it, guys?
Guys, which is...
a hammer on the right or do we skip echo i need hammer
hammer okay i'll pick hammer yeah i was thinking i feel like
hammer would be better more of those shades oh my god give
me oh my oh my god i need that oh my god the did you get me
there No, I agree about the fucking...
Shit.
I need a tree.
Okay, there's a tree.
We'll grab HP first, because I'm dying right now.
Okay, got more heals here.
Oh god.
Alright, I can get my mana right now here.
Mana regen.
Ging it, Hef.
God damn it, I didn't see it.
God, I hate these guys the most.
They're fucking stupid-ass projectile.
Get him out of here, too.
Maybe it was a bad idea to get the cat.
All right.
Cast your damage, your Weapons still weren't damaged based
on...
Oh.
D plus... Am I getting hit right now?
What's hitting?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll grab that.
I hope I got the right item.
I was too busy trying to figure out what was hitting me.
Where's the hammer?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh my god, it's so fucking far.
Stuck.
Oh, God.
Wake up.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
There we go.
Your tax deal.
Tracking votes.
Your tax are 35.
Oh, they're all pretty good.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, you ripped them under the natural environment.
Can't even breathe.
Would they not look sad that you were the super chat that
you think?
I would say two.
Yeah.
Master is always good.
Maybe I'll bump into Echo again.
Maybe I'll give me another Echo.
Nope.
Oh.
I mean, that's Moon Hermes.
Yeah, you know what?
That's a lot of.
That's a lot.
Oh my god.
I'm Rainbow now.
Lucky you.
Who said that?
Oh my god, where is she?
Where is she?
I'm scared.
I don't trust her.
Like, what is she doing here?
Okay, nice.
All right.
She's back.
Oh!
That's three?
Oh, I have three!
You don't even know unless you take damage.
If you deal with my until you take down, you take more and
more and more for you're getting this.
Out of your cast rapidly to deal damage near it.
Ooh, two.
Self-healing.
The force of fire.
Yeah, self-healing is good.
I'm gonna grab this first before I talk to her.
I don't trust her.
I wanted this, right?
Hey, this is different.
I'll get to the end.
Yeah.
Oh, pretty much sucks, so I need to get to the end.
Also lost here in these fields, I guess.
Trade you a map or something if I had one, but you wouldn't
have been able to afford it.
So I'd use it to get out of here myself.
I don't know if I could kill Prometheus, yeah.
Pathways seem to shift from night to night.
I've been able to make use of the Golden Bows scattered
about at least.
What about you?
The Golden Bows.
Had no idea those did anything but look all sad.
I need a charge that would actually that...
That I can cat like throw.
That can chuck.
You give.
Oh.
Yeah, I'll take that.
Fair is fair.
I have money.
Okay.
Your special deals more damage and inflicts freeze.
Oh!
One!
Right?
It is a scam, but like, I'll take it.
Um...
More armor?
Yeah, but it's eight.
Eight is nothing, I feel like.
It is barely anything.
Not that good.
A gift from the earth.
all right
yeah there you go my cat i'm always trying to figure out
where the fuck my cat is like are you fucking kidding me
god damn okay that's fine god i hate those ones they're so
fucking annoying all right let's see is that the last one on
my authority well you have at least eight
That's a very tall order.
Alright.
What are my chances again?
Days?
Right?
Oh wait, except for dodge and days.
I have to go one.
Yeah.
That's, yeah.
No, I'm not close to either.
No, we're guys, we're not very close.
To any of those.
I'm ready for you.
Unfortunately.
I would love to beat.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god, that's a lot of pimples on the ground.
Okay, we gotta get to the end game here.
I'm gonna try and head to the end.
I should be able to get out, I think.
Is that money?
Uh, we gotta go to shop.
Oh!
Alright.
time 120 150 125 oh yeah i have enough i mean that's the
only thing i can get the only thing i get okay that's fine
that's fine okay i i don't know how this is gonna go for
servers because like Oh my god.
Where's my cat?
Okay, go in there.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Cat, it's time.
God damn it, cat.
Okay, that's okay.
We just gotta get this guy.
Alright, cat, it's time to wake up.
Wake up!
Oh, God.
I don't know where he's gonna go.
Where he's gonna go.
It's okay.
We just gotta wake her up.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That got me?
Oh, I didn't even remember.
I almost forgot I had the...
Okay.
he's awake oh yeah oh my god
okay that's fine wake up oh my god she missed oh my god she
actually missed okay
that's fine she woke up it's okay she still woke up Oh,
thank God.
I didn't use my death defiance.
Oh, I'm really worried because I am missing the tooth right
now.
I fucked up with that.
I do have three, but like, I'm scared because I did.
I am missing the strongest death defiance.
Okay, how do I get out of here?
Is this way?
Oh my God, I almost forgot how to get out of here.
there all right grandpa time grandpa time uh what is this
this one just grab doom all right we'll try doom out doom
i've never done the doom one yet before is there anything
that's good here game bonus help based on your limit max
life from magic i don't think i need anything i don't need
to sell any of them i believe this is the last grandpa run
if i if i make it if we make it here this would be the last
grandpa run and then we can go all in on all in on the
surface All right, nice.
Cat tab.
Cat, wake up!
Where the fuck are the others?
Okay, whoa, he died so fast with the cat.
Jesus Christ.
Come on, that was so fast.
Summon him too.
In this.
Okay.
Okay, we have cat and a minion.
Let's go!
Is that it?
Wait, where's the last guy?
Oh, wait, food.
What's that?
They're all dead?
Oh, they are.
Oh, dad!
Oh, thank you for the red!
Thank you!
He still hates me.
I can't believe that I'm asking, but how fair is the
limitless in all this?
I don't know.
They're not doing all right.
I mean, they are fighting a lot of things, but I think
they're doing all right.
the surface swarms with the dead and the armies of Kronos
are besieging the mountain yeah dad it's it's not doing all
right sorry not a pretty sight up there right now not a
pretty sight up there you mean to say you've seen all this
firsthand how you mean our birthright would you believe I
learned a means by which I could withstand surface climate
for a while I did that long enough to that's surprising that
like never tried you know never tried to like use a spell
seemingly all these impossibilities continue to occur she
literally just did it instantly as well as come to the
rescue of Olympus how all right after taking damage come oh
wait we need that sure everyone damage no one percent damage
you until you reach the limit life taxer if your
reinforcements is always good just so easy bro she's such a
she's just like yeah like it's hard you know that's what she
feels like she's like yeah yeah i can breathe in the air
like it's hard wake up
all right nice oh my god what the you mean break
okay there we go let's get her out of here first all right
uh oh apollo what's this okay okay we're waking you up
you're you're you're waking up now oh my god oh my god okay
like i need you awake
there you go
you need more damage to take damage.
If you take no more than 50 seconds, regain this.
Oh, pose with days taking more damage.
Oh, but I don't know if I can strike them from behind.
Oh, it's Rusky.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you had to choose which game do you think is better?
I think two, just because there's more content in two.
I think.
I literally, that is true.
I do it.
have the backstab weapon but like i'm very bad at it my dash
i hit some robot okay we'll try that out all right because
last time i took something similar it did not go so well for
me all right we'll do that first juice i can dodge easier oh
my god okay um okay uh what am i even replacing i don't even
know what is this oh wait that's good that's better wait
three is this better than standing still or nah I say three
bro I get like not a lot of armor okay I'll try I'll try
guys we are a family that is true but when the need arises
the final say I mean it's true he is like he is big Big
Papa.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, I can't see.
Where's my cat?
I can't see.
Yeah.
I mean, he's not wrong, though.
He's like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's so many!
There's so many!
Oh my god, we're not doing okay.
We are not doing okay We already lost 20 armor.
We already lost 20 from that
Alright, oh, that's fine.
Oh Wait Metal damage per hit.
Oh, wait Prime 50 Ooh
Oh I'd be like two, but I would prime a lot.
I have five.
But I don't know.
I do have five.
I have five in fusion.
Is it worth it?
Is it worth it, chat?
Okay, I'll do five then.
Oh, yeah, more palms.
Yeah, I do have it.
Okay, wake up.
Oh, wake up.
I need you to be awake right now.
Okay.
Oh, God, oh, God.
Oh, my God.
That was close.
That was actually very close.
All right.
Let me stand still.
Okay.
Palm time.
Faster, foes with it.
Hmm.
I guess back burner.
Uh...
I guess 111% is a lot.
I think I do have re... Yeah, I'll take... It's a lot.
A few more chambers.
It is a lot.
I'm like thinking about it.
Okay.
My backstabbing him, I can't tell.
I get that.
Where are their backs?
It's just a head.
Look, it's very hard to tell where the fucking facts are in
for this.
It's just all head.
Whoops, all head.
There you go.
Anything back here?
No.
Yeah, at least my boomer...
That's good to know that my boomerang...
Oh my god!
Oh my!
Okay, okay, wake up.
Wake up.
Oh, wake up.
Yeah, this is not good for me.
It is not, this is a lot.
Okay, that's fine.
I need to remember to use my, uh, my summon.
I forgot about my summons again.
I'm just gonna stay over here.
There you go.
Wait, which one's, oh my god, that's fine.
Which one's mine and which one's the enemy?
I can't tell.
Okay.
Oh, moon.
Okay, I can get the final for my minion for this.
Yeah, okay.
It's fine.
I'll also get like my final thing for my summons.
Okay, backstab.
Backstab.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, there's so much going on.
Oh my god!
Summon!
Where am I?
I actually lost track where I am.
I can't tell.
Where the fuck am I?
Okay.
I'll make it over, right?
You'd steal 5%.
All right, we'll grab that.
And then...
Boom.
Eraser and that's...
That'll grab this.
Uh...
Alright, that's five.
Oh!
No, I can't do it.
I won't make it.
Five encounters.
I should grab this.
Yeah, because I think the next one is...
Yeah, it is.
Next one would be chaos.
grandpa I'm pretty sure yeah we gotta wake him up before we
fucking do whatever the fuck we had to do here okay there
you go it's okay nice it's time I'm behind him that's where
I got got your back oh my god I'm back backstabbing the hell
out of him right now all right uh oh money money time
i think i'm backstabbing
oh god okay let's where's my cat i can't see i always lose
track of him
jesus christ there's so many people all right it's just sad
as yellow and he's yellow it's so hard to tell
hi okay what can i get what the god damn it i should need
the sale god okay i i don't need zeus i
I need the end mare.
No, it's just so much better.
Yeah.
That's all my money.
It is.
It is all my money.
I have to get it.
Long term wise, it's just better.
Swim time.
Yeah.
It'll be fine, right?
Returned from above ground.
You continue to return.
more than these conversations of ours but also that mirror
and those squalid shameless hand the whole the single
artifact i could not budge but it is useless without night
herself i'm not here for this house's former furnishings you
should know you have at least one relative who would be most
distraught if you were destroyed you alone can prevent that
if you would end all this only one that's so sad grandpa oh
i intend to But we are far past the point of preventing the
distress of this supposed relative to whom you refer What
was already done is done.
Yeah, I'm like, who?
That's so sad.
It's like only one person is coming to your funeral.
That's like one of the sad parts.
Okay, where is my cat though?
Wake up, wake up.
Oh my god, my armor's already gone.
already got.
That's not good.
Okay.
What?
That's bullshit.
Okay, that's fine.
I need to get rid of this anyway.
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
Where's my cat?
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I have summons.
I almost forgot about my summons.
Okay.
Oh god, I didn't even see that.
Okay, I gotta get this guy out of here.
Are you fucking kidding me?
There you go.
Where is he?
Oh fuck, okay.
He missed him, he missed.
Ha ha, you missed, bitch.
I'm gonna take it.
three two all right at least he's sleeping yeah I can't get
there are you fucking oh my god oh my god and then of course
he sleeps
oh my god he's sleeping here
Okay, that's five.
It's not, but that's five.
Oh, it got me.
It got me.
Okay.
Where's the healer?
Okay, that's five.
That's an easy summon for me.
Oh, oh, we're okay.
We're okay.
Oh, my God.
That's not good.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
Heal!
Heal me!
Help me!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Heal me.
It's fine.
There we go.
Oh, I had a good build in the end.
That's good.
No depth of fire is needed.
I've had a really good build for this one, for this weapon.
I'm glad.
Of course you do.
That was really strong.
Yeah, the backstab build was actually nuts.
And do hurry.
Fry shall never be gone.
Bye.
Bye, Grandpappy.
Should I try for the surface?
If I get backstab build again, it'll be really good for us.
Oh my god, I've been taking so long for these builds.
He's gone for now.
Alright, I'll try a backstab build for the surface.
But I have to get a backstab build, though.
Surface is way harder.
I know, that's what I'm saying.
Do I keep with a backstab build?
something beside the bed oh shit guy caros this must be it
got it dream its essence is real yeah we did it we got the
weapon once more night and darkness guide me to my blood
beyond the grasp of time oh you always said to trust my
instincts so Oh my god, he pulled through.
My brother pulled through.
No, the axe build I was tanking so much.
I don't think it's going to work in the long run.
Zachary, you did it.
I found the traces of Gargoyle is here, which should be what
I need for what comes next.
No, I was not doing it.
I used all my death defiances for that build.
I don't think it's going to go well.
takes but i've been giving this a lot of thought and there's
an alternative i wanted to propose you said before you've
never even met kronos let's say you find him in his fetid
layer what are the outcomes then well let's see one i could
murder him as we discussed two i could fail miserably in the
attempt or three we hit a thousand oh yeah yeah maybe maybe
grandpa will you know maybe you'll be best friends with
grandpappy and then he won't freeze you more or less bear
with me what if prior to striking you first took that latter
course got to know him endeared yourself to him if possible
wait what we'd have ourselves a nice grandson to grandfather
chat I could invite him to the house for a bottle of
Ambrosia he's been festering a while perhaps he's keen for
company you're serious I am but he's been festering for far
too long and very bitter that our family broke ties with him
his ambitions likely can't be changed even in your time
though if nothing else perhaps you can use such knowledge
against him you really do mean he and i should have a chat
so we become best mates what then and maybe if you become
his best friends he won't be misunderstood anymore you know
like all disney villains just talk to them and then
everything gets better a security specialist it ought to be
within your right he probably is far too proud to go quietly
but it's a chance.
Well, why not?
If he hasn't met me right, or you for that matter, then he
can't be harder to talk to than father,
on site version at least.
But I need assurances that if the conversation does not go
the way you wish, you will not hesitate to run him through.
Then here are those assurances.
If I meet him, can't get through to him, don't like him, and
determine he's a threat to you and all of us.
I'll kill him.
Whoa!
just that easy what if he just okay but he can come back to
life though I had this task death to Kronos but that was
never the goal in its entirety yeah he's like I'll just kill
him it's like is this that easy you know I'll just kill him
I'm like bro I killed him like seven times right it's not
that easy I'm like bro like I've killed him three times bro
he's still there Be ready.
Preparing Gaigaros may take a little while, and I may have
difficulty reaching you until such time, but I'll return.
Till then, be well, Zagreus.
Big brother.
He's got a real big spear, though.
He does.
I don't know, but it's not that easy to kill him.
It doesn't matter.
What is easy for me?
I'm a gamer, but we don't know.
Look, Zagreus, he has been doing these runs in a while,
guys.
Washed.
For the dissolution of time.
But I won't find it in the underworld.
Guys, he's fucking washed right now.
He's been chilling with his multiple girlfriends.
I've heard about the latest happening, sister.
But we'll discuss them out there on the hunt.
Not while we're here.
Oh, she just wants to sing.
Alright, we have...
What's to be done?
Okay, that's good.
We need more fountain water anyway.
And boyfriends, sorry, too.
His multiple girlfriends and boyfriends.
Yeah, I don't know if he's fit right now to do all that
shit.
I still don't.
I must be the last one.
Must be, like, on the surface.
Let's grab these plants.
I guess now I can just plant mystery seeds.
Oh, I don't have any mystery seeds.
I'll just plant random shit.
Because I don't need it, technically.
Oh.
I'll just grab everything here.
Your goal is within reach, Goddess.
That much I know, just from how tense the good witch seems
to be of late.
Not to pry, but are you clear about what more needs to be
done?
I believe so.
I'd be inclined to tell you all of it, except you know how
Headmistress gets about these things.
Suffice it to say that the final phase of our plan is in
progress.
Yay!
I'm doing it.
That's all I need to hear.
This phase is up to you and her.
the surface level just this is that easy just just you know
just need to beat prometheus that's all i have to do it's
just that easy perhaps i could have protected them as was my
charge to think the fates themselves may have denied me the
attempt it's discomforting that i may never know good talk
sharon good talk you have every reason to be angry i'm angry
too nonetheless i'm grateful that our paths have intertwined
again be safe caron another shipment already yeah we always
gotta get more psyche i need how many fate fabrics
i need three oh i can buy them now i'll take it never mind
never mind All right, give me a sec.
All right.
Oh my gosh, I still don't have enough.
Oh, I need shadow.
Fuck, okay, I need...
Yeah.
Can't do anything here.
I'm poor.
What say the cards this Eve?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Yay!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Alright, I can't upgrade now.
Uh, I wanted to grab this.
I want to try this.
Show me your true strength.
Alright, let's try it.
Let's try this.
What does this look like?
What the fuck is that?
Oh!
Wait, I like that.
Let's try that out.
The ancient fate-wrought arms of night is now rejoined under
the princess of the underworld's care.
All equally prepared to rid the realm of any of its foes.
Origination.
What the fuck is that?
Guys, I don't know you even know what that is.
Origination?
Where is that?
Or cana?
Oh!
Not now.
Curses.
Wait, but I don't have enough.
Who do I get rid of, though?
Okay, but what do I get rid of?
Oh, money?
I guess I...
Oh.
Um, maybe do I have enough?
Ash.
Ooh, that's awkward.
Oh, I can sell?
How do I sell my fish?
We'll take my fish.
We'll take it.
I have fish for sale.
Oh, I can't sell it yet.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh.
Alright, I guess not.
I guess we just go up to the surface.
then oh my god we'll get rid of this oh what the fuck oh
shit yeah no get that shit out of here best be a little
cautious here probably smart you must think you're pretty
tough by now don't you beaten chronos or whoever down again
and again but are you pushing yourself to the fullest or
taking it easy few would consider the task of vanquishing
the titan of time to be an easy one commander though i take
your meaning the oath of the unseen beckons Come on, use it.
My disciples and I are practically daring you.
You'll get to spruce up your nocturnal arms.
We'll get to see what happens.
No, that's okay, guys.
It's okay, guys.
We don't need to upgrade anything, guys.
We just...
It's just time to do the runs.
It's okay.
We're just gonna do the runs now, guys.
I have it.
No use.
Uh...
Okay, so I...
Yeah, I don't have anything.
Oh, I could upgrade an insight.
Can I upgrade?
Uh...
Plus three.
Oh!
Do I save for depth defiance?
I could.
I don't think so.
I feel sure it's a good one.
Should I just do that?
Chat.
For re-rows?
I don't think I need the re-rows.
Or initial HP.
Oh, wait.
Restore is four.
I could do that, too.
Is this worth it?
I'm in four Restore.
Oh, wait.
Plus 30.
Yeah.
Max life.
I'm going to get that.
More HP.
All right, let's try a surface run.
All right.
Let's try this out.
Let's see what we can get.
Let's see what we can kill Prometheus this time.
A hammer?
Oh, shit.
It's hard.
That requires me to channel this more.
But, do I do it?
One with the staff?
I will try.
My stuff.
Yeah, and I have the moments, too.
I have this.
all right cat fish tab yay oh that that fish is half eaten
okay let's try this out I have two oh I can oh that's cool
okay I just need regen now I know we should be good all
right we just need regen ah for daddy golden apple on you
love i knew you had good taste their uses are more plentiful
than you can imagine okay apollo or hara okay we gotta make
sure we grab are able to grab it
but she had three oh oh okay nearby foes oh wait they're all
good
glamour game sucks should we get one then since our specials
already boosted up Or two?
Very good versus bosses.
It's bad for this weapon.
I'm going
to say one.
Other three.
Majority rules.
Sorry, buddy.
Alright, let's calculate this.
Oh, hey, what?
There's someone to talk to.
We'll grab Zeus first, just for the...
Actually, no, let's talk.
Let's go get the talking one.
Let's go see the NPC.
Is it Hercules?
Oh, who are you?
Hello?
Oh, wait, mine.
Mining, mining, mining.
Mining.
Media.
Media?
spreads every which way you cast your gaze and on a night
most foul simply appalling no goth mama oh my dear i can
only appreciate the suffering for so long as olympus calls
though how fair's your research i mean so many new people
making lots of new friends
nice i didn't know global warming is ready to hit that much
oh my god she's draining her blood
Wait, this is good If I can get to the end If I don't die Do
the, okay Or plus Okay, wait I could get HP back Wait, what?
I don't think I need the money That much for In game Wait,
this 2 actually suck I was seeing about Prometheus.
He fucks me up.
Okay, we'll get three.
Okay.
I mean, finding, getting heals is always good.
Planning for failure.
Oh, this is hard.
I'm going with three.
I'm going for three.
I feel like I need HP more.
Oh, that.
I feel like I definitely need HP more, guys.
I feel like I fucked over by HP more than that, others.
And then we'll go for the Zeus.
We'll go for Zeus next.
Zeus is here.
What the fuck?
There you go.
Yeah, I got the Pylon.
We got the cat over here, too.
Oh, fuck, I didn't even see the house.
I didn't see that.
I didn't see this guy's fucking house right here.
No house for you.
Nice.
And there's food, too.
Oh, I forgot to gift her.
I forgot to gift the mom.
There is some difference of opinion here regarding where
your efforts are of greatest benefit.
We shall keep the matter on Olympus well in hand.
But we cannot get to Kronos in your father's realm as easily
as you.
Hermes is a must.
Okay, well, do not blitz on attack.
Wait, why not?
Alright, one or three?
Three?
Three days solid?
Oh my god, that's not a lot of magic now.
Oh no, I don't know why I decided to freeze the fucking...
Let me freeze the house real quick.
Gotta make sure he doesn't move.
Guys, I gotta make sure.
Alright.
Yeah, it's 30.
You're back.
I gotta get more mana.
Gotta freeze the house, guys.
We don't know if the house is gonna move.
We don't.
We gotta make sure to keep the house there.
What if the house grows legs?
It could happen.
Okay, we should get the magic.
Yeah, magic and the moon.
I'm gonna get magic and moon.
We need magic.
Really badly.
Alright.
Wait, the hunter is...
Oh, wait!
Athena's here.
Nice.
That's nice of her.
Oh.
It's alright.
I got it again.
Uh, oh hey.
Don't be frightened.
Hail sister.
I forgot the frog does it automatically.
That frog doing it automatically was so good.
You sister.
Your brother once had us all convinced.
Sorry, Artemis.
His way to Olympus.
Now none of us can believe you're trying to do this.
to do it for real homies wouldn't have asked me to go if it
wasn't important nice I got magic and a and a spoon then by
all means what a time that you're on your way up to the
mountain while I'm on my way down to the underworld at least
we oh yeah I was like wondering why she was here I thought
she doesn't exist up here our seeking arrow plus 3% is not
that much A random flow location becomes marked if it takes
credo damage.
This repeats.
Hmm.
One?
Okay.
I'll try it.
Oh, hey.
Free room.
Oh my god, it just fucking slaps me for free.
All right.
Nice.
Money.
Oh, and food.
Yay.
Free food.
Oh, is there anything else here?
I'm glad that it gives me food.
Um, three more.
I guess I'll go for moon?
And I don't know which one to get after.
I don't know what would be good after the moon.
Honestly.
Jesus Christ, that's a lot.
Okay, don't worry.
I can summon another one.
I freeze the house.
Yeah, it's very important.
Okay, get over here.
Alright, yeah, fuck that one.
That's like a fucking bulldozer.
Holy shit.
I draw you down, Arun.
Lend me your light.
Hermes?
Okay, we'll do Hermes.
Of your vision in which Kronos found and captured the three
fates.
This must have been a key component of his plan.
That one has.
But it does not change.
hours.
The silver sisters never seed control.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, this is always good.
Is there any rooms?
I just gotta make sure I can upgrade this later too.
So my summons would be better.
Oh hey guys.
Can I kill these guys for free?
Nice.
Yay, money.
I know I didn't...
I didn't wait for you guys to answer me.
I was like, I'm going to do it.
Hermes.
There you go.
There's Hermes.
Okay, we'll grab this.
And then I'm going to wake up my cat real quick.
There you go.
Wake up!
God, I just tore the house.
Okay, nice.
I don't know who I summoned, but that's good.
Where's my cat again?
Where the fuck is my cat?
I'm just going to destroy this.
One pine on left.
Alright, one more pylon.
I always lose my cat.
She, like, blends in.
You should be resting easy in your father's care, but Graham
shut it all down, flung up in the underworld's gates, and
here we are.
If I were dead, I'd be mad, too.
Alright.
Hit block per counter.
Oh, three.
Moves are faster.
Is I two or three?
I get three hits blocked.
I'm full of Mega.
That's true.
Yeah.
I'll do it.
Yeah, this is a charge build.
I agree.
Yeah, but I saw like three hits.
Okay.
That's like three hits for free?
Alright, last one.
What is a good last pile on chat?
I am a little worried with how little HP I have, though.
Okay, not gonna lie.
This good guy has been...
I feel like he's, like, talking to his inner demons.
Like...
He's, like, having his own conversations.
With...
I don't know with who, though.
I...
I don't know him, who?
Every time I look over, I'm like, I don't know what he's
responding to.
I hope actually with his inner demons.
I'm like...
All right, let's see you.
Oh, wait, there's the house.
All right, nice.
Okay, we always need HP.
Oh, nice.
Another one.
Yeah, it's like...
Oh, wait, yeah, it is.
It's like the guy that's replying to his own...
Like, those people that do, like, replies to their own
threats.
Oh, wait.
Triple health.
Let's go.
Yeah, this one feels like every time I look over.
I'm like...
He's, like, talking to the voices right now.
But it's, like, the text in his head.
Alright.
Chop time.
I have 615.
That should be enough.
Might as well take a sip.
Oh, I forgot the fountain.
I mean, I'm full HP.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot.
A lot of free stuff.
And a fish, too?
Let's go.
It's over.
Got me a zeal.
Alright, I have enough for everything.
Oh, I didn't get a free hat.
Not free.
I had to pay for that.
There you are.
Paying for goods and services as though Kronos has already
prevailed.
all right she wants a sacrifice
oh plus three percent per boon plus three percent per boom
yeah but i have
heroic is it worth it two for sure two is a huge swap okay
i'll try it
I'll try it.
Get the atom ball.
All right, nice talk.
This is going to be a 10 plus hour stream.
No, no, no, no.
It's not going to be a 10 plus hour stream this time.
I just want to try Prometheus.
I don't know.
We'll see how it goes.
We'll see how this run goes.
And then I'll see if I'll do another run.
I just want to see if I could beat Prometheus here.
Because I know there's another area after Prometheus.
I wanted to say thanks.
Gave me a real zinger there last time, you know that.
You're back.
And you're grateful that I vanquished you earlier.
You seem more the sort to hold a grudge.
I'm like a challenge.
It's just...
Sliving him, Jokey, please.
After you lock me up, call him.
6 a.m oh yeah see he's like using me as like nap time
yeah he's like free nap time you know oh my god i'm like
accidentally okay give me a sec i gotta grab my cat what the
how does that hit me that's bullshit okay oh my god that's i
don't know how i'm getting hit okay that's good i got free
food okay i'm summoning
that's right can't see me oh shit okay it's fine my cat's
here i'm gonna grab my cat real quick i'm like burning
all right there you go
oh my god i can't see shit
okay it's okay okay he's not grab you can't grab me nice no
deft of fire slowly approaching ring hate that all right
about the wool as well i think he yeah he took up a lot of
my age Yeah, I think I was, like, full HP there.
Any food?
We'll grab this, and then...
Yeah, we'll grab the concave stone.
And...
Water tab.
That should be everything.
I should have bought... I should have got the Ares for
the...
Now then.
For Ares, I should have got the...
What was it?
The, like...
the minus damage in hp shit too i was debating about it
such a strange and awful fleet that kronos has don't like it
mr first game always punish me for being too good i know
what you mean fuck eris that's the only thing i hate about
80s 2.
is the only thing i hate about it like that oh sorry for
being good Like, why should I be punished?
Where am I?
Oh, I'm over here.
Okay, get Demeter.
Oh, I summoned.
Oh, my God, I summoned this guy.
I gotta wake up the cat.
Nice.
Oh.
If you mean to our world's surface, have you, Flower?
If you mean to visit our mountain, and merely follow the
path of desolation leading straight to us all right your tax
deal more damage inflict freeze your cast inflicts freeze
and we quickly deal this damage the foes and the binding oh
i know one or two
two arctic ring is better all right we'll do two oh my god
are you serious okay You could have given me one, Echo.
Echo, I needed one!
It was one or two, not one or three!
God damn it.
It's like, Joki, why?
It's free.
Why are you complaining?
Whoops.
Ash.
Okay, that guy's gonna die soon.
Wait, I can mine some cannonballs, though.
Before it happens.
And this.
Alright.
Bomb.
Push closer.
Alright, wake up.
Okay, there you go.
Nice, wake up!
Alright.
I think the attack should be different colored.
I'm not gonna laugh.
Okay, born again.
Static shock.
Ooh.
Magic primed.
Wait.
One?
Which one?
One or two?
One?
Okay, I see more ones.
I don't know how to fight the octopus again.
The octopus was so fucking annoying for...
God damn it.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Alright, I have to blow shit.
Get over here.
I'm summoning him too.
We definitely need a moon though.
We need to upgrade our summons.
I'm not a fan of the lack of summons.
Keep the meter.
Okay, that's fine.
Into the sea with you.
Thank god, I need more.
What?
Icarus?
What are you doing here?
Wait, what?
Why are you dead?
Is that what Icarus is?
He flew too close to the sun.
Bro, stop!
You're gonna die!
You're gonna fly too close to the sun, bro!
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Oh, here he is.
He is dead.
Is he dead?
Yeah, no, but he's on the surface.
The surface world.
I spotted this ship and I had to drop in for a closer look.
He just got better.
But how is he in the surface if he's dead?
Yeah, you're not even supposed to be here.
He just got better.
Yeah, he just got better.
What are you doing in the middle of this blasted war?
The same thing I've been doing, slowing these bastards down.
me pitched in a little bit this war would have been well
over by now that may be so but this is a matter between gods
and titans i wouldn't want you to get hurt all right a bit
late for that melee anyway what does he give me oh shit i've
been working on before i go and these will work i swear well
here's what i've got jesus okay i don't trust myself with
wiremer though
I like two.
20 to me?
Yeah, two.
Three would be...
Guys, we're not...
No.
But it'd be so funny, though.
Alright.
Deal more damage, and it flicked freeze.
I do use my special.
Oh, wait.
Am I going to get six encounters in time?
Chat?
Or do I do...
It was nice, but nicer if it was rare.
What?
Get six encounters?
Two sucks as a common boon?
Oh.
I got plenty of encounters.
Okay, if I get plenty of encounters, I'll risk it.
Oh, grab the ash.
I need you guys to know.
I like forgot any of what upgrades I did.
I have.
Like, I legitimately, I forgot.
I don't know what my fucking build is.
I actually don't know my build right now.
I'm so confused.
Oh, I could have upgraded that.
Fuck.
I forgot about the upgrade shit.
Oh, no.
I don't have a lot of stuff, though.
Oh, I see Octopus too.
Oh, wait, what?
Who's the fuck is this?
Okay, what the fuck?
Oh my god, wake up.
Okay, I was not expecting auto-aim there.
Okay, I need the cat's help.
Oh, God.
Like, I remember it does the auto-aim.
shit oh god oh my god thank god i was not doing so well with
the hp
you prime magic prime 15.
it bounces yeah i'm that like spooks me sprint forms a gust
three or one it's just one though Three is nice.
Or what?
See, I see a lot.
Okay, I'll do one.
I'll get that barrier.
Oh, I didn't see the fucking talk.
It's fine.
I'll grab the tree branch.
I'll grab this guy, too.
It'll be all right.
All right, there you go.
A black ship darkest of them all I hate that hound Olympus,
yet none dare engage with it for long.
Yeah, I said three.
Sorry, I can't count.
I can't count.
I'm bad at counting, guys.
Good evening, Boatman.
Okay.
And make one and random boon.
All right.
Two.
We take the Gamba.
It's time.
It's Gamba time.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, shit!
Wait, that's good Gamba.
Good Gamba!
Okay.
Oh, bad Gamba!
Okay, not really.
Okay, mediocre Gamba.
Average Gamba.
Average.
Let's go.
Okay.
Jesus born again oh my god okay I'm just getting hit by
everything right now
all right her me is time I
don't know how to feel about my fucking oh my god a fucking
course all right I'm just gonna get these guys in nice all
right Olympus, I accept this message.
I have eight?
I don't have eight anything.
I'm not close.
Alright, attacks.
Alright, attacks faster.
That's always good.
Oh, wait, it's this.
Earn it?
I'll slay you all without a scratch.
I don't earn it.
Oh, that's how I earned it.
Alright.
Alright, we gotta...
No!
Without getting hit!
Oh, so close.
I got an onion.
Yay.
I was so close.
I was got cocky.
I got really cocky there.
Oh, it was literally two.
I got, I got two cocky.
I was like, you can't hit me.
I'm so strong.
I was not so strong.
I can Blitz as well?
Yeah, I should have played at range.
I just got too confident.
I got way too confident.
All right, either armor and moon.
I feel like moon because I need I haven't encountered a
single moon upgrade yet and like I need to upgrade my uh I
really need to upgrade the moon thing the summons the
possibilities Backstone is 75 Faster.
Okay.
We're gonna grab this then.
We have to grab that.
The attack's faster.
Okay, we might use a death defiance here.
I'm not confident.
I'm not confident here.
What took you so long?
Give back the golden apple that you took from me last time.
And I might just let you walk this way.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Which one?
I already ate it.
How many golden apples are here anyway?
It doesn't seem so rare if I get to get one every time I
kill you.
Life starts to get a lot more interesting.
What if I already ate it?
You don't always need an invitation to show up.
Keep the apple then.
I've got a whole lot more.
What?
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Oh, I'm scared of her.
I'm...
All right
Where is she?
Get over here, I need your help No, I'm not okay Oh my god,
we have 13 HP It's not looking good guys
Okay Oh god, where am I?
Okay
Oh no
We have to fight, oh wait not Oh, wait, that's my...
That's mine.
I was like, you got this!
That's the shot my own teammate.
I got...
No, that's my own teammate again!
I keep accidentally shooting her.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Please not again.
Not again.
Wake up.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I'm so scared.
Where is she?
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
I'm going to die to a goon.
No.
Oh,
I was so scared.
I was 13 HP in a dream.
Oh.
I got an upgrade, too.
I was not okay.
My cat clutched it.
Come on, Tula.
No, I was spamming that shit.
I definitely need the heals.
And we're grabbing...
Wait, what do I grab?
The tooth.
We're grabbing the tooth.
So we have four depth defiances now.
Uh...
Or we could do the evil eye.
Which is more.
Which you think is better.
Evil eye or the tooth?
Evil eye?
Alright, we'll try it.
Okay.
Might not do so well.
Alright, we'll try our best.
Okay.
Up we go.
That's not your property.
Okay.
All right, there we go.
Oh my god.
You're not expecting to follow me there.
Oh, money.
Ooh, hammer.
All right, hammer time.
There they are.
All right, there we go.
Jesus Christ.
I take those.
Oh my god, yeah, I know I take those.
100%.
Okay.
Where's the hammer?
Oh, hey!
Mining, mining, mining.
Hammer time!
That's hit two, but you use five.
I don't use a lot.
Your special fires, two projectiles, your balance.
Oh!
Two foes.
Dealing.
Plus.
Yeah, I feel like two.
secrets in this stuff okay heart or palm which is better for
us do we need more hp or are we good to go with palm or do
we just need to upgrade
chat hp or just upgrade our palm hp all right i see more hp
fuck that one guy in particular oh my god doesn't even kill
him what's the point doesn't even fucking kill him did all
that for no reason
where is he okay there you go here's the automaton
all right nice
oh yeah no i'm running out of fucking magic suit
let's see hp a magic or a moon moon we gotta get to the end
for summons i'm gonna go for moon we need the summons to end
here there you go
get over here there you go
all right is there more oh yeah there is a lot more there is
a lot more i was like i'm done Unfortunately, we are not
done.
There you go.
Goodness.
Born again.
Divine intervention?
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Yay!
Hello, Athena.
Free stuff time.
Oh, I forgot to give the...
God damn it.
I forgot to give her stuff.
We're planning, doesn't he?
And can retaliate accordingly.
He knows what is to come to some extent.
I already talked to her.
She's gonna leave now.
I got too excited.
And just because he knows you're coming doesn't mean he can
stop you.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
Four death defiances?
Oh, but I prime.
Okay.
does the prime replenish oh my god I don't have wait I do I
have 9 100 wait
I get no magic basically okay I don't get magic okay yeah no
I don't want to risk that I can't afford it okay re-arming
after that can deflect okay we use 90 up to 2 for mana usage
I do use a lot of mana do is better
deflect will help a lot the spears hit hard okay we'll go
too the spears hit hard I'll go with that wait don't leave
don't oh wait wait wait wait don't leave don't okay never
mind guess you leave okay okay that's cool that's fine oh I
just need I need one I literally just need one more.
The sheer might of the moon.
Uh, Demeter or Zeus, guys?
Demeter or Zeus?
I don't know what I need for my build.
Alright, let's hope the boss is not that scary.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, I don't like this boss.
And, uh, we're gonna wake her up.
This boss actually fucks me up, though.
This boss fucks me up a lot.
I'm really- Oh, wait, hey, plant.
Okay, but plant, though.
Try not to, like, die too easily.
God damn it.
Oh, my God.
That scared me.
Okay, I'm okay, okay.
I was like, what the fuck happened to me?
Okay, there we go.
Okay, now, now it's over for you.
Boom!
There we go.
I prefer drakens that cannot fly.
Jesus Christ.
This better be worth it.
So I'm 45!
I could have done three of those and do less.
A lofty mountain is not easily besieged.
So the crafty titan of time saw to wing it beasts
susceptible to his persuasion.
All right, just better give me some good shit From the
skies.
All right, Zeus.
Looks like they've made themselves at home.
My command of the heavens is nothing compared to the strict.
Oh, is this duo of Hera?
The queen and I have struck together through worse times
than this.
Oh, duo!
We've stood together now through more hard times than I can
tell.
She talked about his ways.
perhaps after our present difficulties finally subside and
now his other girlfriends and boyfriends all right what the
fuck okay okay one two duos
okay but like oh i can't do that i have to get the hell
serum yeah i'm not gonna fucking get the three like i think
it's yeah i i lose boring yeah i think it's two yeah sorry
i'm like you you both came over i know you both came over to
talk to me but i'm gonna go with the hell storm yeah they're
like like the queen came over i'm like sorry girl that sorry
it's awkward but um that that's pretty awkward man
she literally came over just to talk to me too and i was
like um so um the thing is You know, your thing is not
better than the other duo, so I'm sorry.
I gotta pick that one.
These palms are even...
You kind of suck.
Alright.
Oh.
One or three.
I don't think I need more...
I don't think Prime really affects me too much.
Two?
Two or one.
I only need three.
Inflict splits.
More blitz, though.
Yeah.
More blitz.
I'll get the blitz just because it's more.
Grab the shop, too.
Um...
I don't know if...
I don't have enough...
Do I have enough money?
I think I do.
Oh, yeah.
spheres yeah coin will i get shop after i don't know this is
the last room that's the thing i don't know if it's the last
room so i'm afraid if i go through here because i can't tell
how many rooms this is
uh yeah this might be the last room check room number bro i
don't what does this guys yeah i'm checking i'm checking the
room number right now i'm checking i'll go to shop yeah it
feels like the last one oh it's not oh thank god okay it's
not the last room oh i could have got money then no escape i
could have got money oh wait i can't afford okay i can get
my magic too five do i have five i have three was struck by
lightning again 50% of the time.
Uh, yeah, yes, a little hat.
You're probably... No, I don't have five.
I have three.
I don't know if I can grab two more in time.
Yeah, I don't.
I have three.
See?
I guess I go...
Yeah.
It would have been great.
I don't think I could.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
yeah but i don't know i can't just grab it asap you know
like i can't just go to walmart be like i would like two air
please i i like two swirlies please
one like i gotta pray that i'll give me two air
uh Alright, we gamba.
Fuck it.
Fuck it, we gamba.
Alright.
Palm?
Palm or health, guys?
Me, I believe.
We're gonna gamble.
HP?
HP, alright.
I think there is a chance this might be the last room, too.
Have a feeling.
Alright, we can grab the cat in here, though.
oh my god that's some gold i'd need that too what the fuck
where the fuck happened i was not expecting that all right
so you're more gold i actually need more gold so badly right
now oh this is not doing so well because we're not getting
more boons we are just getting
ashes I can wait I mean they're just killing each other so
like I don't have to worry about anything all
right nice oh yeah I can summon I keep forgetting the summon
there's just so many buttons right now that I have to
fucking pay attention to Jesus Christ all
right I'm just gonna wait here.
Oh, I can transform.
God damn it.
Oh, thank God Zeus.
Oh, but I think that's just gonna give me four instead of
five.
Uh.
Alright, does that...
I think that's the final room.
That has to be the final room.
Yeah.
I don't think it matters because yeah but i need two chat i
have 192 dollars so i don't think i can afford it i don't
think i can afford
two i have 192 do you think i can afford anything
yeah zoos all right maybe he'll have air hey guys yay money
and a flower yay
I'm at 4 a.m.
now.
I literally need one more.
I'm so bullshit.
I literally just need one more.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, I'm a little...
I don't know.
I feel like...
I don't know if this is the run.
It's the bird.
It's the...
fucking bird.
At least the bird didn't fucking crash the party.
Didn't party crash this time, while it came over.
What would you know of my plight?
You who flail against time itself?
So much courage born of pride.
That's why he has fiery powers, I just realized.
God damn memory game.
Yeah.
God.
Oh my god.
The goddamn fucking bird.
Where's my cat?
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
My cat's in the fire.
I can't do anything about it.
Cat's in the fucking fire.
There you go.
Oh, there you go.
Memory game time.
Middle.
Bottom.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, just made it.
God damn it
Okay Oh my god Oh my god that's a fire
He ate the fire I keep accidentally hitting the fire guys I
swear to god I'm sorry I don't know why Are you fucking
kidding me okay That's okay.
That's okay.
Where the fuck is my snakes?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Middle.
Top.
Middle, top, bottom.
Oh, my God.
Top.
Bottom.
Oh, guys, guys.
I forgot.
What's after that?
Guys.
Guys, what's after?
bottom what's after bottom guys what's after bottom okay top
and then what's after top top middle okay we got no we
couldn't make it we couldn't make it
unfortunately unfortunately he's too He's too fast, guys.
He was way too fast.
I tried.
I really tried.
He was just too fast.
Okay.
Oh my god, I used up all my primes.
Oh my god.
Oh, is it over?
Is there a face too?
I knew this would happen.
Yet I could not prevent it
part.
Oh, he's bleeding.
Oh my god, he's bleeding!
I'm gonna take your liver!
I did it!
Silence.
Save your troubles for your master Kronos.
It's okay.
He's bleeding.
I could take his fucking...
It's not my troubles that I mean to save.
An agent of change.
He can bleed.
Yeah!
Ha ha!
He's gone.
Okay, I saw two more.
No trace remains now of the titan of Fawcite.
We'll pull out his goddamn liver.
Save for a single feather left behind.
As if to go the princess on toward greater heights.
Just no more eagles, please.
Oh, okay, third try.
it took me three tries to get here.
I think the memory game fucked me up.
It's the memory game that messes me up the most.
Okay, now I get to have a tooth.
Alright, tooth time.
Okay, now I have three death defiances again.
I got three more.
I got three more in me.
Wait, is it three?
How many death defiances do I have?
I can't tell.
Two?
Wait, I used two.
He is too- oh my god, I didn't even realize that he's too
deaf defiances.
I don't even remember.
The summit.
Oh hey, that's- that's my uncle.
Hello?
Knock knock.
Oh no.
What the fuck?
Fuck it my- What are these?
That's a, oh my god, that's a good question.
What the fuck are these?
I'm also confused what they are.
Like, is my fucking minion doing anything, question mark?
What the fuck?
I don't even get anything out of here.
All right.
Like, aliens?
Aliens are real.
Oh my god.
They're aliens.
What the?
What the fuck was that?
Okay, I'm getting the Pob.
I don't think we need more Demeter, right?
Unless we can get air.
I can't believe the Greeks got invaded by aliens.
Bomb or boon?
Meter for...
There's no air...
Someone said there's no meter for air.
Yeah.
There's no air for...
The meter attack?
The meter attack.
Okay, we might be able to grab an attack, though.
Yeah, okay.
Closer to the top.
Try this.
What the fuck?
Yeah, what the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
What am I looking at?
It's like even the game doesn't know.
The game is like question mark.
Even the game is like question mark.
I don't even know, bro.
Holy shit!
Oh my god, I might have to use another Death Defiance
actually.
Oh my god!
what the fuck oh my god this is hard i'm so scared i don't
know what he is and i'm scared
oh wow oh my god oh my god
jesus christ oh my god cat i need your help cat this is i
need your help cat
oh my god cat wake up wake up cat wake up
oh my god
the fact that even the game was like bro i don't know bro
oh my god he like slammed me against a wall like three times
i lost all my hp in the name of hades okay i don't even have
six okay we have to get the attack right attack right yeah
now caught out okay i got the jesus that i don't like that I
don't like that it has veins.
I don't like that.
The veins might make me a little uncomfortable, chat.
Just a little.
Jesus Christ.
All right, 20 HP in a dream.
I don't know what to expect here.
I just work.
I don't know what to expect in this world.
I could dig food.
Okay, moon, Zeus.
Jesus.
Okay, they're both.
They are...
If we do moon, we could have the last upgrade.
Okay, for air.
Yeah, we have to get the air.
I know this place.
Oh, God.
We're going to get Deft of Fines here.
No, 100%.
No, we are...
What the...
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay.
Literally, I am hoping the cat will wake up.
Oh, my God!
What did that do to me?
Okay.
Oh, God.
Cat, wake up.
cat wake up wake up cat you gotta wake up bro
oh my god wait what the fuck is going on i don't know what
that does
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh it's coming closer isn't he
jesus christ
I don't know.
I just didn't know.
I- Oh my god!
Shit!
Where's my cat?
He needs to come in right now.
I am very scared.
I am very scared, buddy.
Oh god.
Oh, God.
I'm not going to make it.
Oh, my God.
I don't know what that does.
I know for sure.
I'm not going to make it.
I'm behind him.
Oh, God.
He's getting closer, isn't he?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
At least I get to see them.
You know, at the end, I get...
At least I get to see him at the end.
I beat question mark, question mark.
Okay.
That's good, actually.
Wait, hold the cast.
Wait, hold...
Wait, I... Two, right?
Two.
Okay.
At least I get to see the boss this time.
Okay, I think I have enough.
I have no more death defiances.
That was my last one.
At least I get to see it.
Oh, hey!
Hey, Hermes.
Okay, um...
What the fuck is this?
Oh, Death Defiance.
I mean, if we're Death Defiance,
and...
I'll talk to you.
Okay, I can buy a Deftify's schedule armor or pub.
I don't...
Don't give me HP, so that's...
I'm a little scared.
Oh, Father of all monsters.
Oh, God, that's why it looks like that.
Oh, he's not going to give me anything.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Guys.
Armor or double palm.
Do you think armor?
I think armor.
The plus $5 is not going to save it.
Armor and Hera?
Or Palm?
All right, let's go.
Okay.
I have...
Okay, so I don't have two for Hestia.
Does that still count?
Okay.
This is a little weird, bad.
No, it doesn't, right?
I need...
Oh, my God.
I just...
Oh, that sucks!
Okay.
Oh.
One.
All right, here we go.
At least I can see him, you know?
I don't know.
I don't think I'm going to beat him, but I get to see him.
Let's see what he looks like.
What?
Oh, Jesus.
Okay, I don't know his patterns, dude.
That's the worst part.
Yeah.
Let's just do this, I think.
Oh my god.
Yeah, this...
It's just another foe.
Jesus!
What the?
Fuck!
Alright.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is so bad.
It's so bad.
This is so bad for me, guys.
oh my god take the food cat wake up oh my are
you kidding me oh my god what the fuck
oh my god what's
going on.
Oh, God.
No!
I'm dead.
I was so close.
I've trained to slay Kronos, not the father of all Oh my
god, we were just there.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
We were so close.
There was like so many projectiles, yeah.
Go for a jog.
That seems nice.
Having legs.
Getting the heart rate going.
Oh, that was so many projectiles.
I think I could do it.
Next run.
I think the next run I could do it, actually.
Make something with my hands.
They all hit so hard.
I didn't realize that he would slam his fucking face down.
And he doesn't show his HP.
Take care, Dwayne.
If I may.
My sisters told me of a certain prophecy even I thought
would never come to pass.
That Olympus would once again face the fury of the father of
all monsters.
And their conflict would shake the world to its core.
And now it's happening.
How many faces does he have, though?
How many?
How many phases is this?
Yeah, it was a real possibility.
Why didn't you warn us?
We could have prepared.
That was it?
Okay, guys, okay.
If I can't do it next run, I call it.
I call it for next stream.
Though perhaps your implication is correct, and this is all
my fault.
What?
How is this all your fault?
Unless you aided Kronos in awakening the most notorious
fiend, the gods of faced i don't see how you had anything to
do with this unraveling a fateful bond i abetted your plans
to gain the surface the awakening of typhoon oh my god it
was the first time i thought of to defy the fates princess
that's why i didn't realize he would slam me if i knew i
wouldn't be up close not you what the does picking these up
even give me on black wings does the uncontrollable
embodiment of strife go wheresoever she may please and
lately that is often in the princess of the underworld's way
oh i can sell them okay making things the way they used to
be you especially you don't even know what you're missing
we're trying to see i should have used the omega cast but i
was panicking too because this is my first time fighting
again so i was like what the fuck does everything do All of
you are so obsessed with there being a point to everything.
You do know there isn't one, don't you?
Can't just let loose and have a good time.
All right.
Not under the present circumstances, no.
No, I am definitely not letting loose right now.
I'm fucking stressed.
All right.
Got the Sandine life springs.
Let's grab some.
Oh, God, I hate these fruits.
I hate this goddamn pitumer fruit.
Fruits are, like, not it.
Okay, I should have...
How much ashes do I...
Wait, do I have enough now?
I should have enough now, right?
Okay.
I want to get rid of...
I don't want to get rid of this.
Okay.
Okay, this should work now.
I mean, chat.
shadow.
Okay.
I can level- I don't think I have any more to level up.
I have one.
I need five.
I can't.
That almost worked try him!
Hamis told me everything.
Save what was going through your head.
I was not about to tell you.
my back on my family especially not after having come so far
what should i have done flee at the first sight of that
monster we flee that we do and you best keep reminding
yourself of yeah but i almost killed them though again do
not take unnecessary risks or lose sight of the task oh yeah
there's no back for that guy we do as we must wait what do i
make oh the shadow okay i can
and wait what do i need shadow again for chat
fabric i can't oh wait i'm broke never mind oh bigger deck
okay i reached the summit of olympus finally they're
fighting back against typhon himself perhaps you knew
already guys it's a little oof can even i don't have god if
only i guys i literally needed like two more
I just needed two more All right, I'm gonna upgrade the
staff that actually was so good for me the Cersei staff or
not sorry the moments
Should I get more should I upgrade the moments guys?
So where is it All right, I'll create it okay i have i have
the upgraded staff i forgot about nemesis she's so
forgettable has to deal with typhon huh wonder if chronos
made a deal with him or just revived and set him loose
either way when like that takes a lot of guts you sound
rather impressed i'm certain chronos would welcome you into
his ranks as well if you just tell him how you really feel
hit a nerve fine doesn't change the fact our enemy
outsmarted us so no need to keep wasting your time up top
wait you're not going to try and fight that thing are you
you really think I'm going to leave my family on Olympus to
face that monster on their own you don't know me at all all
right here we go one last run if I don't get it on this run
we we had to bed uh we got the money oh okay money first
what is this
all right mind telling all these shades that know the father
of all monsters isn't back because they're so caught up with
this outrageous rumor they don't buy it when i tell them
commander the thing is i confronted typhon himself just last
night while chrono schemes from the underworld night
monstrosity attacks a Jesus Christ.
Oh, I, uh, I knew all that.
It's just...
Are we lock in?
You fucking lock in.
We got this, guys.
To stand up for that which they truly believed.
And they did.
Nice going, everyone.
Okay, we can do this.
Yeah.
All right, we locked in for the final countdown.
Going up.
This is it.
This is...
It's ride or die.
The warrior's sigil.
What?
Oh, Athena?
I was beginning to think this one would never show his face.
In the name of his...
Wait, who's this?
Aris?
Oh, I finally got Aris?
Oh, my God.
It's been...
Who did he kill?
Oh, it's because I met Typhon.
Get his attack?
Oh, God.
Please give me the attack.
I don't know what his attack is, but...
actually gets... Oh, never mind.
I don't have its attacks.
Um...
We want special then?
May spill?
Also restores.
Oh, may spill.
Is there three good?
One or three?
So what is it?
Three is better?
Okay, we'll try three.
Three.
Oh god, I need to get this house.
There.
Alright, nice.
Uh, oh, fishing.
Alright.
Chaos time.
Yeah, early chaos too.
Which is good.
I'm doing is that the fate's based upon you proved inspiring
to me.
After some consideration, I discovered how to call upon you
even from the surface of this world all right cast deals 30
damage your champ pyromus
i don't know two or three 50 faster all right this is all
dragon does this dragon build i'm not using my brain right
now i do that i all right guys i will be in charge of not
dying you guys are in charge of making my build because I
cannot think right now I moved I control PC you use brain
all right let's see hammer oh we'll talk to NPC first
yeah you're gonna ride to me a solitary seeker of profane
mysteries conducts takings beneath a pale distant boom it's
a it's ratatouille time hey she won't take my gift returns
not had your fill of this putrescent atmosphere or merely
not succeeded yet in breaking the titan stage i guess i
don't as quickly as olympus can repel them have you found
any weaknesses in their ranks they cannot be permanently
slain are barely susceptible to my most noxious poisons and
are single-minded in their devotion to the titan lord any of
those sound like weaknesses
okay one to nine hundred five if you think like time falls
you take that oh plus five wait i will have so much magic by
then what is pure gem all right guys
Is it like one foe or every foe?
Three is so much.
One thousand mana endgame.
Okay, okay.
Let's get a thousand mana, guys.
I'm grateful, lady.
Alright, let's see.
Three, I hate Kava.
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Uh, we'll grab Moon.
Yeah, we'll grab Moon and then we'll grab the hammer.
I forgot to gift again.
Ha ha ha ha!
Fucking damn it.
There's my target.
Alright, we gotta get this actually.
Wait, wake up.
God, what hit me?
Oh my god, I forgot it's a goddamn chaos.
I was like, what the fuck hit me?
Okay, wake up.
Good evening.
Alright, what summons do I get?
That foolish Titan.
He is awakened Typhon, the most terrible monstrosity that
ever lived.
They still bear my scars from when we first clashed very
long ago.
Together, we did vanquish him before.
We shall have to manage it again.
That should be easy, right?
Oh my god, health.
Health, right?
Health over...
Oh.
Healing?
Three?
Alright, three.
I'll do that.
Whoops.
Any fish is here?
No.
Oh, no.
I can...
Yeah, I think I'm okay.
Oh, nice.
There's a room.
It's always good.
Nice, alright.
Money!
Oh, wait, magic!
Okay, magic!
I almost left the room there.
Alright.
Go out.
Alright, where are the bats?
I don't know where to go.
Oh, hammer.
Yeah, we wanted a hammer.
What the?
ugly and i require neither assistance nor witnesses sister
why is he gonna fight me and i'm not leaving here until the
traitors to the house of hades like broken at our feet
oh no oh no he's gonna kill steal me oh my god he get the
cat i've got the cat
okay we just gotta make sure he doesn't kill steal he's
gonna make sure he doesn't kill steal guys are you okay it's
okay okay oh no i already don't have magic i already oh my
god
where's my cat cat
holy okay it's okay i'm taking a lot of damage but it's okay
there you go yay money hundred dollars one hundred gold
though by my good grace is granted but first I've seen
somebody stand against the filth that's overtaken this
accursed town I aim to cleanse the filth down to the source
he resides deep in the underworld though I've business to
attend to on olympus first what a coincidence i just
returned from there not long ago so the gods are putting all
the pieces into place you watch yourself sister i go oh i
have a gift for you oh okay i guess he doesn't want my gift
okay that's fine i don't need your good body
100 damage to armor.
Oh, wait.
All of these are really good, chat.
Oh.
Alright.
Brain time.
Yeah, it does.
Hold to... It affects my Omega.
Do I do I get it?
Okay, too.
I just say you guys will be my brains.
I'm not going to think here.
A pylon's remaining.
Alright.
You guys said Alright, we have three more I guess we'd go
Eris Then
Oh god, okay, that scared me That'll be careful Oh my god,
I'm just on fire I'm just on fire Okay, it's fine Let's get
you someplace Safe
Alright Alright Yay.
Oh, here we go.
We wanted this one, right?
That's what we wanted.
All right.
Two?
Two better?
Two better than one?
Chat!
You guys were telling me to get one before.
Two is better rarity.
Through his bed.
Alright, we'll grab that then.
I got spammed two more then.
They were wrong.
Alright, two left.
What was the last two?
Chat.
We have Hera, Demeter, Magic, Aphrodite, and Hermes.
Hermes next?
Alright, I'm heading over.
Good.
Let's see.
Okay.
I need gold.
I gotta grab the gold.
Nice free money.
Okay, Hermes time.
I gotta be careful here.
Oh my god.
I don't want to say I gotta be careful here about.
I somehow keep forgetting.
fucking kidding me okay that's the last one changed you can
now be sure what grabs had planned for us but bad news is
it's typhon and he's big but my pops often once so how hard
could it yeah how can it be it shouldn't be that hard your
moves are faster i do cast a lot but we had that money all
right think dragoos think
All right.
Okay.
You guys had thought.
All right, guys.
One last one.
The barrier is almost down.
Last one.
I'm going to drink the fountain.
I don't trust myself.
I...
Oh, my God.
Not him.
Oh god, a fucking course.
Oh my god, I accidentally healed.
I thought...
Are you fucking...
Okay.
It's okay.
I keep...
I thought I was the...
For some reason, I thought I was the...
I was the...
What's the call?
I was the summons.
Oh my god, a fucking course.
Get over here.
Get over here, cat.
To the now.
It's okay.
We made it.
Got you.
I thought it was the summon, so I went and used it here.
Recycle, thank you for the gift of ship, thank you.
Thank you!
Because I'm tired!
That's why I'm making you thick!
It's been eight hours!
Alright.
Choose!
Think for me!
Think, Dragoons!
Think!
But we're tired, too.
I'm outsourcing right now.
I'm gonna outsource.
Alright, one.
I accept this gift.
I had not, I only got one extra room in all of this.
That's crazy.
Can't you get another found?
Oh, no, I can't.
Alright, shop time before we fight the Cyclops.
Go Tula Go Tula Nice Grab the palm upgrade now Alright I
assume wound right Wound is always good
Or one
I see more twos than one So I'll go with two Alright Oh I
assume Arctic Ring Oh uses your charge attack one two three
three all right three kill some weeds the mountain of the
gods my lord though I missed you up there I never thought
I'd see a place you couldn't reach by boat you have a very
good side class time hello I'm back Do you know who's
disrespected me like this?
Nope.
Yes, well, sometimes we have no one to blame but ourselves.
Nobody's gonna pay for all that someday.
But who's nobody?
Wait, what?
What did I do?
Oh, wait, the sheep is alive on his...
Oh, the sheep is, like, sleeping on his back.
I just noticed that.
I thought it was like...
God damn it I thought it was like I thought it was a dead
sheep You know
Okay, we'll grab this Oh, God Okay, it's 5 Okay, we do cast
here And another, oh, oh, I'm fucking running I gotta get to
mana regen Okay, the only thing we're missing right now is
mana regen For sure
Yeah, we definitely need mana regen.
Oh fuck, I didn't even...
I wasn't paying attention.
That's fine, we have... we have him.
Okay.
Let's grab him out of here.
Alright, that's fine.
Okay.
I'll be careful now.
Oh, wait, I do have mana regen.
So it's win.
Oh, plasma redrop, yeah.
I forgot about the plasma.
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't die.
Thank God I didn't use my Deftify.
I was worried.
I was worried about the Deftify and shit.
Now...
uh get that one and i'll get tooth later yeah we get it con
yeah we'll get the yeah we'll get con cave stone and then
water okay we need hp cross a foul smelling hovel crudely
furnished with okay all these dead bodies let's go slated
decay all right back to the boat we go okay we need to grab
hp we are very very very Very, very weak.
Yeah.
That nice.
I grabbed some more snakes.
Ashes, boys.
I need to remember that I have heals now and not...
I wake up.
Wake up.
And not summoning.
I always forget that I don't have summons.
Okay, transform.
God.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
I need the money anyway.
I'm poor.
It's just okay.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
We need the money.
We're not doing so well in the economy.
The economy's been very rough, guys.
I don't know if I have enough damage, though.
Oh, hey.
Nice.
We actually needed HP.
Whoops.
Where's the other guy?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, that's good.
We needed that.
Activated.
Uh...
Up we uh...
Alternate attack in special.
Alright.
Try.
Alright, wake up!
Oh shit!
Wake up!
Okay.
Oh, nice.
You want to make sure I'm not missing anything here?
Nice, another...
Another Ares, too.
Which is good.
Need another Ares.
Right now.
Oh, no, I ran out.
Oh, where are the orbs?
Where are the mana regen?
There you go.
Yeah!
I!
Yes!
I got too excited.
Cast crates over each flow in the binding circle I got too
excited.
I was like, yay!
Okay.
Three.
For the captain's wheel.
Boy, Ash.
What the fuck?
I hit the big cast.
Come on!
Are you serious?
There it is.
Jesus Christ, that did so much damage on me.
Another Ares?
What am I going to do?
Oh, I'm like, oh, fuck.
Okay, that's fine.
What am I going to do with all this Ares?
Okay, this is not cool.
It's not cool.
Okay, we got it.
Oh, my God.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Bro, okay.
Holy shit, he's so hard.
Okay, there you go.
I'll take the helm from here.
I lost the Deft of Guides.
Okay, now I can gift.
Lord Ares, I know mortal warriors often would make offerings
to you before their battles to the death.
I likewise wish to pay you my respects.
Maybe if I gift him something, I can bribe him for some- a
good- I can bribe him for like a good upgrade.
Alright, nice.
Alright, let's see if bribery works.
Olympus, I accept this message.
I don't know.
I've never had Ares before.
Three?
All right.
Oh shit, nice.
Got the double at least.
Oh, and I get to talk to...
Uh...
Is that Cersei?
Yeah, Cersei.
Oh, I already gifted, though.
That ancient isle on which a great enchantress plies a
trade.
I like the that pig over there.
That pig's seen things.
This pig has seen things.
Oh he has a tattoo too!
So what is even happening there at the mountain of the gods?
Some nights, great plumes of flame appear on the horizon and
storm clouds, terrible as ever.
The source of these phenomena is a two-pronged assault on
Mount Olympus.
The Titan Prometheus and his raiders and the monster Typhon
himself.
I'm headed to face them.
Good heavens you mean face them all, Puppet.
Although perchance the perils you confront beneath them.
The earth are even worse.
Let me protect you then as best I can.
Alright.
And grow in size.
Not okay.
Do it.
Guys.
I don't know if I can survive.
Two?
Two.
Okay.
Okay, guys, will it lead me to, will it lead me to victory?
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my, I swear to God, guys, if we die because we picked
you, I swear to God, we're a giant woman now.
More hitbox.
Let's go.
Oh my god, it's already looking very rough.
Okay.
Am I slower, too?
I can't tell.
New course needs to be set.
Ash, as always.
Jesus.
Alright, it's fine.
Okay.
A lot of shit going on right now.
On my screen.
Now for the last one.
Holy fuck, that was a lot on my screen.
I got very confused.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I am so confused.
There's a lot on my screen.
Alright, shop tab.
Oh, that one was stressful.
Yeah.
I can afford everything.
That's three, right?
Alright, Bray.
What are you gonna- what do you want, Bray?
What do you want?
Yeah
We're not spoken Aries time We need moon we need a moon
upgrade bad Whoa trouble you're huge like you and nemi had a
child which come to think of it is just about the worst
thing I've ever imagined and I've imagined a lot Then
imagine what I'm about to do to you in this I'm really
afraid of the if we're if we make it to olympus i'm afraid
of that world of the bosses at the fight there you mean
that's the difference between you and me you need somebody
to teach you everything while i've got pure instinct you got
a gun that's not fair i wasted that
this is not fair you got a gun this is not fair
wake up
Oh no.
Oh no, I just noticed it's also fucking red.
Okay, so I...
Don't have...
Alright, there we go.
Oh my god, fuck me.
Wake up.
Fucking kill me.
Okay, I have this.
Like, I'll just stay here.
And then wake up.
Okay.
Wake up.
God damn it.
Okay, that's fine.
Wake up.
Where is she?
Oh my god, that's close.
Oh, where is she going?
Are you fucking kidding me?
There you go.
What you gonna do now?
Yes!
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
All right, we're good.
She didn't summon anything, too.
That's good.
She never learned.
Oh, she didn't summon anything.
That's good for me.
All right.
Off we go, Prometheus time.
Okay, we gotta get the Tooth now.
Prometheus time.
Water, Tooth.
Oh, yeah.
Tooth.
We need it.
We need HP.
What's the?
Which palm does so the magic gives me more HP?
Which one was it?
Okay.
Which god does that for me?
I'm here, bitch.
I do not like how much it's costing me.
Hef for Aphrodite, okay.
It's good to know.
Uh, we'll get palm.
All right, let's hope we bump into a hef then.
Oh my god, are you fucking...
Okay, okay, close enough.
Close enough.
We were almost there.
Yeah, oh my god, it's okay.
We have this.
There you go.
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh god, oh my god.
She can't get me.
He can't get... Oh my god, he's stuck.
It was Where is it?
He was stuck.
Straightforward.
He is.
Thank God.
Touched him.
Stupid bird.
Yeah.
Stupid fucking bird.
Alright.
I need more mana.
Okay.
Follow your senses.
What?
Oh yeah.
Now.
Uh, hammer time.
Alright, this should get locked.
There you go.
Jesus Christ.
I do that, and then...
There you go.
Oh yeah, no, we're fucking...
We're gonna...
We're gonna lock this guy down fast.
Okay, we got...
Where's my cat?
I feel like I'm always, like, trying to find my cat.
Oh, there he is.
That's, like, where the fuck did he go?
Alright.
Attacks have more range.
Your channel.
Oh.
Wait.
Three, right?
Three.
Deskira grows in strength.
Anything I'm missing?
Oh, moon.
Fuck.
Okay.
What?
What was the talking one again?
Moon or moon upgrade or NPC?
I don't remember what the NPC was.
I met so many NPCs.
Oh, Dio.
Alright, moon or Dio, guys?
Dio is useful.
Okay, we'll grab Dio then.
We'll party.
It's time to party.
It's yester time.
Well, hey.
The gods apparently is concentrated.
I don't have another gift.
I don't have another nectar.
I would if I could.
Does anyone have any spare nectar?
Hey,
look who decided to reconsider coming to our little
gathering.
Welcome back, Mel, baby.
Now go on.
You grab yourself a cup and mingle with the crowd.
Is he supposed to be, like, awesome powers?
Baby.
Unfortunately, I don't think I can.
There are various perils beyond.
And your fellow Olympians can only do so much to hold them
off.
Oh my god, they the Greeks invented the disco ball I feel
bad for them really all mighty gods with limitless power
having to fend for themselves Good thing I can drown my
sorrows here and guess what what the fuck?
That's I didn't know.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe the Greek gods invented disco
Being stronger about in it
Three.
Oh, baby.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Hef.
Wait.
Okay.
Do we risk getting Hef for the chance that we get the
percentage magic shit or we get HP?
We play safe.
Do we take the Gambo or we play safe?
Gambo or safe?
safe.
Gamba all right.
Gamba time.
Guys, I don't even know which one.
Did I got two?
Three or two, guys.
Does anyone remember?
Guys, I sort of don't remember if I took two or three.
We, I just need the cast thing and then my build is really
good.
Okay, I took three.
Okay.
Oh, and I grabbed this too.
I could find You've seen the size of the bloody monster Been
clamoring up our mountainside, would you?
I am, thankfully, but Hearing that he's pretty big in size
Typhoon himself A scarce can keep a steady hand with him
about Oh, damn it
Okay, we didn't get the magic The gamba We lost the gamba
chat we lost the gamba
all right oh but okay wait wait we can get hp here i'm gonna
grab hp here i don't think we need to meet her right now we
actually really need health right health time i
still streamer luck is still here how many death defiance
i've defiance cat and me.
Health tab.
Yeah, I feel like we really need it.
We're a bit poor in the health department.
Oh my god, it doesn't even kill him.
That sucks.
It doesn't even kill him.
Oh my god.
Okay, what we really need is moon right now.
We really need moon power.
I have not upgraded my moon yet.
It's pretty bad.
Nice.
okay good oh my god there's so much stuff on my screen guys
i don't know i don't think god okay oh we got divine
intervention thank god
you've seen what plagues us at the summit haven't you the
source of all the tremors almost as though the mountain
itself quakes with fear we need a plan the gods have stood
against typhon wasn't it a well-placed yeah from zeus just
let zeus do that again tales of valor and deeds of valor i
mean that hard right then let us lure this typhon toward the
summit where our strength combined with yours is the best
opportunity we have
okay but i prime 150 okay but i do get a lot of prime though
i get i do get now i get four if I and can momentarily
deflect is that good I guess it is it's top tier okay I
believe in you guys oh I got heff again wait but I do have I
do have enough money I think this okay is this the last room
I can't tell how do you tell it oh location 36 is that the
last room or no no Alright, then we do heff, I guess.
Alright, chopper boss, guys.
Heff, okay.
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh, just attack me right away.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, okay.
That's cool.
Where's my cat?
I always try to find my cat.
Where is he?
oh my god okay that's cool i feel like i'm always trying to
find my cat like where did he go okay okay he's sleepy again
eepe that's okay that's guys i had to wake him up oh my god
i got healed it's 15 hp but that's okay
okay that's fine
Oh my god.
I really mean moon power guys
Yeah God damn it Oh Don't have a lot of heals I've not
bumped into moon yet Which is not good You see that Icarus
flying about at first I took him with some giant ghost Oh,
goddammit, still not it?
No duel.
Still no health thing.
Goddammit.
None of these are...
Yeah, no duel out of it.
Icarus was just like, fuck you, I guess.
I lost the Gamma.
Yeah, I've always lose armor.
so fast oh
man you guys are not a hive mind for this you're not high
mind right now i don't like this
guys you're not high man what the fuck do i pick
uh three okay safety okay oh hey f again wait maybe Third
time's the charm?
Third time's the charm!
We gather again.
Oh, God.
I'm just gonna go here.
Okay, oh, this is bad for me.
Wait, wake up.
Jesus Christ!
Okay, it's fine.
It's okay.
From the forge.
Alright, third time's the...
Guys, we're not...
Guys, um...
Okay, okay, we might...
Okay, it's fine.
Third time was not it.
Third time was not the charm.
I see more twos than ones at the moment.
One or twos?
All right, one.
Yeah, see, I've already lost all my armor.
Look at that.
It's already gone.
Okay.
I guess I'll grab money.
I'll grab money just in case.
I don't think I need more magic.
Like, I feel like I've already fucking grinded so much
magic.
Right?
I'll let them fight.
Yeah!
Alright, I gotta get my cat.
Wake up!
It's time to fight, cat!
Goodness.
Wake up, cat!
Oh, Maka already took away all my armor.
My armor's already gone.
And it's gone.
I have money.
What have...
Is this the last room now?
This is the last room, right?
Yeah?
Okay, shop then.
Alright, let's shop then.
Moon?
Oh, thank god.
Okay, it's just one moon, but that's fine.
I need, like, something.
Okay.
You deal plus 50.
Grant, you're using value.
grounds plus three uses of your heads or hex if you see
yourself uses left okay uh we can grab that I feel like plus
five is much better
plus ten plus ten all right yeah plus three right
is there one more fountain after this though yeah
grab this one with selene yeah there's still one more oh oh
but expires faster i don't know if that's good all right you
guys pick
two two okay off i go all right here i go is prometheus time
what do you know i was too anyway i forgot what i'm thinking
i told you guys i'm not thinking right now i i'm just do i
do oh dash okay it's dash it's dash i didn't think that's
like what the fuck did i pick i
I You guys don't understand?
I do.
I don't think that's your job Well, if you truly think you
can withstand that monster.
It's like Prometheus is Oh,
God.
Oh, God.
Oh, God It's someone saved me
Okay, that's fine
Okay Oh my god, my armor.
It's gone.
Okay.
Prometheus says.
I can't.
Okay, it works, though.
That should not have worked, but it did.
Okay.
I almost messed that up.
Yeah, no, that's true.
Not have work.
I almost fucked that up.
Okay, wake up.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
Where's my cat?
Oh my god, are you serious?
Cat.
Oh my god again.
Oh my god.
okay jesus oh my god that's so close okay top middle top top
middle top top oh top middle top i forgot okay
okay oh shit middle wake up wake up we need you to wake up
right now oh god damn it okay that's fine that is not fine
it's not no longer fine holy fuck it's no longer fine guys
i might have to use another depth of violence i have a
feeling
oh god but i don't want it to be over
okay oh god not god not the eagle not the eagle
not the eagle it's all is the god damn eagle holy fuck Oh my
god, and my cat is like not even with me
Oh god Oh god Yeah, yes, oh too.
Okay.
I still have I still have one more death defiance Oh
So that coming.
Oh my god.
It's my tooth though, isn't it?
Oh no My last death defiance is my tooth even the intense
heat rising from the mountain i can't switch can entirely
dispel the chill here in the air a gathering storm not
wrought by gods but something else something friendly oh no
that is not good for me right now Okay, I could either get
Typhon or Tooth, but I don't know.
Yeah, Lingua Super Chat, they could think.
Yeah, no, I like this.
This game is fun.
Okay, Tooth or Evil?
Tooth?
I gotta make it over there.
I have to make it over.
No, I didn't get this before.
Okay.
I gotta make it over there.
I think it's tuftab I think it's tuftab I have to travel so
far Yeah, no you guys are right No, I have to get through
the alien world
caught okay I gotta fight the aliens To all our family
welcome I don't think Guys, I don't think I'm gonna make it,
guys.
I do not feel very confident.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
Alright.
Here we go.
Guys, maybe.
Third.
Guys, four times the charm.
Or moon.
Four.
Four times.
Okay.
This time.
Moon or Gamba.
Guys.
Chat.
Oh.
Oh my god, it's split.
It's split between the two.
Heal, then Gamba.
Heal, okay.
We got the plus 25.
All right.
Maybe we can get it to this.
Oh, no.
Wait, I don't like...
Wait a minute.
Wait, I don't...
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait.
I don't think I like these two.
Oh, where's my cat?
What the fuck is going on?
Okay.
I don't know what's going on.
Oh, my God.
I got healed again.
I think that's the last one.
Okay.
That's fine.
Okay, it's fine.
There we go.
Oh.
They're easy.
Yeah, this one was easy.
Okay.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
I heal.
Because
we gotta stop gambling, guys.
We gotta...
Guys, we gotta...
Guys, guys, I don't think we...
Guys, I think...
I think we might have to stop gambling, guys.
I never stop ever.
I think the house is winning.
I think the house is winning, guys.
Just get three.
Do we get three?
One, two, or three?
Three?
All right.
I see more people.
Same three.
All right.
more people pick three oh my it's fine I have the goddamn
armor shit going on so I can take shit for now but I am so
fucking confused what is going on on my screen I there is a
lot of things going on on my screen right now and I'm
worried there you go all right up I go
I do think that maybe, maybe we gambled a little too much,
but that's just a little game theory.
I could be wrong.
Obviously, I could be wrong.
Coin for Karon.
Okay, Palmer Demeter.
There's never enough gamma.
Yeah, I want to get rid of that.
I see more palms.
What is this?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck am I?
What the fuck?
Okay.
It's very slow, though.
Oh, it's not even over.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
I was like, we did it, guys.
And then it's not even over.
I was like, oh my god, guys.
That was so fast.
Yeah, man, let's go.
All right, he's coming back.
Okay, that is a lot of shit I have to fucking be aware of.
All right.
It's no use.
I have to do this.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Okay, this is taking a long time.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's not good.
not good for me I don't know how I took so much damage there
oh my god are you fucking oh fuck okay this is really bad
for me this is really bad I'm gonna use my death defiance
here no don't okay this is bullshit oh god I want to just
mine this.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, is this body up?
Oh my god, I didn't realize.
I didn't realize the body was up during that.
I thought I had to kill the eye.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
I didn't see that.
I thought the eye was the boss.
Yeah.
Yeah, if I knew, I would focused on him yeah i learned for
next time
well i have no death to i have no no death defiance now
all right i have enough though okay that sucks the enemies
of all seeing typhon cannot possibly escape his rinker for
his that sucks oh if i knew i wouldn't have fucking did that
i would have of like shot him first.
Oh, hey.
I'm like a fish, I guess.
Some assistance, please.
Oh, nice Deft of Finds.
Nice.
Okay.
We actually need that.
I feel like I failed you here.
I was supposed to figure out what Gramps was up to, but I
wasn't quick enough.
So now you're fighting Typhon face to face.
This won't be a 10-hour stream.
Almost 10 hours later.
I mean, thank you for the Magenta but they look look i have
perfectly good excuse okay they're so close we're actually
so close to beating the game than the past i know you're
right it's just i'm starting to accept that all of this is
what gramps wanted to achieve first capture the three fates
so they can't mess with him then wake up typhon so he can
mess with us then take you didn't know all the details but
long since figured out kronos was up to something big had
you not acted swiftly then i wouldn't be here now wait we're
not doing a hundred percent guys i just want an ending i for
guarantees the chances m but hey you're right we do the best
we can with what we've got all right we'll grab armor short
up all right guys which one guys the meter i mean they're
both demeanor and then air eris or the meter the meter i'll
do first.
How much we got?
We got a lot of money.
Okay, but Heph's like in a wheelchair, bro.
Like, he's out there, like, building shit.
Like, he doesn't want to do anything.
Oh, shit.
Hello.
Oh, my God.
Thank God I do.
Yeah, he doesn't want any of this shit, bro.
Chill.
all right okay oh
wait that's so good because that's gonna be me too okay
we'll do too all right left or right oh wait no I can only
afford one yeah I don't have enough all right left or right
guys I
see you right all right
Alright.
Okay.
Three.
Alright.
This is gonna be much more risky of a cast because I have to
run at him.
It's gonna be a lot riskier than before.
Because
like...
It's like it.
It's my temporary hits.
Oh my god, this is not...
It's already not looking so good, guys.
Okay.
I can't!
Where's my cat?
I need to grab my cat.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This is not good for me.
This is not good for me, guys.
Okay, this time.
Oh God Wake up wake up
Oh God oh God oh
This is so bad
Please cat Oh God
It's not I don't know when he does that attack sometimes
okay
okay okay that's fine
okay wake up wake up
wake up wake up No!
Wake up!
Oh my god.
Please wake up.
Please wake up!
Oh god.
Guys, it's not looking good.
Okay.
Oh my god, I tried to...
Oh my god, too.
Those three...
I got hit by the three legs because I couldn't figure out...
I couldn't see the pattern for that.
So, how's it going on Olympus recently?
What if you do one more?
There was so much to keep track of.
Every time the tongue came up, I was not looking for it.
I was not aware of the tongue.
The tongue?
fucking if I didn't get hit by it guys I can't I can't I'm
tired I gotta call it we'll be in next week I'm tired oh my
the five time gamble on hip was not it the five time gamble
on fucking hip was not it It was just, it was just not, not
it, guys.
Goddess.
Oh my god.
Alright guys, we're gonna call it here.
Alright, I want, I feel like I could beat him, like, after
the next run, but, like, I'm tired.
I want to eat food.
I want to make my, my bulldog do this.
So I'm gonna call it here, guys.
And I'm gonna push the, to, sorry, technically today's
stream.
um 30 minutes later guys because i i want to i want to get
more sleep in chat so i'm gonna make it start at one instead
uh or 1 30 i'll push it in an hour later i'm gonna push it
to 1 30 instead because i that's a long stream anyways as
always everybody say hi really pause to check out and move
around and get that blood flowing you still for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys i'm so tired guys i i wish i had the
energy for one more run but no this i gotta tap out i'm
tapping out here i'm tapping out bye-bye guys bye